ASSEMBLY MEMBER PETRIE-NORRIS
NOTICES THE ABSENCE OF A QUORUM.
THE SERGEANTS AT ARMS WILL
PREPARE THE CHAMBER AND BRING
THE ABSENT MEMBERS AND THE CLERK
WILL CALL THE ROLL.
AGUIAR-CURRY ARAMBULA.
OUR QUE HAN BERMAN.
BIGELOW.
BLOOM.
BURNER **** BATH.
BONTA [inaudible]
ROW [inaudible]
BURKE [inaudible]
CALDERON CARILLO [inaudible]
CERVANTES CHAU [inaudible]
CHEN.
DAVID CHIU.
CHOI [inaudible]
KANSEN CHU [inaudible]
COOLEY [inaudible]
COOPER [inaudible]
CUNNINGHAM [inaudible]
DALY [inaudible]
DEEP [inaudible]
EGGMAN [inaudible]
FLORA [inaudible]
FONG [inaudible]
FRAZIER [inaudible]
FRIEDMAN.
GABRIEL.
GALLAGHER CRISTINA GARCIA.
I WONDER GARCIA [inaudible]
GIPSON.
GLORIA GONZALEZ IS GRAY.
GRAYSON HOLDEN.
IRWIN JONES SAWYER [inaudible]
KALRA KAMLAGER-DOVE [inaudible]
KILEY.
LACKEY LEVINE.
LIMON [inaudible]
LOW.
MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS MAYES MCCARTY
MEDINA MELENDEZ MULLIN.
MURATSUCHI NAZARIAN.
OBERNOLTE O'DONNELL PATTERSON
PETRIE-NORRIS QUIRK QUIRK SILVA.
RAMOS RAY IS THREE OF US ROBERT
RIVAS.
RODRIGUEZ RUBIO [inaudible]
SALAS SANTIAGO SMITH.
STONE.
TEEN [inaudible]
VOEPEL WALDRON WEBER WICKS WOOD
MISTER SPEAKER
.
MEMBERS PLEASE REPORT TO THE
FLOOR AS SOON AS PRACTICABLE
WITH A VERY HEAVY LOAD OF BILLS
TODAY.
PLEASE REPORT TO THE FLOOR.
AS SOON AS POSSIBLE
.
A QUORUM IS PRESENT IN THE
ASSEMBLY.
WE HAVE SET OUR GUESTS AND
VISITORS IN THE REAR OF THE
CHAMBER AND IN THE GALLERY.
PLEASE STAND FOR THE PRAYER.
TODAY'S PRAYER.
WILL BE OFFERED BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER KAMLAGER-DOVE.
THIS KAMLAGER-DOVE.
GOOD MORNING MEMBERS.
OVER THE WEEKEND I TOOK MY STEP
DAUGHTER TO VISIT HER FRIEND IN
THE HOSPITAL.
ANGEL WAS RECOVERING FROM A
BLOOD TRANSFUSION.
SHE IS.
FOURTEEN RECENTLY LOST TWENTY
POUNDS.
AND HAS BEEN DIAGNOSED WITH
LUPUS.
IT IS SCARY TO SEE A YOUNG LIFE
STRUGGLE TO WALK.
NEED HELP WITH HER BALANCE.
IN RE LEARN HER FACULTIES.
IT IS EVEN SCARIER TO WONDER HOW
YOU WOULD COPE.
IF SHE WERE YOUR CHILD.
ANGEL IS A YOUNG LIVE WHOSE
HEALTH IS ON THE ROPES.
SHE IS LEARNING TO LIVE WITH A
NEW DISEASE.
WHILE HER MOTHER LEARNS TO FIND
NEW FAITH IN HER GOD.
AND NEW SOURCES OF STRING. TO
BOTH SHIELD AND SUPPORT HER
YOUNG DAUGHTER.
LORD I PRAY. FOR ANGEL AND HER
MOTHER MELANIE.
LET US ALL PRAY FOR THOSE WHO
ARE NEGOTIATING AN ILLNESS.
A LONELINESS OR A LOSS.
LET US ALSO PRAY FOR THOSE WHO
BATTLE FEAR.
FEAR OF LIVING LIFE TO THE
FULLEST.
OF LIVING IN SOMEONE ELSE'S
SHADOW.
OF NOT MEETING ON SPOKE IN OR ON
REAL EXPECTATIONS.
OR JUST FEAR OF LIVING LIFE IN
ONE'S TRUTH [inaudible]
WHY LORD?
BECAUSE IT IS TOO SHORT AND TOO
PRECIOUS. TO BE EXPERIENCED IN
ISOLATION.
WITHOUT LOVE.
AND WHILE AFRAID.
SOMETIMES WE ACT AS IF THE ENEMY
IS THE TRUTH.
BUT OFTENTIMES THE ENEMY IS OUR
FEAR.
LORD LET US NOT BE AFRAID.
LET US NOT BE AFRAID TO HEAR
FROM ALL PERSPECTIVES.
SO THAT WE CAN SHIELD AND
SUPPORT THOSE WHO LIVE IN AND
DEPEND ON CALIFORNIA.
LET US PRAY FOR THE HOUSE AND
THE HOMELESS.
LET US PRAY FOR CHARTER SCHOOLS
AND PUBLIC SCHOOLS.
LET US PRAY FOR LANDLORDS AND
TENANTS.
LET US PRAY FOR HEALTH CARE
PROVIDERS AND PATIENTS.
LET US PRAY FOR LAW ENFORCEMENT
AND THE COMMUNITIES THEY SERVE.
LET US PRAY THAT WE ARE ABLE TO
FIND STRENGTH. TO LIVE LIFE OFF
THE ROPES.
THAT WE ARE ABLE TO FIND THE
BALANCE TO WALK THROUGH LIFE
WITH OUR FACULTIES AND IN OUR
FAITH.
AND THAT WE ARE ABLE TO FIND THE
GRACE TO LOVE THE LIFE THAT WE
ARE GIVEN.
AND THE LIFE THAT WE SHARE.
WITH OTHERS [inaudible]
AMEN.
THANK YOU IS KAMLAGER-DOVE.
WE ASK OUR GUESTS AND VISITORS
TO REMAIN STANDING.
AND JOIN US FOR THE FLAG SALUTE.
PLEASE JOIN ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MEDINA AS HE LEADS US IN THE
PLEDGE MISTER MEDINA.
MEMBERS AND GUESTS PLEASE JOIN
ME IN THE PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE I
PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE.
BY THE STATES OR WHICH IT STANDS.
ONE NATION UNDER GOD INDIVISIBLE
WITH [inaudible]
OR THANK YOU YOU MAY BE SEATED.
READING OF THE PREVIOUS DAY'S
JOURNAL.
ASSEMBLY CHAMBER SACRAMENTO
THURSDAY MAY NINTH TWENTY
NINETEEN THE SALLY MET AT NINE
AM ON OVER BACK OF OUR QUE
HANNAH ASSISTANT SPEAKER PRO TEM
OF THIS ON THE PRESIDING CHIEF
COOKIE DOTSON WILSON AT THE DESK.
READING CLICK KATHLEEN AND LOUIS
READING THE ROLES CALLED.
HER CALDERON MOVES AND MR FONG
SECONDS.
THE READING OF THE PREVIOUS
DAY'S JOURNAL BE DISPENSED WITH.
PRESENTATIONS AMPUTATIONS THERE
ARE NONE.
INTRODUCTION REFERENCE TO BILLS
WILL BE DEFERRED.
REPORTS OF COMMITTEES WILL BE
DEEMED READ AND AMENDMENTS
DEEMED ADOPTED.
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR THERE
ARE NONE MESSAGES FROM THE
SENATE.
THERE ARE NONE.
MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS THE
ABSENCES FOR THE DAY FOR ILLNESS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER KEN COOLEY. FOR
A FUNERAL A DEATH IN THE FAMILY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER EDUARDO GARCIA
[inaudible]
MISTER CALDERON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR PROCEDURAL
MOTIONS THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
AT THE REQUEST OF THE AUTHOR
PLEASE MOVE ITEM TWO FORTY FIVE
A. B. ELEVEN NINETY SIX GIPSON
TO THE INACTIVE FILE.
THE CLERK WILL NOTE
MEMBERS WE
ARE MOVING TO BUSINESS ON THE
DAILY FILE.
ASSEMBLY SECOND READING.
CLOCK RATE.
ASSEMBLY BILL 1-650-609-5217 AND
TEN THIRTY SIX ALL BILLS HAVE
BEEN DEEMED READ AND AMENDMENTS
DEEMED ADOPTED.
MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING TO
CONCURRENCE IN THE SENATE
AMENDMENTS.
THIS IS FILE ITEM NUMBER.
FIVE AB SEVENTY FOUR BY MR TANG
CORKERY.
ASSEMBLY BILL SEVENTY FOUR BY
SOME REMEMBER TING AND ACTUALLY
TO THE BUDGET ACT OF TWENTY
NINETEEN MEMBERS.
PLEASE GIVE YOUR ATTENTION TO MR
TANG MISTER TANK YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AB
SEVENTY FOUR IS OUR ANNUAL
BUDGET BILL -- THIS IS A BILL
THAT I THAT WE ARE ASKING TO BE
SENT INTO THE BUDGET CONFERENCE
COMMITTEE.
SO I AM I AM VOTING YES FOR THE
BILL BUT WE ARE ASKING OUR
MEMBERS TO BE VOTING NOW SO IT'S
A VERY UNUSUAL INSTANCE BECAUSE
THIS IS THE BILL THAT WILL
ACTUALLY BECOME.
WHAT IS THE BUDGET FOR THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA FOR THIS YEAR?
SO WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY I'LL
BE VOTING YES BY MASK AND ALL
ARE ALL OUR COLLEAGUES TO BE
VOTING NO ON THIS BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MEMBERS WE HELP YOU
WERE LISTENING TO MR TANG.
SEE NO DISCUSSION DEBATE.
CLARK WILL OPEN THE ROLE
[inaudible]
MR.
TING IS REQUESTING A NO VOTE.
MISTER KING IS REQUESTING A NO
VOTE FOR NON CONCURRENCE.
MEMBERS THE NO BUTTON IS THE RED.
ONE MISTER CUNNINGHAM KNOWS
WHERE THAT BUTTON IS.
THIS IS A REQUEST FOR A NO VOTE
ON NON CONCURRENCE
.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE [inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSE YOUR ROLE.
ITALIAN VOTE AYE AYES.
ONE KNOWS SIXTY ONE SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE NOT CONCURRED IN.
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO MOVE
EXPEDITIOUSLY TO THE THIRD
READING FILE.
FILE ITEMS SEVEN EIGHT AND NINE
PASS RETAIN.
FILE ITEM NUMBER.
TEN THIS IS AB TWENTY NINE FOR
THE PURPOSE OF AMENDMENTS CLERK
WILL READ.
WITH AMENDMENTS AS SOMETHING
WILL TWENTY NINE WITH AMENDMENTS
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER HOLDEN.
MR HOLDEN ON THE AMENDMENTS.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I AM
PROUD TO PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY NINE FOR PURPOSES OF
AMENDMENTS.
THE BILL REMOVES THE MOST
DISPUTED LAND OF THIS S. R.
SEVEN TEN FROM THE FREEWAY
EXPRESSWAY CODE A LINE IN THE
LAW WITH THE DESIRES OF THE
CITIES.
THESE AMENDMENTS ADDRESS THE
AFFECTED COMMUNITIES CONCERNS BY
INSERTING RELINQUISHMENT
LANGUAGE FOR THE PARTIES TO USE
IF NECESSARY.
AS THE FATE OF THE AREAS DECIDED
FOR THESE REASONS I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
IN TAKING THIS HOLDEN.
WE MAY TAKE A VOICE VOTE ON
THESE AMENDMENTS ALL THOSE IN
FAVOR SAY AYE.
AYE OPPOSED SAY NAY THE AYES
HAVE IT.
THE MEMBERS ARE DOTTED THE
BILL'S HOW TO PRINT AND BACK ON
FILE FILE ITEM ELEVEN PASS AND
RETAIN.
FILE ITEM TWELVE IS AB.
SIXTEEN HUNDRED BY MISTER KALRA.
ASSEMBLY BILL SIXTEEN HUNDRED BY
SOMETHING MEMBER KALRA AND
ACTUALLY TO DISCOVERY.
MISTER KALRA.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY PERCENT THIS
BILL BEFORE YOU TODAY.
THIS BILL WOULD MAKE THREE
CHANGES TO EXISTING PITCHES
MOTION PROCEDURES TO ENSURE
GREATER ACCESS TO DUE PROCESS
AND THE RIGHT TO A SPEEDY TRIAL
FOR PERSONS CHARGED WITH CRIMES.
AS A FORMER DEPUTY PUBLIC
DEFENDER I HAVE EXPERIENCED
FIRST HAND THE CHALLENGE OF
PURSUING A TIME NOT WAIVE JURY
TRIAL OR MY CLIENT HAD THE WAY
THEIR RIGHT TO A SPEEDY TRIAL.
AGAINST HIS OR HER RIGHT TO DUE
PROCESS.
ASSEMBLY IN THIS BILL IT'S AN
EFFORT TO BRING PITCHES MOTION
TIMELINES TO ALIGNMENT WITH THE
REGULAR CRIMINAL DISCOVERY
NOTICE TIMELINES.
AB SIXTEEN HUNDRED WOULD AMEND
THE EVIDENCE CODE TO ALIGN THE
TIME PERIOD OF PITCHES DISCOVERY
MOTIONS WITH THE NOTICE PERIOD
FOR DISCOVERY MOTIONS.
IN CRIMINAL CASES FROM SIXTEEN
DAYS TO TEN DAYS.
THIS IS NOT ONLY BENEFIT DEFENSE
ATTORNEYS BUT PROSECUTORS -- THE
ACT BUT PROSECUTORS ENSURING THE
LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS WHO
USUALLY ACT AS THEIR LEAD
WITNESSES DO NOT HAVE ANY
HISTORY THAT WOULD JEOPARDIZE
THEIR SUCCESSFUL PROSECUTION OF
A CRIMINAL DEFENDANT.
THIS BILL ALSO MAKES A NEEDED
TECHNO CORRECTION OF THE CHANGES
MADE IN SB FOURTEEN TWENTY ONE
FROM LAST YEAR BY ENSURING THAT
COURTS MAY NOT ISSUE A
PROTECTIVE ORDER.
LIMITING THE USE OF RECORDS THAT
HAVE ALREADY BEEN MADE AVAILABLE
UNDER THE PUBLIC RECORDS ACT.
I WANT TO EMPHASIZE THIS POINT
THIS LIMITS THE ABILITY TO IS TO
PROTECT ORDER IF THE PUBLIC
RECORDS WERE OBTAINED PROPERLY
AND WITH THE WITH IN ACCORDANCE
THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC RECORDS
ACT.
LASTLY TO IMPROVE TRANSPARENCY
WOULD ALSO REPEAL RESTRICTIONS
EXEMPTING SUPERVISING OFFICERS
FROM THE DISCLOSURE OF RECORDS
THROUGH A PITCHES MOTION FOR
THEIR PRIOR MISCONDUCT WHEN IT
IS PERTINENT TO A DEFENDANT'S
RIGHT TO DUE PROCESS WHICH MEANS.
PART INTO THE FACTS OF THE CASE
AT HAND NOT OPENING UP RECORDS
FOR A FISHING EXPEDITION.
IT WOULD ALSO -- FOR THE SAME
PROTECTIONS ALONG FOR SOME BY
SUBJECTING THE PITCHES MOTION
FOR SUPERVISING OFFICER RECORDS
THE SAME JUDICIAL SCRUTINY
ALREADY REQUIRED UNDER CURRENT
LAW.
IT WILL BE LIMITED TO WHAT IS
RELEVANT TO THE CASE AS
DETERMINED BY THE JUDGE.
BY MAKING THESE MODEST CHANGES
CALIFORNIA TO MAKE PITCHES
PROCEDURES LESS BURDENSOME AND
TIME CONSUMING WHILE INCREASING
FAIRNESS IN CRIMINAL PROCEEDINGS.
AND PROVIDING GREATER
TRANSPARENCY -- I WAS JUST LAST
WEEK BUT WITH THIS BILL ALREADY
ON THE THIRD READING FILE.
WE RECEIVE LATE OPPOSITION FROM
LA POLICE PROTECTIVE LEAGUE --
BUT GUARDING JUST THE LAST
PROVISIONS THE LEAGUE DOES NOT
HAVE ANY CONCERNS WITH THE OTHER
PROVISIONS OF THE BILL -- WE ARE
IN EARNEST TALKS WITH THE PLEASE
PROUDLY IN NEARING DOES
NARROWING AND CLARIFYING THE
SCOPE ABOUT THIRD ITEM WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THEM AS
THIS BILL GOES THE SENATE.
AND HAVE COMMITMENTS BUT TO TAKE
APART A TAKE ON APPROPRIATE
MOMENTS -- TO ENSURE THAT THE
BILL IS A PROBABLY NARROWED IN
ITS FIRST SENATE COMMITTEE.
BUT THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AIBO.
THANK YOU MISTER KALRA.
IS CUNNINGHAM YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
I RISE TO URGENT AYE VOTE ON
THIS MEASURE BROUGHT FORWARD BY
OUR COLLEAGUE FROM SAN JOSE.
I WANT TO OFFER A LITTLE
PERSPECTIVE FROM SOMEBODY THAT
HAS -- JOINT PITCHES MOTIONS AS
A PROSECUTOR AND ALSO MADE
PITCHES MOTIONS DEFENDING PEOPLE
THERE'S NOTHING MORE FUNDAMENTAL
TO A SIXTH AMENDMENT RIGHT. TO A
JURY TRIAL INTO DUE PROCESS THEN
THE ABILITY TO CROSS EXAMINE
WITNESSES AND THIS IS IMPORTANT
NOT JUST FOR DEFENSE THIS IS
IMPORTANT FOR PROSECUTION
BECAUSE I CAN TELL YOU.
AS A DEPUTY A THE LAST THING YOU
WANT TO DO IS CARRY A CASE FOR
TO A JURY.
NOT KNOWING WHETHER YOU'RE GOING
TO PUT A POLICE OFFICER ON THE
STAND HAS IMPEACHMENT MATERIAL
IN THERE FILE THAT YOU HAVEN'T
GOTTEN ACCESS.
TO THAT'S WHY WE NEED TO SHORTEN
THE TIME FRAME FOR PITCH IS TO
MAKE SURE THAT BOTH DEFENSE AND
PROSECUTION GETS THOSE RECORDS
IN A TIMELY FASHION.
IT'S CONSISTENT WITH DUE PROCESS
I KNOW A LOT OF MY COLLEAGUES ON
OUR SIDE OF THE AISLE ARE
NERVOUS ABOUT THIS BILL -- BUT I
DON'T THINK YOU SHOULD BE I
THINK IT'S A GOOD CHANGE IN LAW
AND I HAVE A COMMITMENT FROM OUR
COLLEAGUE FROM SAN JOSE TO
NARROW THE THIRD PORTION OF IT
IN THE SENATE.
AND CLEAR UP SOME ISSUES THAT I
THINK -- WILL REMOVE OPPOSITION
FROM LAW ENFORCEMENT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISS CUNNINGHAM SEE NO
ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
CARL YOU MAKE CLOTHES IF YOU
WISH.
THANK YOU MISTER NICE WANT THINK
A COLLEGE OF SCIENCE A MISSILE
FROM BRINGING BACK PERSPECTIVE
BOTH AS A PROSECUTOR AND A
DEFENSE ATTORNEY AS YOU
INDICATED -- AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK WHEN I BOUGHT.
THERE WAS KALRA AND WITH THAT
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS OF THE DESIRE TO
VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE
.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE ABOUT
[inaudible]
MR.
KALRA WHAT'S YOUR PLEASURE SIR.
MISTER KALRA MOVES A CALL.
WE ARE FILE ITEM.
THIRTEEN AB THREE THIRTY BY MR
GABRIEL QUICKLY.
ASSEMBLY BILL THREE THIRTY BY
SOMETHING MEMBER GABRIEL AND
OTHERS AND I PLAN TO COURTS.
MR GABRIEL.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I AM
PLEASED TODAY TO PRESENT AB
THREE THIRTY WHICH WOULD EXPAND
THE HIGHLY SUCCESSFUL SARGENT
SHRIVER CIVIL COUNCIL PROGRAMS.
THESE PROGRAMS PROVIDE VITAL
LEGAL REPRESENTATION IN ACCESS
TO JUSTICE TO SOME OF THE MOST
VULNERABLE CALIFORNIANS IN LIFE
CHANGING CIVIL LEGAL MATTERS.
AND I'VE ALSO BEEN PROVEN TO
HELP IMPROVE OUR JUDICIAL SYSTEM.
IN TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN THE
JUDICIAL COUNCIL RELEASED A
RIGOROUS EVALUATION WHICH FOUND
THAT SHRIVER PROGRAMS NOT ONLY
DRAMATICALLY IMPROVED OUTCOMES
FOR LITIGANTS.
BUT THAT THEY ALSO INCREASE
SETTLEMENTS REDUCE COST TO THE
COURT SYSTEM AND PROVIDED
NUMEROUS OTHER EFFICIENCIES AND
BENEFITS.
THE SHRIVER PROGRAM WAS CREATED
WITH BIPARTISAN SUPPORT IN
SIGNED INTO LAW BY GOVERNOR
SCHWARZENEGGER.
AND IT WOULD SEND A POWERFUL
MESSAGE TO EXPAND THIS PROGRAM
WITH THE SAME BIPARTISAN SUPPORT.
INVESTING IN THIS WHERE THE
PROGRAM WILL BRING JUSTICE TO
MORE CALIFORNIANS IN MORE PARTS
OF THE STATE'S.
AND EXPAND SERVICES TO CRITICAL
AREAS SUCH AS DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
THANK YOU AND RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR AYE VOTE.
THINGS GABRIEL YES MISS
CUNNINGHAM YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
ALL RIGHTS ARE JUST BEGINNING
COLLEAGUES IF YOU GO.
TO A NUMBER OF COURT ROOMS IN
FAMILY COURT ALL ACROSS
CALIFORNIA.
ON ANY GIVEN DAY YOU WILL SEE A
LINE OF PEOPLE.
THAT ARE SELF REPRESENTED AND
TRYING TO WORK THROUGH SERIOUS
DISPUTES INVOLVING THEIR
CHILDREN -- AND IT IS A
COMBINATION OF TRAGEDY AND
COMEDY TO WATCH THAT -- THIS
PROGRAM RAISES A FEW NOMINAL
FEES BY NOMINAL AMOUNT.
AND IT FUNDS REPRESENTATION FOR
THOSE PEOPLE.
WHICH FREES UP OUR COURT SYSTEM.
IS BETTER FOR CHILDREN IN THE
LONG RUN AND ALLOWS THEM ACCESS
TO COUNSEL THAT CAN HELP RESOLVE
THEIR DISPUTES THAT THEY ARE NOT
ABLE TO RESOLVE ON THEIR OWN --
I URGE AN AYE VOTE THANK YOU.
THEY WAS CUNNINGHAM MISTER
MALONE HERE RIGHT NOW I THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER I JUST WANT
TO ADD TO THAT -- I'VE SEEN THIS
PROGRAM IN ACTION IT'S HIGHLY
SUCCESSFUL VERY EFFECTIVE IT'S A
GOOD EXPENDITURE.
OF MONEY IT'S IT'S UNFORTUNATE
THAT THE ONLY PLACE WE CAN FIND
IT IS THROUGHA SMALL INCREASE
IN FEES THAT'S AN ISSUE THAT WE
REALLY NEED TO BE LOOKING OUT AS
WE GO FORWARD BECAUSE FEES GO UP
AND UP AND MORE AND MORE PEOPLE
ARE EXCLUDED FROM THE JUSTICE.
SYSTEM IS -- RESULT OF THAT --
BUT AS FOR THIS BILL I URGE YOUR
AYE VOTE IT'S A IMPORTANT STEP
FORWARD.
THANK YOU MUCH BLOOM SAYING NO
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
MR GABRIEL YOU MAY CLOSE WE WISH
I APPRECIATE THE BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT IN THE KIND WORD FOR MY
COLLEAGUES AND WOULD
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE VOTE
[inaudible]
CLARK LIBERAL.
ALL MEMBERS OF THE DESIRE TO
VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
THIS TAKES THIS TAKES.
FIFTY FOUR YEAH.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE
THIS TAKES
.
FIFTY FOUR ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
OUT OF
CLARK WELL TIED ABOUT
EYES.
FIFTY SEVEN KNOWS.
NINE THAT MEASURE PASSES FILE
ITEMS FOURTEEN THROUGH TWENTY
ONE PASS AND RETAIN.
FILE ITEM.
TWENTY TWO AB FOURTEEN SEVENTY
EIGHT BY MS CARILLO COOKERY.
ASSEMBLY BILL FOURTEEN SEVENTY
EIGHT BY SOMETHING MEMBER
CARILLO AND ACTUALLY TO
EMPLOYMENT.
MISS KOREA THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I'M HERE TO
PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL.
FOURTEEN SEVENTY EIGHT A BILL
THAT WILL INSURE DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE SURVIVORS HAVE THE
DESERVE OPTION OF A STRAIGHT
FORWARD AN EXPEDITIOUS LEGAL
PATHWAY TO JUSTICE.
IN THE CASE OF THEIR EMPLOYERS
WRONGDOING AB FOURTEEN SEVENTY
EIGHT IS NEEDED BECAUSE THE
METHOD VIOLENCE SURVIVORS TO
SERVE A CLEAR AND DIRECT LEGAL
AVENUE. TO REDRESS
DISCRIMINATION OR RETALIATION BY
THEIR EMPLOYER BASED ON THEIR
STATUS AS A DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
SURVIVOR.
UNDER CURRENT LAW SURVIVORS OF
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE SEXUAL ASSAULT
AND STALKING MUST BE PROVIDED
JOB PROTECTION TIME OFF TO SEEK
MEDICAL LEGAL AND SOCIAL
SERVICES AS WELL AS REASONABLE.
ACCOMMODATIONS IN THE WORKPLACE
UNFORTUNATELY WHEN THESE RIGHTS
ARE VIOLATED SURVIVORS ARE OFTEN
LEFT WITH LITTLE TO NO RECOURSE.
TODAY SURVIVORS OF DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE WHO EXPERIENCE
MISCONDUCT AT THE HANDS OF THEIR
EMPLOYER.
ARE ABLE TO FILE A COMPLAINT
WITH THE LABOR COMMISSIONER'S
OFFICE OR PURSUE A CLAIM UNDER
PRIVATE ATTORNEY GENERAL'S ACT
OTHERWISE KNOWN AS PAGO.
THESE EXISTING OPTIONS ARE OFTEN
INEFFECTIVE REMEDIES THAT CAN
TAKE MONTHS OR EVEN YEARS TO
PROCESS OR RESULT IN THE
SURVIVOR RECEIVING A SMALL
PERCENTAGE OF CIVIL PENALTIES.
RECOVERED FOR LABOR CODE
VIOLATIONS A RECENT STUDY FOUND
38% OF SURVIVORS REPORT EITHER
HAVING BEEN FIRED OR FEARING
TERMINATION.
BECAUSE OF THEIR DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE SITUATION AND 34%
REPORT HAVING TO QUIT A JOB.
DUE TO DOMESTIC VIOLENCE.
I AB FOURTEEN SEVENTY EIGHT
PROVIDES DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
SURVIVORS THE OPPORTUNITY TO
CHOOSE WHEN AND HOW THEIR
COMPLAINTS OF AN EMPLOYER OF
MISCONDUCT IS HEARD.
THE ABILITY TO GARDNER DAMAGES
OF THE HARM THEY HAVE BEEN COST
AND THE RIGHT TO REPRESENTATION
BY AN ATTORNEY WHO IS
PARTICULARLY EQUIPPED TO DEFEND
THE SURVIVORS BEST INTERESTS AND
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE.
THEY GIVE US CREEL.
SEEING NO DISCUSSION DEBATE ON
THE ITEM.
LOCAL OF THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
DESIRE TO VOTE
.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE ABOUT
MS CARILLO THE CALL.
THE SCRIPT WAS A CALL.
MISTER CALDERON FOR WHAT PURPOSE
THE RISER.
MEMBERS WE GOT A LOT OF BILLS TO
DO WE GOT TO MAKE SURE PAYING
ATTENTION TO THE VOTES GOT TO
MAKE SURE YOU KNOW WHERE YOU'RE
AT WHEN THE BOAT BILLS ARE
COMING UP.
AND IF YOU COULD PLEASE BE AT
YOUR DESK SO THAT WE CAN MOVE
THROUGH BUSINESS IT'S NOT GONNA
BE VERY GOOD FOR US IF WE END UP
WITH TWENTY THIRTY BILLS ON
CALLED THE OTHER DAY.
BECAUSE WE'RE NOT PAYING
ATTENTION THERE'S A LOT TO DO WE
GOT TO GET A LOT DONE THIS WEEK
SO THAT WE CAN BE SUCCESSFUL IN
GETTING DONE AT A REASONABLE
TIME.
NEXT WEEK PLEASE PAY ATTENTION
THANK YOU FOR THAT ADMONISHMENT
MISTER CALDERON
.
PASS A RETAINER FILE ITEM.
TWENTY THREE WHERE FILE ITEM
TWENTY FOUR A. B. ELEVEN TEN MS
FREEMAN CORKERY.
ASSEMBLY BILL ELEVEN TEN BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRIEDMAN AND
ACTUALLY THE RENT INCREASES THIS
FRIEDMAN.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
AND WE ALL KNOW THAT THERE IS A
HOUSING AFFORDABILITY CRISIS IN
CALIFORNIA.
IN MY DISTRICT A LOT OF THE
TENANTS ARE MONTH TO MONTH
RENTERS -- AND EVEN TENANTS THAT
HAVE YOUR TWO YEAR LEASES ARE
BEING SLAM WITH.
TWENTY THIRTY FORTY WE'VE SEEN
EVEN A 100% RATE INCREASES NOT
THAT UNCOMMON RIGHT NOW IN LOS
ANGELES.
THIS IS A MODEST BILL THAT
REQUIRES INCREASE NOTICING FROM
WHAT'S NOW REQUIRED UNDER STATE
LAW FOR LARGE RENT INCREASES.
IT'S A SMALL AMOUNT OF
PROTECTION FOR RENTERS THAT
HELPS PEOPLE FIND OTHER
ACCOMMODATIONS BEFORE THEY'RE
OUT ON THE STREET WITH WHAT'S
TYPICALLY JUST A ONE MONTH
NOTICE OF A MAJOR RENT INCREASE.
UNDER THE BILL CURRENT
REQUIREMENTS OF A THIRTY DAY
NOTICE 4% RENT INCREASES OF 10%
OR LESS REMAIN IN EFFECT SO IT
DOESN'T CHANGE A LAW FOR YOUR
10% UNDER INCREASES.
BUT FOR NEW PROPOSE RENT
INCREASES OVER 10% AND UP 250% A
NEW NINETY DAY NOTICE WILL BE
REQUIRED FOR RENT INCREASES OF
MORE THAN 50% A NEW A HUNDRED
AND TWENTY DAY NOTICE WILL BE
REQUIRED.
IN ADDITION RENT INCREASES FOR
THE PURPOSE OF NOTICING WILL BE
CALCULATED ON A CUMULATIVE BASIS
FOR THE PREVIOUS TWELVE MONTHS
THIS IS REALLY A SMALL AMOUNT OF
PROTECTION FOR TENANTS. TO GIVE
THEM TIME AND I THINK IT'S THE
LEAST THAT WE CAN DO.
AB -- ELEVEN TEN IS SPONSORED BY
THE CITY OF GLENDALE AND
SUPPORTED BY THE AIDS HEALTHCARE
FOUNDATION CALIFORNIA CATHOLIC
CONFERENCE EAST BAY HOW THE
HOUSING ORGANIZATIONS AND THE
NEIGHBORHOOD LEGAL SERVICES OF
LOS ANGELES COUNTY.
I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE
VOTE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MS FRIEDMAN SEEING NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE.
CLUB RURAL ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THESE ARE ABOUT ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS OUT OF OF ALL MEMBERS OF
THE DESIRE TO VOTE [inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSE ROLE TALBOT EYES FORTY
EIGHT NO.
SEVENTEEN THAT MEASURE PASSES.
PAST RETAIN ON FILE ITEMS
[inaudible] TWENTY FIVE THREE
THIRTY WE ARE FILE ITEM.
THIRTY ONE AB THIRTEEN FORTY
FIVE MCCARTY CORKERY.
ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTEEN FORTY
FIVE BY PHONE NUMBER MCCARTY AND
OTHERS AND ACTUALLY TO PRIVATE
POSTSECONDARY EDUCATION.
MR MCCARTY.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I AM
LEADING OFF HERE TODAY WITH A
PACKAGE OF BILLS WE'RE GOING TO
HEAR.
THIS MORNING TO BETTER PROTECT
STUDENTS IN THE FOR PROFIT
COLLEGE INDUSTRY WE CERTAINLY
HEARD THE STORIES AND NO THERE
ARE ARE.
OUR EFFORTS THE CALIFORNIA COULD
DO YOU NEED TO DO TO BETTER
PROTECT STUDENTS ESPECIALLY IN
LIGHT OF WHAT'S HAPPENING AT THE
NATIONAL LEVEL.
SO MY BILL HERE THIS MORNING
THIRTEEN FORTY FIVE WOULD CLOSE
THE LOOPHOLES AND CURRENT LAWS
AGAINST KICKBACKS AND INCENTIVES
FOR RECRUITERS WHO ARE GOING
AFTER THE STUDENTS.
ESSENTIALLY THESE RECRUITERS ARE
JUST HIGH PRESSURE SALES PEOPLE
GETTING PAID TO PUT BODIES IN
SEATS.
WORST THESE RECRUITERS -- TARGET
THEIR INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE
VULNERABLE PEOPLE IN THE FIRST
PLACE VETERANS SOMETIMES
HOMELESS INDIVIDUALS TEENAGERS.
FIRST GENERATION AND LOW INCOME
STUDENTS PUT ON LEAVE FROM KICK
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR -- CURRENT
LAW ONLY PREVENTS KICK BACKS BY
EMPLOYEES AND DOES NOT COVER
INDEPENDENT CONTRACTORS.
AND ALSO DOES NOT INCLUDE --
KICK BACKS BASED UPON FINANCIAL
AID.
THIS BILL HAS RECEIVED
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT SUPPORTED BY
A BROAD COALITION ASK YOUR AYE
VOTE THIS MORNING THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AS MCCARTY SEEING NO
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE ITEM.
COR CORPORAL.
ALL MEMBERS OF THE DESIRE TO
VOTE ALL MEMBERS OF THE DESIRE
TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS OF THE DESIRE TO
VOTE [inaudible]
CLICK WELL [inaudible] ZERO TELL
YOU VOTE.
I FIFTY SEVEN NO ZERO THAT
MEASURE PASSES FILE ITEMS THIRTY
TWO THIRTY THREE AND THIRTY FOUR
PASS AND RETAIN.
WHERE FILE ITEM THIRTY FIVE A.
B. FOURTEEN THIRTEEN BY MR
GLORIA CORKERY?
AT SOME LEVEL FOURTEEN THIRTEEN
BY SOMETHING MEMBER GLORIA AND
ACTUALLY TO TRANSPORTATION.
MR GLORIA.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I RISE
PRESENT AB.
FOURTEEN THIRTEEN MEMBERS THIS
IS A BILL THAT'S GOING OUT OF MY
EXPERIENCES I THINK PROBABLY
MANY OF YOUR EXPERIENCES LOCAL
ELECTED OFFICIALS WE TRIED SEE
PROGRESS ON TRANSPORTATION
INFRASTRUCTURE INVESTMENT.
BUT TOO OFTEN OUR CITIES IN OUR
COMMUNITIES ARE PITTED AGAINST
ONE ANOTHER'S DOES NOT URBAN
COMMUNITIES I WANT TO SEE MORE
TRANSIT BICYCLE PEDESTRIAN
IMPROVEMENTS THOSE URBAN MORE
WILL COMMUNITIES LOOK FOR ROAD
IMPROVEMENTS.
AND WHEN THOSE THINGS ARE COUPLE
TOGETHER THOSE THAT OPPOSITION
RESULT IN NO PROGRESS BEING MADE
AB FOURTEEN THIRTEEN IS LOOKING
TO BREAK THAT DYNAMIC AND
pINFRASTRUCTURE INVESTMENT.
BY ALLOWING TRANSPORTATION
AUTHORITIES TO HAVE A SUB RESULT
TAXING AUTHORITY THIS WOULD MEAN
THAT COMMUNITIES CAN WHO BENEFIT
FROM IMPROVEMENTS WILL BE THE
ONES THAT PAY FOR THESE
IMPROVEMENTS.
AND WE CAN ELIMINATE THIS
CONFLICT BETWEEN THE PROGRESS
THAT SO DESPERATELY NEEDED IN
OUR STATE MEMBERS THIS BILL HAS
RECEIVED TREMENDOUS SUPPORT FROM
ACROSS CALIFORNIA FOR MANY OF
THE DISTRICT THAT YOU REPRESENT.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THERE WAS GLORIA AND SEEING.
NO DISCUSSION DEBATE.
CLERK OF ALL.
MEMBERS VOTE.
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE IT IS OUR TO
VOTE
.
ALL MEMBERS REYES ARAB VOTE.
MR GLORIA -- THE COMMENTS
BECAUSE YOUR GLORY MOVES A CALL.
WE ARE GOING TO PASS RETAIN A
FILE ITEM THIRTY SIX THIS IS
FILE ITEM THIRTY SEVEN A. B..
CUNNINGHAM FIVE THE ANTI
EAVESDROPPING ACT AFTER A VERY
ROBUST POLICY DISCUSSION IN THE
PRIVACY COMMITTEE THE BILL WAS
PASSED OUT THESE AMENDMENTS
ADDRESS SOME OF THE ISSUES
RAISED IN COMMITTEE BY MY
COLLEAGUES -- THE AMEND IT'S
ALSO AT CO AUTHORS TO THE BILL
YEAH MY COMMITMENT TO CONTINUING
TO WORK WITH STAKEHOLDERS IN
INDUSTRY TO COME UP WITH THE
FINAL WORK PRODUCT ON THIS BILL.
DOES NOT STIFLE INNOVATION BUT
PROVIDES THE BASELINE OF
CONSUMER PRIVACY THAT WE ALL
NEED IN OURHOMES THANK YOU VERY
MUCH I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS CUNNINGHAM.
WITHOUT OBJECTION WE MAY TAKE A
VOICE VOTE ON THESE AMENDMENTS
ALL THOSE IN FAVOR SAY AYE.
AYE OPPOSED SAY NAY THE AYES
HAVE IT THE MEMBERS ARE JOB TO
THE BILL'S OUT TO PRINCE.
AND BACK ON FILE.
FILE ITEMS THIRTY EIGHT THROUGH
FORTY FIVE PASS AND RETAIN.
RESIST FILE I'M FORTY SIX A. B.
TEN SEVENTY TWO FOR THE PURPOSE
OF AMENDMENTS COURT AGREED WITH
AMENDMENTS
AS LEGAL TEN SEVENTY TWO WITH
AMENDMENTS BY SOMETHING OVER
PATTERSON WHICH PATTERSON ON THE
MEMBERS THANK VERY MUCH MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS -- AB TEN
SEVENTY TWO PROVIDES CLARITY TO
SMALL WATER AND TELEPHONE
PROVIDERS ABOUT THE TIME LINE
UNDER WHICH THE PC MUST COMPLETE
AN AUDIT OR REVIEW OF THEIR
UTILITY.
IT ALSO AVOIDS DUPLICATION OF
UNNECESSARY WORK ON THE GENERAL
RATE CASES BEING.
COMPLETED FINDING THE BILL
INSURERS TRANSPARENCY BY
REQUIRING THE PC TO PUBLICLY
POST THEIR AUDITING PROCESS
STANDARDS.
THESE AMENDMENTS ARE TECHNICAL
AND CLARIFYING ONLY AND I ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU REST PATTERSON WITHOUT
OBJECTION WE MAY TAKE A VOICE
VOTE ON THESE AMENDMENTS ALL
THOSE IN FAVOR SAY AYE.
AYE OPPOSED SAY NAY.
THE AYES HAVE IT THE MEMBERS ARE
JOB TO THE BILL'S OUTSPRINTED
BACK ON FILE MEMBERS WE ARE
GOING TO MOVE BACK TO FILE I'M.
THIRTY NINE THIS IS FILE ITEM
THIRTY NINE WE ARE GOING TO TAKE
UP AB ELEVEN TWELVE I MISS
FRIEDMAN CORKERY.
ASSEMBLY BILL ELEVEN TWELVE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRIEDMAN AND
ACTUALLY SHARED ABILITY DEVICES.
MS FRIEDMAN.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS WE ALL KNOW THAT
SCOOTERS ARE BECOMING AN
INCREASINGLY POPULAR FORM OF
ALTERNATIVE MOBILITY.
THEY HAVE A LOT OF ADVANTAGES IF
YOU DON'T LIKE SCOOTERS JUST
REMEMBER THAT EVERY SINGLE
PERSON ON A SCOOTER SOMEONE IS
NOT IN THE CAR.
IN FRONT OF YOU CAUSING TRAFFIC
BUT WE HAVE OF A SERIES OF A
PATCHWORK OF LOCAL ORDINANCES
ACROSS THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
THAT'S VERY CONFUSING FOR
WRITERS.
ESPECIALLY IN THE DENSE URBAN
AREAS LIKE LOS ANGELES WHERE YOU
HAVE CITIES THAT ABOUT EACH
OTHER YOU CAN LITERALLY RUN TO
SCOOTER IN ONE CITY AND HAVEN'T
STOPPED DEAD IN THENEXT CITY OR
YOU CAN GO INTO THAT CITY NOT
KNOWING THAT SCOOTERS MAYBE
AREN'T PERMITTED.
AND GET A TICKET OR YOUR YOU
MIGHT NOT KNOW THAT THEIR ONLY
PERMITTED IN CERTAIN PLACES WHAT
THIS DOES IS IT SETS A BASIC
MINIMUM STANDARDS ACROSS THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
BOTH FOR REGULATIONS INSURANCE
AND FOR PRIVACY WE ARE WORKING
WITH CITIES TO ENSURE THAT
CITIES THAT ARE KIND OF I HEAD
AND ALREADY HAVE THE REGULATIONS
ADOPTED DON'T HAVE THEM
UNDERMINE.
BY WHAT WE'RE DOING BUT WE
BELIEVE THAT THIS HAS A THIS --
DOES GET CITIES ON THE ROAD TO
HAVING THE DISCUSSION WITH THEIR
COMMUNITY ABOUT WHERE AND WHEN
AND HOW THEY WANT TO HAVE THE
SCOOTERS OR EVEN NOT ALLOWED
THEM IF THEY WANT NOT TO INVOLVE
THEM.
THIS BILL HAS BROAD SUPPORTED
SUPPORTED BY THE SIERRA CLUB BAY
AREA COUNCIL ENVIRONMENTAL
DEFENSE FUND SILICON VALLEY
LEADERSHIP GROUP THE CALIFORNIA
HISPANIC HOW A CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE.
BIRD LIFT JUMP AND TECH NET
WITHOUT I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
AN AYE VOTE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MS FRIEDMAN SEEING NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE ITEM
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE ALL
MEMBERS OF WE'RE SORRY ABOUT ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLICK WELL CLOSER ALL TIED ABOUT
ICE FOR THE FOR KNOWS.
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES BACK IN
REGULAR FILE ORDER FILE ITEM.
FORTY SEVEN AND FORTY EIGHT PASS
RETAIN.
THIS IS FILE ITEM FORTY NINE AB
SEVEN TWENTY NINE BY MISTER
KANSEN CHU CORCORAN.
I SOME LEGAL SEVEN TWENTY NINE
BY SOMETHING MEMBER KANSEN CHU
AND ACTUALLY DO RECYCLING.
MR CHILL YOU MAY OPEN.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER SAM
MEMBERS I HOPE I WILL NOT BREAK
THE VOTING SYSTEM AGAIN TODAY.
BUT THIS IS A BILL THAT I
PRESENTED TO A MONDAY AB SEVEN
TWENTY NINE FOLLOWING.
IS A AS A BILL FOLLOW UP WITH A
BIT MY BILL LAST YEAR TO IMPROVE
THE CARPET RECYCLING IN
CALIFORNIA.
AND THE A. B. SEVEN TWENTY NINE
WOULD REQUIRE A BREACH OR
CONTINGENCY PLAN TO AVOID
DISRUPTING CALIFORNIANS COPY
RECYCLING EFFORT.
AND PROTECT FEES PAID BY THE
CONSUMERS IN THE CASE THAT THE
MANUFACTURER.
RUN THIS STATE COVERAGE SURE
SURE PROGRAM IS DISAPPROVE OR
DISSOLVED I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE THE SECOND TIME.
THANK YOU MISTER Q..
SEEING NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THE ITEM THANK YOU FOR
PRESENTING THAT ITEM.
YET AGAIN.
CLARK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
WHO'S OUT OF THAT ALL MEMBERS
THAT IT IS ACTIVE VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF OUT.
TAKES FORTY ONE MEMBERS.
PLEASE FIND YOUR DESKS.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE ABOUT
.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
CLERK WILL CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT
AYE AYES FORTY TWO KNOWS.
FOURTEEN THAT MEASURE PASSES.
FILE ITEM FIFTY AB EIGHT SEVEN
THREE CORPORATE.
ASSEMBLY WILL EIGHT SEVENTY
THREE BY FAMILY MEMBER IRWIN AND
ACTUALLY TO CONSUMER PRIVACY.
MISSOURI WHEN.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I RISE
TODAY TO PRESENT AB EIGHT SEVEN
THREE THE RESULT OF EXTENSIVE
WORK TO BRING THE BUSINESS
COMMUNITY TOGETHER. TO
UNDERSTAND HOW TO IMPLEMENT THE
CCPA AND MANY CONVERSATIONS WITH
THE ORIGINAL AUTHOR.
THIS BILL TAKES ON TWO CRITICAL
ISSUES THE DEFINITION OF
PERSONAL INFORMATION THE
DEFINITION OF DE IDENTIFIED.
THE PROVISIONS IN THIS BILL WILL
PROVIDE A CLEARER UNDERSTANDING
OF THESE TWO THRESHOLD
CONSIDERATIONS A MAKES THE CPA
IMPLEMENTATION MORE STRAIGHT
FORWARD AND WORKABLE.
AB EIGHT SEVEN THREE AVOIDS
COSTLY CONFUSION THAT WOULD
PROLONG IMPLEMENTATION PUSHING
BACK WHEN CALIFORNIANS COULD
UTILIZE THEIR NEW RIGHTS AS
PROMISED TO THEM BY THE SEA CPA
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
THOUGH.
THANK YOU MISTER WHEN SAY NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE.
OUR CLUB THE WRONG.
ALL MEMBERS.
FOR DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
MATTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT ABOUT
[inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
YOUR ROLL TIDE ABOUT ICE FIFTY
SIX NO.
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES FILE
ITEM FIFTY ONE IS AB ELEVEN
NINETY FIVE BY MISTER O'DONNELL
QUIRK READ AS A LEGAL LEVIN
NINETY FIVE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
O'DONNELL AND ACTUALLY TO
GREENHOUSE GASES.
THE SHOW DONALD.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I AM
PLEASED TO PRESENT AB ELEVEN
NINETY FIVE WHICH INCENTIVIZE IS
THE REPLACEMENT.
OF NATURAL GAS WITH RENEWABLE
NATURAL GAS BY EXTENDING THE LOW
CARBON FUEL STANDARD CREDIT.
AVAILABLE FOR SUCH REPLACEMENT
OIL PRODUCERS.
AMENDMENTS TAKEN IN COMMITTEE
CLARIFY THAT IN ORDER TO RECEIVE
A CREDIT THE RENEWABLE NATURAL
GAS MUST BE GENERATED BY A
SOURCE THAT WILL DIRECTLY.
REDUCE METHANE EMISSIONS IN
CALIFORNIA.
THIS WILL NOT ONLY REDUCE THE
GHG FOOT PRINT OF ALL OIL AND
GAS OPERATIONS BUT ALSO ASSIST
IN CREATING A STRONGER IN STATE
MARKET FOR MATH THING.
THAT WOULD OTHERWISE DISSIPATE
INTO THE ATMOSPHERE.
THIS OF ROSAL SUPPORT SUPPORTED
BY BOTH LABOR AND INDUSTRY AND
RECEIVED BIPARTISAN SUPPORT.
I ASKED FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER DONALD.
SEEING THEIR DISCUSSION BET ON
THE ITEM CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE -- ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
QUIRK WELL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT ICE FORTY
SIX KNOWS.
TO THAT MEASURE PASSES FILE ITEM
FIFTY TWO THREW FIFTY FOUR PASS
RETAIN.
WEIRD FILE ITEM FIFTY FIVE AB
FIFTEEN EIGHTY FOUR BY DR QUIRK.
CORKERY ASSEMBLY WILL FIFTEEN
EIGHTY FOUR FIVE FAMILY MEMBER
QUIRK AND ACTUALLY TO LECTURE
CITY.
DOCTOR QUIRK EMAIL [inaudible]
THIS BILL.
DEALS WITH -- CORPORATIONS WHICH
SUPPLY ELECTRICITY TO THE GRAD
[inaudible]
AND ORDINARILY THEY WILL BALANCE
THEIR LONG TERM CONTRACTS SO
THAT THEY CAN SUPPLY ALL THE
ELECTRICITY ALL THE TIME.
OCCASIONALLY ARE THINGS WON'T
WORK OUT MAYBE THERE'S A PLANT
DOT DOWN.
ALL AND THEY'RE GOING TO HAVE TO
BUY ON THE SPOT MARKET.
CURRENTLY THE ISO WILL KEEP
TRACK OF ALL THESE PURCHASES.
AND THEN -- SO THAT IT KNOWS WHO
MADE THOSE PURCHASES AND WHO'S
RESPONSIBLE FOR THEM.
THE PROBLEM IS THAT THEY NOW GET.
DISTRIBUTED.
JUST ON THE BASIS OF LOAD AS
OPPOSED ON THE BASIS OF WHO
ACTUALLY MADE THE PURCHASE.
SO A CORPORATION WHICH IS
SUPPLYING ELECTRICITY THE GRID
AND HAS BEEN ABLE TO SUPPLY IT
ON A CONTINUOUS BASIS NEVER HAS
TO GO TO THE SPOT MARKET.
IS PENALIZED BY THOSE WHO ARE
NOT SO CAREFUL.
SO THIS IS ABOUT.
PEOPLE PAYING FOR WHAT THEY
ACTUALLY USE.
THE CCAC ORIGINALLY OPPOSED
THEIR LEGISLATIVE COMMITTEE HAS
VOTED TO GO NEUTRAL AND I'M
EXPECTING THEIR WHOLE BOARD TO
GO -- TO APPROVE A NEUTRAL
POSITION IN THE NEXT FEW DAYS
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU DOCTOR QUIRK.
SEEING NO DISCUSSION ON THE ITEM.
LOCAL OF NARAL.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF OUT
[inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE BUT I SIXTY NO
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES.
FILE ITEM FIFTY SIX PASS AND
RETAIN.
FILE ITEM FIFTY SEVEN IS H. R.
THIRTY ONE BY MR GLORIA CLERK
READ.
HOUSE RESOLUTION THIRTY ONE BY
SOMETHING MEMBER GLORIA AND
OTHERS RELATIVE TO HARD ENOUGH
DAY.
SURE GLORIA ON THE RESOLUTION.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
I RISE TODAY TO PRESENT HR
THIRTY ONE WHICH RECOGNIZE THE
CONTRIBUTIONS OF HARVEY BERNARD
MILK.
HOW THE MILK WAS BORN ON MAY
TWENTY SECOND NINETEEN THIRTY
AND WOOD NEAR NEW YORK?
PERHAPS MORE THAN ANY OTHER
MODERN FIGURE HARVEY MILK'S LIFE
AND POLITICAL CAREER EMBODY THE
RISE OF THE LESBIAN GAY BISEXUAL
AND TRANSGENDER CIVIL RIGHTS
MOVEMENT.
NOT JUST HERE IN CALIFORNIA BUT
ACROSS THE NATION AND AROUND OUR
WORLD.
HARVEY MILK MOVED TO SAN
FRANCISCO IN NINETEEN SEVENTY
TWO WITH HIS PARTNER SCOTT SMITH.
ANDHE OPENED HIS NOW FAMOUS
CAMERA SHOP IN THE ON CASTRO
STREET IN THE HEART OF THE
CITY'S BLOSSOMING GAY DISTRICT.
SOON BECAME A COMMUNITY LEADER
FOUND IN THE CASTRO VALLEY
ASSOCIATION OF LOCAL MERCHANTS.
MILK RAN SEVERAL TIMES FOR
PUBLIC OFFICE BUT WAS
UNSUCCESSFUL UNTIL HE WAS
ELECTED TO REPRESENT DISTRICT
FIVE ON THE SAN FRANCISCO BOARD
OF SUPERVISORS.
MILK WAS ONE OF THE FIRST OPENLY
GAY POLITICIANS TO HOLD PUBLIC
OFFICE WHEN HE WAS ELECTED IN.
NINETEEN SEVENTY SEVEN LOOK WAS
INSTRUMENTAL IN THE DEFEAT OF
PROPOSITION SIX CALMLY KNOWN AS
THE BRIGGS INITIATIVE IN
NOVEMBER OF NINETEEN SEVENTY
EIGHT I AM VERY ASK YOU TO THINK
ABOUT IN NINETEEN SEVENTY EIGHT
THE FOLKS IN THIS STATE WERE
ASKED WHETHER OR NOT.
WE SHOULD HIRE A BAN GAYS AND
LESBIANS FROM BEING PUBLIC
SCHOOL TEACHERS THAT WAS ON THE
BALLOT IN HARVEY HELPED LEAD THE
FIGHT TO DEFEAT IT WHICH THE
VOTERS DID.
HARVEY MONK'S LIFE WAS CUT SHORT
AS MANY OF YOU WELL KNOW.
HE WAS ASSASSINATED IN NINETEEN
SEVENTY EIGHT ALONG SIDE THEN
SAN FRANCISCO MAYOR GEORGE
MOSCONI.
BY A FORMER COLLEAGUE DAN WHITE.
HARVEY MILK WAS JUST FORTY EIGHT
YEARS OLD WHEN HE WAS KILLED.
ARE YOU LOOKS KILLER SADLY
RECEIVED A VERY LENIENT SENTENCE
SOME OF YOU MAY KNOW THAT
DESPITE THE PRESENCE OF A TAPED
CONFESSION HE WAS ONLY CONVICTED
OF MANSLAUGHTER IN ONLY SERVE
FIVE YEARS IN PRISON.
MAY BELIEVE THAT HAPPENED
BECAUSE OF THE HOMOPHOBIA IT WAS
SO COMMON IN THOSE DAYS.
ARE YOU LOOK IS CONSIDERED BY
MANY TO BE ONE OF THOSE
INFLUENTIAL POLITICIANS OF THE
TWENTIETH CENTURY DESPITE HAVING
ONLY SERVED IN PUBLIC OFFICE FOR
A BIT OF A BIT LESS THAN A YEAR.
THERE ARE NUMEROUS INSTITUTIONS
AND SCHOOLS IN THIS STATE AND
ACROSS THIS COUNTRY THAT BEAR
HARVEY MILK'S NAME A TESTAMENT
TO HIS CONTRIBUTIONS.
HARVEY MILK WAS STATIONED IN SAN
DIEGO.
AS A NAVY DIVING INSTRUCTOR IN.
NINETEEN FIFTY FOUR AND TWENTY
TWELVE SAN DIEGO BECAME THE
FIRST CITY IN UNITED STATES TO
HONOR MILK WITH THE STREET.
WITH HIS VERY OWN NAME.
MEMBERS ARE PROUD TO SHARE WITH
YOU THAT TODAY WE ARE BUILDING
THE U. S. AND S. HARVEY MILK.
IN THE SHIPYARDS IN SAN DIEGO
THAT SHIP IS EXPECTED TO BE
COMMISSIONED IN JUST A FEW YEARS
FROM NOW.
MEMBERS THE CALIFORNIA LGBT
LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS WILL BE
HOSTING A SCREEN OF THE NEW FILM
ROCKET MAN IN HONOR OF HARVEY
MILK DAY LATER TODAY AND ALL OF
YOU ARE INVITED TO ATTEND.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
ON HR.
THIRTY ONE LET'S LIFT UP HARVEY
MILK'S MEMORY ON HIS BIRTHDAY
AND ALL THAT HE'S DONE FOR SO
MANY OF US NOT ONLY TO SERVE BUT
TO LIVE IN A MORE EQUAL AND JUST
SOCIETY.
I WOULD EXPECT WE ASK FOR THE
FIRST WILL BE OPEN FOR CO
AUTHORS MISTER SPEAKER.
THANK YOU MISTER GLORIA SEE NO
ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION ON THE
RESOLUTION MR WARS ASSN OF THE
FIRST WILL BE OPEN FOR CO
AUTHORS.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS ON HR.
THIRTY ONE THIS IS FOR CO
AUTHORS ADDING ON THE RESOLUTION.
THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS.
THE CLERK WILL.
CLOSE THE ROLE THERE ARE FORTY
EIGHT CO AUTHORS ADDED AND
WITHOUT OBJECTION WE MAY TAKE A
VOICE VOTE ON THE RESOLUTION ALL
THOSE IN FAVOR SAY AYE.
AYE OPPOSED SAY NAY.
THE AYES HAVE IT THE RESOLUTION
IS ADOPTED.
FILE ITEMS FIFTY EIGHT THROUGH
SIXTY ONE PASS AND RETAIN.
FILE ITEM SIXTY TWO IS AB. TEN
FIVE MISTER DAVID CHIU CORPORATE.
ASSEMBLY WILL TEN VICE ONLY
MEMBER DAVID CHIU AND OTHERS AND
ACTUALLY TO TAXATION TO TAKE
EFFECT IMMEDIATELY TAX LEVY.
RESEARCH YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
COLLEAGUES IN THE MIDST OF THE
WORST HOUSING CRISIS IN OUR
STATE'S HISTORY.
AB TEN WOULD EXPAND OUR STATE'S
MOST EFFECTIVE HOUSING FINANCING
TOOL OR STATES AFFORDABLE
HOUSING TAX CREDIT.
THE BILL WOULD INCREASE THE TAX
CREDIT BY FIVE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS WHICH WOULD IN TURN
LEVERAGE ANOTHER ONE BILLION
DOLLARS IN FEDERAL TAX CREDITS
LOCAL AND PRIVATE SECTOR
INVESTMENTS.
AFTER THE GREAT RECESSION
CALIFORNIA LOST ALMOST TWO
BILLION DOLLARS A YEAR IN
AFFORDABLE HOUSING FUNDING IN
LARGE PART DUE TO THE END OF
REDEVELOPMENT.
WHILE WE HAVE MOVED A NUMBER OF
NEW POLICIES IN RECENT YEARS TO
ADDRESS THE CRISIS INCLUDING
FUNDING.
WE NEED MORE RESOURCES TO BUILD
THE ONE POINT FOUR MILLION
AFFORDABLE RENTAL HOMES FOR
LOWER INCOME CALIFORNIANS
PARTICULARLY GIVEN OUR HOMES AS
CRISIS ON OUR STREETS.
AB TEN IS SIMILAR TO PREVIOUS
BILLS THAT I'VE AUTHORED
INCLUDING THE FIRST BILL THAT I
INTRODUCED AS AN ASSEMBLY MEMBER
THAT WAS VETOED BY GOVERNOR
BROWN DESPITE UNANIMOUS SUPPORT.
I APPRECIATE THE GOVERNOR
NEWSOME HAS SHOWN STRONG SUPPORT
FOR EXPANDING THIS CREDIT
PROPOSING FIVE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS IN EXPANSION IN THIS
YEAR'S BUDGET.
I WANT TO THANK THE UNANIMOUS
BIPARTISAN VOTES TO THE PROCESS
THE TWO DOZEN CO AUTHORS AND
BOTH SIDES OF THE AISLE AND
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN SAYING
NO DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE ITEM
CORD BLOOD IN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSE THE ROLE TODD ABOUT ICE
FIFTY EIGHT NO.
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES FILE
ITEM SIXTY THREE IS AB.
SIXTEEN BY MYSTERY OF US
CORPORATE.
AT SOME LEVEL SIXTEEN BY SOME
REMEMBER THREE OF US AND OTHERS
AND ACTUALLY TO HOMELESS
CHILDREN AND YOUTH.
THREE OF US YOU MAY OPEN.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS AB SIXTEEN ESTABLISHES A
COMPREHENSIVE POLICY APPROACH
THAT WILL GIVE THE STATE THE
ABILITY TO BETTER HELP
COMMUNITIES PROVIDING SERVICES
TO HOMELESS FAMILIES WITH
CHILDREN.
BY INCREASING THE NUMBER OF
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION HOMELESS COORDINATORS
AND BY FUNDING THREE GEOGRAPHIC
COUNTY OFFICES OF EDUCATION TO
DEVELOP TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
CENTERS.
THIS IS UNACCEPTABLE THAT WE
HAVE THIS MANY HOMELESS CHILDREN --
IN OUR STATE WE HAVE OVER TWO
HUNDRED THOUSAND HOMELESS
CHILDREN -- CALIFORNIA HAS
EXPERIENCED A RISE IN STUDENTS
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS BUT
THERE'S BEEN NO INCREASES IN
RESOURCES AT OUR DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION TO HELP COMBAT
HOMELESSNESS.
AB SIXTEEN WILL ENSURE THAT THE
CD AND DISTRICTS HAVE THE
RESOURCES NEEDED TO ASSIST OUR
CHILDREN AND COORDINATE BETWEEN
OUR EXISTING STATE.
AND LOCAL HOMELESS EDUCATION
PROGRAMS ON THIS BILL HAS
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND
OPPOSITION I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MS RIVAS SEE NO
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
CLARK LIBERAL ALL MEMBERS VOTE
THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
CLARK WELL CLOSER ROLE AND TELL
YOU ABOUT AYE SIXTY FIVE NO.
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES.
FILE ITEM.
SIXTY FOUR PASS RETAIN WE'RE
FILE ITEM SIXTY FIVE AB TWENTY
EIGHT CORPORATION ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY EIGHT BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
OBERNOLTE AND OTHERS AND
ACTUALLY THE HIGH SCHOOL
DIPLOMAS.
MR OF AN OLDIE THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER COLLEAGUES.
JOBS IN THE FIELD OF SCIENCE
TECHNOLOGY ENGINEERING AND
MATHEMATICS WILL BE AMONGST THE
MOST HIGHLY SOUGHT AFTER.
AND THE MOST IN DEMAND JOBS IN
THE NEXT TWENTY YEARS IN FACT
IT'S ESTIMATED THAT 19%.
OUR JOB GROWTH WILL BE
EXPERIENCED IN THOSE FIELDS AND
THAT OVER HALF OF NEW JOBS IN
CALIFORNIA WILL BE IN STEM
FIELDS BUT UNFORTUNATELY
STATISTICS ALSO SHOW THAT WE ARE
NOT GRADUATING ENOUGH STUDENTS.
WITH JOB SKILLS IN THESE FIELDS
AB TWENTY EIGHT WILL HELP
RECTIFY THAT PROBLEM BY CREATING
A STATE SEAL OF STEM.
THAT ARE HIGH SCHOOLERS WILL BE
ELIGIBLE FOR ON THEIR HIGH
SCHOOL DIPLOMAS QUALIFYING FOR
THIS WILL REQUIRE FOUR YEARS OF
EDUCATION AND SCIENCE FOR YEARS
IN MATH ONE OF WHICH CAN BE A
COMPUTER SCIENCE COURSE.
THIS IS A SMALL STEP TOWARDS
INCENTIVIZING THE STUDENTS TO
PURSUE EDUCATION IN THESE FIELDS
I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR AYE
VOTE ON AB.
TWENTY EIGHT THANK YOU MISTER OF
AN ALL THE SEEING NO DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE ON THE ITEM OR CALL
THE ROLL.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
CLICK WELL CLOSE YOUR ROLL TIDE
BUT ICE FIFTY NINE NO.
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES.
FILE ITEM SIXTY SIX AND SIXTY
SEVEN PASSED RETAIN FILE ITEM.
SIXTY EIGHT IS AB THIRTY NINE BY
MISTER MURATSUCHI CORPORATION
ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTY NINE BY
SOMETHING MEMBER MURATSUCHI AND
OTHERS AND ACTUALLY TO EDUCATION
FINANCE.
MR MURATSUCHI THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MEMBERS TODAY IS RED FOR
AND DAY.
AND AND FAMILIES TEACHERS SCHOOL
DISTRICTS THROUGHOUT THE STATE
ARE ASKING.
WHY IS THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
THE WORLD'S FIFTH LARGEST
ECONOMY? FORTY AND IN THE BOTTOM
TENTH IN THE NATION IN PER
PEOPLE SPENDING.
AB THIRTY NINE PROPOSES A ROAD
MAP FOR CALIFORNIA TO GET TO
WHERE WE USED TO BE IN THE TOP
TEN IN THE NATION.
IN PER PEOPLE K. THROUGH TWELVE
FUNDING.
THIS IS A BILL THAT SUPPORTED BY
ALL EDUCATION STAKEHOLDERS THE
PTA TEACHERS SCHOOL BOARDS
SCHOOL THIS IS SCHOOL
ADMINISTRATORS I ASKED FOR A AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER MURATSUCHI
MISTER MCCARTY YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I'M
ALSO A JOINT AUTHORED THIS
MEASURE AND THIS MORNING WE
ADOPTED OUR BUDGET FOR PROP
NINETY EIGHT AND THE GOOD NEWS
WILL HAVE ABOUT THREE BILLION IN
NEW MONEY. FOR OUR SCHOOLS
ACROSS CALIFORNIA THE BAD NEWS
IS A WERE STILL FORTY FIRST IN
THE NATION IN PER PUPIL FUNDING.
IT'S REALLY A DISGRACE ALL HOW
LOW WE FALLEN.
FRANKLY SINCE NINETEEN SEVENTY
EIGHT AND PROP THIRTEEN THE
STATE IF YOU LOOK AT THE HIGH.
HI.
FUNDED SCHOOLS ACROSS OUR NATION.
NEW YORK ILLINOIS MASSACHUSETTS
THEY ALL HAVE ABOUT THE SAME IN
STATE FUNDING IS THE LOCAL
FUNDING WHICH EVAPORATED OF
COURSE THAT GOES BACK. TO PROP
THIRTEEN SO IS ONLY TWO WAYS YOU
CAN GO ABOUT FIXING THIS ISSUE
CALIFORNIA FRANKLY SHOULD BE
NUMBER.
ONE THAT WOULD BE ABOUT FORTY
FIFTY BILLION DOLLARS I'M NOT
SURE WE CAN GET THERE OVERNIGHT
BUT WE SHOULD BE IN THE MIDDLE
WE SHOULD BE TWENTY FIVE WE
SHOULD BE THE TOP HALF WE LEAD
IN.
ENVIRONMENT HEALTH CARE A CIVIL
RIGHTS ISSUE SO MANY OTHER
ISSUES BUT NOT AND FUNDING OUR
PUBLIC SCHOOLS THE BASICS OF OUR
STATE.
SO TO GET THERE WHAT YOU COULD
DO TWO THINGS YOU COULD INCREASE
REVENUES OR YOU CAN RE
PRIORITIZE OTHER STATE PROGRAMS
REALLY ONLY TWO OPTIONS.
SO TO GET TO THE MIDDLE.
WOULD BE ROUGHLY TWENTY TO
TWENTY FIVE BILLION DOLLARS TO
DO THAT WOULD HAVE TO SHUT DOWN
THE UC CSU SYSTEM EVERY CHILD
CARE PRESCHOOL PROGRAM.
OUR STATE PRISON SYSTEM AND
EVERY STATE PARK.
WE'RE NOT GONNA DO THAT.
THERE IS NO FREE LUNCH HERE SO
REALLY IT'S ABOUT US GOING TO
THE VOTERSOF CALIFORNIANS
SAYING ARE YOU OKAY BEING FORTY
FIRST.
IS IF YOU'RE NOT THERE REALLY
ARE LIMITED OPTIONS AND SO WE
NEED TO MAKE SURE WE FIND OUR
FUTURE THAT'S OUR SCHOOLS IN
THIS DOES IT IT'S NOT.
IT'S NOT ALWAYS ABOUT JUST MONEY
AS A MONEY PER SE BUT THIS IN
THIS IMPACTS SCHOOL CLASS SIZE.
MAKE SURE WE CAN PAY OUR
TEACHERS LIVING WAGES SO THEY
CAN LIVE IN NEIGHBORHOODS WHERE
THEY WORK.
MAKING SURE WE CAN HAVE THESE
ENRICHMENT PROGRAMS LIKE ARTS
AND MATH IN SPORTS AND
COUNSELORS IN SCHOOL NURSES AND
THE BASICS IN OUR CLASSROOMS
WHICH YOU DON'T HAVE TODAY.
SO THIS SETS A FRAMEWORK TO GET
WHERE WE NEED TO GO WE ALSO
CAN'T FORGET IT'S ABOUT FUNDING
THIS AS WELL AND SO WE LOOK
FORWARD TO DISCUSSION ON AN
UPCOMING BALLOT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER MCCARTY MEASURE
OBERNOLTE YOUR RECOGNIZE THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER I RISE AS
PRODUCE PRIDE CO AUTHOR OF AB.
THIRTY NINE COLLEAGUES ACCORDING
TO A RECENT STUDY.
CALIFORNIA HAS THE FOURTEENTH
WORST K. TWELVE SCHOOL SYSTEM IN
THE NATION.
WE RANKED FORTY SIXTH IN.
GRADUATING READING TEST SCORES
FORTY SEVENTH EIGHTH AND
GRADUATING MATH TEST SCORES AND
IN TERMS OF OF TEACHER TO
STUDENT RATIO WE WERE DEAD LAST.
THAT IS UNACCEPTABLE.
I THINK IT'S NOT AN EXAGGERATION
TO SAY THAT WE ARE FAILING THE
PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA WHEN IT
COMES TO K. TWELVE EDUCATION.
DOWN.
TO THE ROOT CAUSE OF THAT IS
THAT WE ARE FORTY FIRST.
IN TERMS OF PER PUPIL SPENDING.
THAT NEEDS TO BE RECTIFIED IT
NEEDS TO BE RECTIFIED
IMMEDIATELY THIS IS A SMALL STEP
IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION IN TERMS
OF PROVIDING ADEQUATE FUNDING
FOR OUR K. TWELVE SCHOOL SYSTEM
AND I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST WITH
RESPECT YOUR AYE AYE.
HEY WE TRY THAT AGAIN
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR AYE
VOTE ON THIS EXCELLENT BILL.
THANK YOU MISTER OBERNOLTE MS
BAUER QUE HAN YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND I
ALSO RISE AS A PROUD CO AUTHOR
OF THIS BILL AND A PRODUCT OF
THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC SCHOOLS
AND WE IN THIS BODY DON'T ACCEPT
BEING.
THE BOTTOM IN THE NATION IN
ANYTHING AND WE DEFINITELY
SHOULDN'T ACCEPTING THE FORTY
FIRST IN THE BASIN WHEN IT COMES
TO PER PEOPLE FUNDING.
WE ARE THE FIFTH LARGEST ECONOMY
IN THE WORLD AND WE NEED TO PUT
OUR MONEY WHERE OUR MOUTH IS WE
NEED TO PUT.
OUR BUDGET SHOULD BE A STATEMENT
OF OUR VALUES AND OUR CHILDREN
ARE OUR FUTURE AND THIS BILL IS
AN IMPORTANT STATEMENT THAT WE
ARE GOING TO PUT THEM FIRST AND
ENSURE THAT OUR SCHOOLS UP AND
DOWN CALIFORNIAN EVERYONE OF OUR
DISTRICTS.
ARE ADEQUATELY FUNDED SO THAT
OUR CHILDREN CAN GET THE
EDUCATION THEY DESERVE IN THE
ONE THAT WILL PREPARE THEM FOR
THE TWENTY FIRST CENTURY JOBS
THAT THEY ARE GOING TO FACE WHEN
THEY GRADUATE.
SO I RISE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE ON THIS BILL THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU MS BARRICADE HAND.
AND MISTER MEDINA YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I RISE
WEARING RED TODAY. FOR WEAR RED
FOR RED AS A PROUD TEACHER FOR
THIRTY FOUR YEARS IN THE
CLASSROOM.
AND AS A SCHOOL BOARD MEMBER.
I I DON'T THINK NUMBER -- FORTY
ONE IS EXIT IS ACCEPTABLE.
IN CALIFORNIA.
AND I THINK THAT THE I
CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS VOTERS
EXPECT BETTER.
WHETHER IT'S HIGHER EDUCATION --
AND WE CELEBRATED UCLA AND IT'S
HUNDREDS BIRTHDAY OR IT'S K.
TWELVE EDUCATION I THINK
CALIFORNIA MUST DO BETTER --
PROUD TO STAND IN SUPPORT OF AB.
THIRTY NINE THANK YOU MISTER
MEDINA MISS WICKS YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES I RISE AS A CO AUTHOR
OF AB THIRTY NINE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
AND URGE EVERYONE TO SUPPORT
THIS AS IT'S BEEN MENTIONED.
WE ARE FORTY FIRST IN THE NATION
ARE FOR PEOPLE SPENDING OUR
THIRD GRADE MATH AND READING
SCORES ARE FORTY THIRD IN THE
NATION.
OUR TEACHERS ARE DOING
EVERYTHING THEY CAN WITH THE
RESOURCES THAT THEY HAVE IN
THEIR HEROES.
WE HAVE TO SUPPORT OUR EDUCATORS
WE HAVE TO SUPPORT OUR SCHOOLS
ARE BUDGET REFLECTS OUR VALUES.
I WOULD STRONGLY URGE EVERYONE
SUPPORT THIS BILL SO WE CAN BE
NUMBER ONE IN THE NATION AS WE
HAVE BEEN.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MS WICKS SEEING NO
ADDITIONAL.
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
MR MURATSUCHI MY CLOTHES.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I REALLY
APPRECIATE ALL OF THE THE
COMMENTS FROM -- THE JOINT
AUTHORS IN THE CO AUTHORS OF
THIS BILL ACROSS.
PARTY LINES I ESPECIALLY
APPRECIATE THE THE COMMENTS OF
OUR REPUBLICAN NO BUDGET VICE
CHAIR -- THIS IS NOT A PARTISAN
ISSUE.
WE ALL HAVE A STAKE AND HAVING
STRONG.
PUBLIC SCHOOLS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND WE CANNOT DO THAT
BY BEING FORTY FOUR AT THE FORTY
FIRST IN THE NATION IN PER
PEOPLE SPENDING.
LET ME JUST EMPHASIZE ONE LAST
THING WHICH IS THAT WE HAVE DONE
THIS BEFORE IN TWENTY THIRTEEN
WE SET.
THE FUNDING TARGETS FOR THE
LOCAL CONTROL FUNDING FORMULA
GOVERNOR BROWN MADE SURE THAT HE
KEPT OUR EYES ON THE PRIZE IN
SAID BENCHMARKS IN TERMS OF
INCREASING ELSE YEAH.
BE K. THROUGH TWELVE FUNDING IN
TWENTY THIRTEEN TO SET THE GOAL
TO RESTORE THE CUTS THAT WERE
MADE DURING THE GREAT RECESSION.
THIS IS L. C. F. F. TWO POINT NO
TO SET THE NEXT ROUND OF FUNDING
TARGETS SO SO THAT WE CAN GO
FROM GOOD TO GREAT.
WHICH IS WHERE.
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA SHOULD
BE I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER MURATSUCHI WITH
THAT CLARK LOCAL THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS OF THE DESIRE TO
VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTE WE DESIRE
TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS OF OUR DESIRE TO
VOTE [inaudible]
PARK WELL.
CLOSER ROLE TELEVOTE.
I SIXTY FOUR NO.
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES.
FILE ITEM SIXTY NINE THROUGH.
SEVENTY TO PASS AND RETAIN.
WHERE FILE ITEM SEVENTY THREE AB
FIFTY ONE BY MS GONZALEZ CORKERY?
ASSEMBLY BILL FIFTY ONE BY
SOMETHING MEMBER GONZALEZ AND
ACTUALLY TO EMPLOYMENT.
THIS IS ALICE YOU MAY OPEN THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER.
OUR LEGISLATURE IN OUR STATE HAS
PASSED IN THE STRONGEST WORKER
PROTECTIONS IN THE COUNTRY AGAIN
SEXUAL HARASSMENT PAY INEQUITY
DISCRIMINATION WAGE THAT.
AND OTHER AGREE JUST LABOR
VIOLATIONS.
BUT THESE LAWS ARE COMPLETELY
WORTHLESS IF THEY CAN'T BE
ENFORCED IN COURT OR BY STATE
AGENCIES BECAUSE AN EMPLOYER HAS
FORCED THEIR WORKERS TO SIGN
AWAY THEIR RIGHTS.
IN AN ARBITRATION AGREEMENT IN
ORDER TO OBTAIN OR KEEP THEIR
JOB.
MANDATING THAT EMPLOYERS.
EMPLOYEES USE ARBITRATION TO
RESOLVE CLAIMS ALLOWS THE
COMPANY TO FORCE THEIR WORKERS
INTO SECRETIVE HEARINGS WHICH
HIGH LABOR VIOLATIONS FROM THE
PUBLIC.
PROTECT SERIAL ABUSERS AND
ULTIMATELY SILENCES VICTIMS.
SINCE THE RISE OF THE ME TOO
MOVEMENT WE'VE CONTINUE TO SEE
WORKERS HAVE BEEN VICTIMS OF
SEXUAL HARASSMENT OR
DISCRIMINATION ON THE JOB SPEAK
UP AND SPEAK OUT AGAINST US AND
JUST PRACTICE FORCED ARBITRATION.
THROUGH COLLECTIVE ACTION
EARLIER THIS YEAR WE SAW GOOGLE
WORKERS REFUSE TO ACCEPT BINDING
ARBITRATION AS A CONDITION OF
EMPLOYMENT.
BUT BECAUSE THEY HAVE LEVERAGE
IN ACCESS THEY WERE ABLE TO GET
GOOGLE TO CHANGE THEIR POLICIES
UNFORTUNATELY MOST OF THE
WORKERS WORKING AT LOW WAGE JOBS
YOU DON'T EVEN UNDERSTAND WHAT
THEY'RE SIGNING DON'T HAVE THIS
KIND OF LEVERAGE.
ARBITRATION CAN BE A HIGHLY
EFFECTIVE DISPUTE RESOLUTION
ESPECIALLY WHEN BOTH PARTIES
FREELY AND HAVE EQUAL.
ENTER INTO IT FREELY
INVOLUNTARILY AND HAVE EQUAL
BARGAINING POWER.
IT'S FAR LESS SUCCESSFUL WHEN
ONE PRAYS ABILITY TO EARN A
LIVING DEPENDS ON SIGNED AN
AGREEMENT TO WAIVE THEIR
STATUTORY RIGHTS.
AB FIFTY ONE IS NARROWLY
TAILORED TO SIMPLY REQUIRE THAT
EMPLOYEES ARE ABLE TO CHOOSE TO
SIGN SUCH AGREEMENTS WITHOUT THE
THREAT OF JOB LOSS OR
RETALIATION.
IT DOESN'T PROHIBIT EMPLOYERS
FROM USING ARBITRATION OR
ARBITRATION AGREEMENTS TO
RESOLVE WORKPLACE DISPUTES AS
LONG AS A WORKER AGREES.
THIS BILL EXPRESSLY STATES THAT
IT'S NOT INTENDED TO INVALIDATE
ANY EXISTING ARBITRATION
AGREEMENT.
OTHERWISE ENFORCEABLE BY LAW OR
TO APPLY TO POST DISPUTE
SETTLEMENT AGREEMENTS IN
NEGOTIATED SEVERANCE AGREEMENTS
THE BOTTOM LINE IS ALL CONTRACTS
MUST BE VOLUNTARY NOT THE RESULT
OF COERCION.
MANY OF YOU HAVE ALREADY VOTE ON
THIS BILL ASHER AND I HOPE THAT
YOU'LL DO THE SAME THIS YEAR I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS GONZALES SAYING.
NO DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE ITEM.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE THE DESIRE TO
VOTE
.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE ABOUT
ALL MEMBER SERVICE OUT OF A
CLARK WELL.
CLOSER ROLL TIDE ABOUT EYES
FORTY THREE KNOWS.
FIFTEEN THAT MEASURE PASSES
PASSER TâM FILE ITEM.
SEVENTY FOUR FILE ITEM SEVENTY
FIVE IS AB SIXTY EIGHT
CORPORATION ASSEMBLY BILL SIXTY
EIGHT BY FAMILY MEMBER TING AND
OTHERS AND ACTUALLY THE LAND USE
MISTER TECH.
THEY GIVE IT SPEAKER -- MEMBERS
ARE PRESENT IN THE FIRST OF TWO
BILLS ON ACCESSORY DWELLING
UNITS.
AS WE ALL KNOW WE ARE IN A
HOUSING AFFORDABILITY CRISIS ONE
OF THE FASTEST WAYS THAT WE CAN
BUILD HOUSING IS TO BUILD EXCEPT
THREE DWELLING UNITS WITH THEIR
IN YOUR BACKYARD WITH THEIR IN
YOUR BASEMENT OR IN YOUR GARAGE.
IT'S ALSO ONE OF THE CHEAPEST
AND MOST AFFORDABLE WAY TO DO IT
IN AND ALSO CONFORMS. TO OUR
NEIGHBORHOODS UNFORTUNATELY MANY
CITIES HAVE GONE AFTER IN TRYING
TO BAN THIS TYPE OF HOUSING IS A
WE ARE ASKING FOR YOUR SUPPORT
FOR E. A. B. SIXTY EIGHT TO
REALLY STREAMLINED EXCEPT FOR
DRAWING UNITS.
WHICH AGAIN PEOPLE USED -- TO
WELCOME BACK FAMILY MEMBERS
HOUSE -- ADULT CHILDREN BUT ALSO --
TO POTENTIALLY ADD HOUSING STOCK
TO THE PARTICULAR NEIGHBORHOOD
THAT REALLY FITS IN THEIR
NEIGHBORHOOD WITHOUT A
RESPECTFULLY ASK WHEN I BILL FOR
A. B..
SIXTY EIGHT THANK YOU MISSION
TANKS SEE NO DISCUSSION DEBATE.
OR CLUB THE ROLE.
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE VOTE.
ALL MEMBER SERVICE ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT EYES FOUR
NINE NO SEVEN THAT MEASURE
PASSES FILE ITEM SEVENTY SIX IS
AB SIXTY NINE CORPORATE.
ASSEMBLY BILL SIXTY NINE BY
FAMILY MEMBER TING AND OTHERS
AND ACTUALLY THE LAND USE MR
TING YOU MAKE AN OPEN.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AB
SIXTY NINE HOURS THE DEPARTMENT
OF HOUSING CAN BE DEVELOPMENT TO
DEVELOP A SMALL HOUSE.
BUILDING STANDARDS CODE FOR
EXCESS WRIGGLING UNITS IN
PARTICULAR FOR SMALLER KITCHEN
SMALL APPLIANCES REALLY WANT TO
WORK WITH THE DEPARTMENT TO MAKE
SURE.
THAT WE HAVE CODES FOR THOSE OF
US WHO ARE INTERESTED IN
BUILDING ASSESSMENT ALL UNITS I
WITHOUT I RESPECTFULLY ASK FRONT.
NAMES TANK MISS QUIRK SILVA HERE
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS I RISE IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL.
AB.
CANNOT SEE IT BUT I SUPPORT THIS
BILL AS WE HAVE BEEN TALKING
THIS YEAR ABOUT HOUSING WE HAVE
MADE IT A PRIORITY AS A CAUCUS
AND THIS IS A UNIQUE AND
CREATIVE WAY TO GO BACKWARDS
WHICH IS ACTUALLY TO BUILD
GRANNY FLATS OR MOTHER IN LAW.
UNITS AND USE EXISTING LAN THIS
OF THESE TYPES OF HOUSING CAN BE
USED FOR FAMILY MEMBERS TEACHERS
OF MANY DIFFERENT PEOPLE AND I
THINK THIS IS ONE OF THE WAYS TO
HELP SOLVE OUR HOUSING CRISIS
AND I ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU MS QUIRK SILVA SAY NO
ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION DEBATE
MISTING YOU MAY CLOSE IF YOU
WISH.
WITH THAT CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLE.
ZARA BUT ALL MEMBERS VOTER
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE OR DESIRE TO
VOTE [inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSE YOUR ROLL TIDE ABOUT AYE
AYES.
FIFTY FOUR NO ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES FILE ITEM SEVENTY SEVEN
AND SEVENTY EIGHT PASS RETAIN.
WHERE FILE ITEM SEVENTY NINE AB
ONE THIRTY BY MISTER LOWE CLERK
WILL READ ASSEMBLY BILL ONE
THIRTY BY SOME A MEMBER LOW AND
OTHERS AND ACTUALLY TO POST
SECONDARY EDUCATION?
MR LOW YOU MAIL THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR SPEAKER MEMBERS AB ONE
THIRTY A FOCUS ON THE POST
SECONDARY EDUCATION SEGMENTS
ENSURING THAT ALL OF OUR
EDUCATION SEGMENTS HAVE A
CONVERSATION WITH EACH OTHER
RESPECTFULLY ASK PRIVATE.
THANK YOU MISTER LOWE SAYING NO
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE ITEM
QUIRK LOVE THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE -- DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
IS THAT ABOUT.
WELL CLOSER ROLL TIDE ABOUT AYE
AYES.
FIFTY SIX NO ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES FILE ITEMS EIGHTY THROUGH
EIGHTY TO PASS RETAIN.
FILE ITEM EIGHTY THREE IS AB ONE
SIXTY BY MISTER VOEPEL.
GREGORY ASSEMBLY BILL ONE SIXTY
BY FAMILY MEMBER VOEPEL AND
OTHERS AND ACTUALLY TO
EMPLOYMENT.
THE SHOW WILL TELL.
MISTER SPEAKER COLLEAGUES.
TODAY I HAVE THE PLEASURE
PRESIDING AB ONE SIXTY A BILL
THAT WOULD ALLOW THE PRIVATE
SECTOR THE ABILITY TO ENACT A
VOLUNTARY VETERANS PREFERENCE
PROGRAM.
VOLUNTARY VETERANS PREFERENCES
RECOGNIZE AND ENJOYED A BUG THE
PUBLIC SECTOR HOWEVER THE
PRIVATE SECTOR IS LIMITED TO
ONLY VIETNAM WAR ERA VETERANS
WHEN EXERCISING THEIR VOLUNTARY
VETERANS PRESENTS.
AB ONE SIXTY SIMPLY REVISE
REVISES AN OUTDATED OVERSIGHT BY
ALLOWING THE PRIVATE SECTOR TO
EXERCISE THEIR VOLUNTARY
VETERANS PREFERENCE TO ALL
VETERANS WITH THE GENERAL OR
HONORABLE DISCHARGE REGARDLESS
OF THE ERA IN WHICH THEY SERVE.
WITH AMENDMENTS AND HELP FROM
MEMBERS FROM SAN JOSE AND SAN
DIEGO THE VOLUNTARY VETERANS
PREFERENCE WOULD NOT BECOME
OPERATIVE INTO THE PROHIBITION
AGAINST TRANS GENDER INDIVIDUALS
FROM SERVING IN THE U. S. ARMED
FORCES UNDER FEDERAL LAW.
IS RESCINDED FOR THESE REASONS
MEMBERS I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER VOEPEL MISTER
GLORIA YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER JUST VERY
BRIEFLY I WANT TO THANK MY
COLLEAGUE FROM SANTEE FOR THOSE
AMENDMENTS. TO LINE THIS WAS
SOME EQUITABLE -- CONCERNS I'D
DEFINITELY ASK FOR EITHER ON
THIS LEGISLATION.
THANK YOU MISS GLORIA SEE NO
ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION ON THE
ITEM CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF A
CLARK WELL.
CLOSE ROLE THÅU THE VOTE EYES
FIFTY NINE NO.
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES FILE
ITEM.
EIGHTY FOUR AB ONE SIX THREE BY
THIS GARCIA CORKERY AT SOME
LEVEL ONE SIXTY THREE BY FAMILY
MEMBER CRISTINA GARCIA AND
OTHERS AND ACTUALLY THE PUBLIC
SOCIAL SERVICES.
MS GARCIA YOU MAIL BUT THANK YOU
GOOD MORNING WE'VE ALL BEEN
READING THE NEWS LATELY ABOUT.
IMMIGRATION ENFORCEMENT POLICIES
THAT HAVE SEPARATED FAMILIES
WE'VE BEEN HEARING ABOUT
UNDOCUMENTED CHILDREN OUT THERE.
ANY OF THESE CHILDREN ARE IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA ARE IN A
STATELICENSED FACILITY OUT
THERE.
ON IN SO WE COULD LEVERAGES
LICENSE TO MAKE SURE KIDS ARE
HAVING THE SERVICES THEY NEED TO
MAKE SURE THEY'RE HEALTHY AND
ARE BEING TAKEN CARE OF JUST
THIS MORNING THERE WAS AN
INVESTIGATION BY THE LA TIMES.
ABOUT THE INADEQUACY OF THE
SERVICES BEING PROVIDED TO KEEP
THESE KIDS SAFE OUT THERE.
SO IN LIGHT OF THIS WE ARE IN
WORKING ON AB.
ONE SIXTY THREE OUR WHICH WOULD
CREATE A FACILITIES THE ACE
OPPOSITION TO CONNECT THE
VARIOUS STYLES OF HEALTH IN THE
CHILDREN ARE PLACE AND WITH
SUPPORT SERVICES INCLUDED BUT
NOT LIMITED TO LEGAL SERVICES.
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
ASSESSMENT PUBLIC BENEFITS A LOT
OF THIS OP FELT HOT LIST AND ARE
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO HELP
THESE FAMILIES AND WE GET.
SIDE -- INSIDERS WE HEAR ABOUT
THE CHILDREN WHO ARE DYING WE
DECIDE ANOTHER TWO YEAR OLD FROM
WHAT THE MOTHER PASSED AWAY
RECENTLY.
ON AND SO THIS IS ONE WAY FOR US
TO LEVERAGE OUR STATE LICENSE TO
MAKE SURE THIS GETS ARE SAFER
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MS GARCIA SAYING NO
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE ITEM
CORPORAL OF THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS OF THE THE DESIRE TO
VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF THE
CLARK WELL.
CLOSER ROLE AND TALLY THE VOTE.
AYE AYES FORTY FOUR KNOWS.
FOR THAT MEASURE PASSES FILE
ITEM EIGHTY FIVE IS AB ONE SIXTY
SIX BY MR GABRIEL CORPORATION.
ASSEMBLY BILL ONE SIXTY SIX BY
SOMETHING MEMBER GABRIEL AND
OTHERS AND ACTUALLY MEDI CAL.
SURE GABRIEL.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I AM
PLEASED TODAY TO PRESENT AB ONE
SIXTY SIX A BILL TO PROVIDE
MEDICARE REIMBURSEMENT. FOR
PROFESSIONAL VIOLENCE PREVENTION
SERVICES FOR VICTIMS OF GUN
VIOLENCE AND OTHER INCIDENTS.
THESE VIOLENCE PREVENTION
SERVICES HAVE PROVEN REMARKABLY
EFFECTIVE AT BREAKING THE CYCLE
OF VIOLENCE THAT IMPACTS FAR TOO
MANY OF OUR COMMUNITIES IN
CALIFORNIA.
WITH THIS BILL CALIFORNIA WOULD
INVEST IN PREVENTION SERVICES
AND TREAT GUN VIOLENCE AS THE
PUBLIC HEALTH CRISIS THAT IT IS.
AB ONE SIX SIX WOULD LEVERAGE
FEDERAL MEDICAID DOLLARS TO
CREATE SUSTAINABLE FUNDING
STREAM FOR THESE PROGRAMS.
BY EXPANDING UTILIZATION OF THE
SERVICES THIS LEGISLATION WOULD
SAVE LIVES PROTECT TAXPAYER
FUNDS REDUCE BURDENS ON THE
MEDICAL AND JUDICIAL SYSTEM AND
ADDRESS TROUBLING RACIAL
DISPARITIES IN HEALTH OUTCOMES.
THIS BILL PASSED POLICY
COMMITTEE WITH BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT IT IS SUPPORTED BY
PHYSICIANS SURGEONS AND VIOLENCE
PREVENTION PROFESSIONALS I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS GABRIEL.
SAYING NO DISCUSSION DEBATE ON
THE ITEM CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLE.
MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE ON
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF A
CLARK WELL.
CLOSER ROLE AND TALLY THE VOTE
EYES.
FORTY THREE KNOWS.
FIVE THAT MEASURE PASSES.
FILE ITEM EIGHTY SIX IS AB ONE
SEVENTY FIVE BY MISTER GIBSON
CORPORATION ASSEMBLY BILL ONE
SEVENTY FIVE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
GIPSON AND ACTUALLY TO FOSTER
CARE.
MR GIPSON HE MAY OPEN.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS I RISE IN
SUPPORT OF ASSEMBLY BILL ONE
SEVENTY FIVE WHICH SIX TOMATO
RISE THE FOSTER YOUTH BILL OF
RIGHTS -- BY ADDING RIGHTS THAT
ARE INCLUSIVE OF THE NEEDS AND
EXPERIENCE OF TODAY'S YOU.
FOSTER YOU HAVE TO OVERCOME
OBSTACLES AND HAVE A HIGH RATE
OF UNEMPLOYMENT AND
INCARCERATIONS.
THESE YOU HAVE A FEW PEOPLE TO
TURN TO THAT CAN HELP THEM
UNDERSTAND THE RESOURCES AND THE
RIGHTS ENTITLED TO THEM THROUGH
THE FOSTER CARE SYSTEM.
AB ONE SEVENTY FIVE WELL AT
PROVISIONS THAT INCLUDES THE
RIGHTS TO RECEIVE GROOMING.
HYGIENE PRODUCTS REGARDLESS OF
SEXUAL ORIENTATION OR GENDER
IDENTITY. TO BE PREFERRED TO
REFER TO BUY THEIR PREFERENCE BY
THE PREFERRED NAME OR PRONOUN --
TO HAVE A REASONABLE ACCESS TO
COMPUTER TECHNOLOGY AND TO THE
INTERNET AMONG OTHER THINGS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK WHEN I VOTE ON
AB.
ONE SEVENTY FIVE THANK YOU MISS
GIVE SEN MS MELENDEZ.
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN I DON'T DISAGREE
WITH THE AUTHOR THAT WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE.
THAT -- FOSTER YOU'VE HAD HAVE
ACCESS TO THE THINGS ARE THAT
THEY NEED TO HAVE A HEALTHY.
LIFE AND AN ENVIRONMENT IN WHICH
TO GROW UP BUT THIS BILL GOES
TOO FAR THIS BILL SAYS THAT.
THE FOSTER YOUTH AND I DON'T
KNOW WHO DETERMINES -- HOW FAR
THIS GOES BUT WHEN IT SAYS?
THEY HAVE A RIGHT TO AN
ALLOWANCE.
THOSE OF YOU WHO HAVE.
CHILDREN WHO YOUR ARE YOUR
BIOLOGICAL CHILDREN.
DO YOU WOULD IT BE PROPER FOR
THE GOVERNMENT TO COME IN AND
TELL YOU AS A PARENT.
YOUR CHILD HAS A RIGHT TO AN
ALLOWANCE THAT YOU MUST PAY.
IT'S AN APPROPRIATE.
YOUR THE FOSTER YOUTH HAS THE
RIGHT TO REASONABLE ACCESS TO
THE INTERNET.
WHAT IS REASONABLE AND WHO
DECIDES WHAT REASONABLE IS?
BECAUSE IN MY HOUSE WE LIMIT
INTERNET ACCESS AS PROBABLY MANY
OF YOU DO BUT THAT'S I AM THE
PARENT SO I DECIDE WHAT'S
REASONABLE IN THIS PARTICULAR
SITUATION I'M NOT CERTAIN.
THAT THE FOSTER PARENTS ARE
GOING TO BE THE ONES WHO ARE
ALLOWED TO DECIDE WHAT IS
REASONABLE.
SO I WOULD.
ASK YOU TO THINK VERY CAREFULLY
ABOUT THIS BILL BECAUSE I THINK
IT GOES TOO FAR.
SEE NO ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION --
THE ITEM MISTER GIVES YOU MAY
CLOSE THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
SPEAKER -- APPRECIATE MY
COLLEAGUES FOR HER --
CONVERSATION THIS BILL MEMBERS
ARE CHILDREN WHO ARE IN FOSTER
CARE ALREADY ARE IN TRAUMA WE
ALREADY DO A NUMBER OF TRAUMA
WE'RE ASKING -- IN THIS BILL FOR
YOU TO TREAT THESE INDIVIDUALS
THESE CHILDREN WHO ARE ALREADY
TRAUMATIZED TO TREAT THEM LIKE
YOU WOULD TREAT YOUR OWN CHILD
COMING TO A LOVING HOME.
ALL PEOPLE GIVE MONEY TO THEIR
CHILDREN WITH AS MUCH MONEY BUS
MONEY WHATEVER -- IN THE BILL --
FOSTER YOUTH ALREADY ARE ALLOWED
SUCH ALLOWANCE.
WE'RE SIMPLY ASKING FOR ONE
THESE CHILDREN TO BE TREATED
JUST LIKE YOU WHICH REACH ARE
ALL WITH LOVE WITH RESPECT WHICH
CREATING A FOUNDATION SO THAT
THEY CAN -- ONE GREW UP TO BE
GREAT CITIZENS IN OUR SOCIETY
MEMBERS LAST WEEK ASK FOR A A
RESOUNDING AYE VOTE OR AB.
ONE SEVENTY FIVE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE
ON MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF A
CLICK WELL.
CLOSE YOUR ROLL TIDE ABOUT ICE
FORTY ONE KNOWS SEVEN THAT
MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS ON BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY
MEMBER TODD GLORIA.
WE WOULD LIKE TO WELCOME HOME A
CLASS OF STUDENTS FROM HIS
DISTRICT WE HAVE FIFTY FIFTH AND
SIXTH GRADE STUDENTS FROM
SKYLINE ELEMENTARY SCHOOL.
IN SOLANA BEACH IN HIS DISTRICT
WELCOME TO THE ASSEMBLY
.
MEMBERS BACK ON THE FILE FILE
ITEM EIGHTY SEVEN AB ONE SEVENTY
SIX BY MISS CERVANTES CORPORATE.
ASSEMBLY BILL ONE SEVENTY SIX BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CERVANTES AND
ACTUALLY TO ALTERNATIVE ENERGY.
MR BONTA S..
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
I INTRODUCED AB ONE SEVENTY SIX
BASED ON MY WRIST MY
RESPONSIBILITIES AS THE CHAIR OF
THE ASSEMBLY JOBS COMMITTEE IN
THE UPCOMING SUNSET ON A PROGRAM
THE COMMITTEE OVERSEAS.
IN DECEMBER TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN THE ALLEY -- RELEASES
STATE MANDATED REPORT ON THE
EFFECTIVENESS OF THE SALES AND
USE TAX EXCLUSION PROGRAM.
GIVEN THE SIGNIFICANCE OF THE
ALLEY OWES RECOMMENDATIONS ON
THIS PROGRAM I BELIEVE IT IS
APPROPRIATE FOR MORE INFORMATION
TO BECOME AVAILABLE PRIOR TO
ADDRESSING THE EXTENSION OF THE
PROGRAM.
THIS BILL REQUIRES A CALIFORNIA
ALTERNATIVE ENERGY IN ADVANCE
TRANSPORTATION FINANCING
AUTHORITY TO FORMALLY RESPOND TO
THE FINDINGS AND RECOMMENDATIONS
IN THE ALLEY -- REPORT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER MARTIN'S SEEING
NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
VOTERS ARE VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE THE DESIRE TO
VOTE [inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT ICE FIFTY
EIGHT NO ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES FILE ITEMS. EIGHTY EIGHT
THROUGH NINETY THREE HOUSE
RETAIN.
WE ARE GOING TO TAKE A FILE ITEM.
NINETY FOUR AB TWO TWO EIGHT BY
MISS AGUILAR CURRY CLERK WILL
READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWO TWENTY EIGHT
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER AGUIAR-CURRY
AND ACTUALLY TO INDUSTRIAL HEMP
DECLINE THEIR TO SEE THEIR UP TO
TAKE EFFECT IMMEDIATELY.
MS AGUIAR-CURRY THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS AB TWO TWO EIGHT
CLARIFIES THAT A FOOD OR
COSMETIC CANNOT BE PROHIBITED
BASED SOLELY ON THE FACT THAT IT
CONTAINS.
HAMPER DERIVES CBD.
HEMP IS NOT MARIJUANA THE CVT
CAN BE EXTRACTED FROM BOTH WHEN
IT IS PRODUCED FROM HIM THERE
ARE NO PSYCHOACTIVE EFFECTS.
THIS IS BECAUSE HIM CONTAINS
THREE TENTHS OF A PERCENT THC OR
LESS AND T. H. C. IS A
PSYCHOACTIVE COMPONENT IN
CANNABIS.
MANY CALIFORNIA CONSUMERS
CURRENTLY PURCHASED HIM CVD
PRODUCTS TODAY AT COFFEE SHOPS
JIM'S WELLNESS STORES WITHOUT
KNOWING THAT IS TECHNICALLY NOT
LEGAL.
FURTHER THE MANUFACTURE IN THE
SALE OF HIM CVD IS RAPIDLY
EXPANDING WITH OVER A THOUSAND
EMPLOYEES AND MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS WORTH OF ECONOMIC
PRODUCTIVITY IN CALIFORNIA.
SHOULD WE CHOOSE NOT TO CLARIFY
THAT HIP CVT PRODUCTS ARE LEGAL
FOR THE SALE AND CONSUMPTION
THESE JOBS AND BUSINESSES WILL
BE LOST.
I HAVE NEGOTIATED AMENDMENTS
THAT I WILL TAKE IN THE SENATE
TO CLARIFY DEFINITIONS AND ADD
LABORATORY TESTING REQUIREMENTS
TO THE BILL
AB TWO TWO EIGHT HAS RECEIVED BY
PARTISAN IN UNANIMOUS SUPPORT SO
FAR.
I SIMPLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MS AGUIAR-CURRY SAYING
NO DISCUSSION DEBATE CLERK WILL
OF THE ROLE.
RETIRED AT ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
OUT OF A ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT
OF A THIS TAKES FIFTY FOR ALL
MEMBERS VOTE THE DESIRE TO VOTE
CLERK WELL.
CLOSE YOUR ROLE IN CHILD ABOUT
AYE SIXTY ONE KNOWS YOU'RE ON
THE URGENCY AYE SIXTY ONE NO
ZERO ON THE BILL THAT MEASURE
PASSES MEMBERS I'M PREPARED TO
LIFT THE CALL ON FILE ITEM.
TWELVE A. B. SIXTEEN HUNDRED
CARPAL.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
CLERK WILL.
CLOSER ROLE AND TALLY THE VOTE
EYES FORTY TWO KNOWS.
TWENTY THAT MEASURE PASSES.
FILE ITEM NINETY FIVE PASS AND
RETAIN FILE ITEM NINETY SIX IS
AB TWO THIRTY FIVE AYE MR MAYES
CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWO THIRTY FIVE BY
SOME REMEMBER MAYES AND ACTUALLY
TO ELECTRICAL CORPORATIONS MR
MAYES.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I
MEMBERS TODAY I AM PROUD TO
PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL. TWO
THIRTY FIVE OVER THE PAST YEAR
AND A HALF I'VE JOINED
COLLEAGUES IN THE ASSEMBLY AND
SENATE AND IN BEING DEEPLY
ENGAGE WITH ALL STAKEHOLDERS AND
ADMINISTRATION.
ABOUT THE ISSUES CALIFORNIA'S
FACING WITH CATASTROPHIC
WILDFIRES EVENTS.
AS WE HAVE COME TO LEARN THIS IS
AN AREA OF EXTREMELY COMPLEX
PUBLIC POLICY THAT IS IN DIRE
NEED.
OF LEGISLATIVE DIRECTION SB NOT
A ONE TOOK THE FIRST MAJOR STEP
LAST UNIT IN SEEKING TO ADDRESS
UNCERTAINTY IN THE FINANCIAL
MARKETS.
AS WELL AS DRAWING ATTENTION TO
THE MASS OF VEGETATION
MANAGEMENT ISSUES WE FACE.
AMONG THE ISSUES WE MUST ADDRESS
THIS YEAR'S A SUBSTANTIAL
LIABILITIES THAT ARISE FROM
THESE FIRES.
WE KNOW THAT BANKRUPTCY IS NOT A
SOLUTION.
IT LEAVES FIRE VICTIMS ANXIOUSLY
WONDERING IF THEY WILL RECEIVE
PAYMENTS OR BE PRIORITIZE BEHIND
SHAREHOLDERS AND BOND HOLDERS.
WHY CONTINUE TO WORK WITH
INTERESTED PARTIES ON THE CREEK
PATH WAY TO RESOLVE THIS A
COMPLEX ISSUE THIS BILL
CURRENTLY PROVIDES A MODIFIED
STRESS TEST INSPIRED BY SB NINE
A?
ONE THEY'LL PLAY IN THE CASE OF
WILDFIRES STARTING IN TWENTY
NINETEEN MOVING FORWARD BUT DOES
NOT APPLY TO TWENTY TWENTY
EIGHTEEN FIRES.
I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR
ASSISTANCE AND GUIDANCE ON HOW
TO CRAFT A POLICY SOLUTION WILL
PROVIDE CLARITY.
PROTECT FIRE VICTIMS AND ALLOW
OUR PUBLIC AND PRIVATE UTILITIES
TO DO THEIR JOB A KEEP THE
LIGHTS ON THANK YOU MISTER MAYES
DOCTOR WOULD YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS I BELIEVE THIS
BILL IS A PIECE OF THE SOLUTION
TO ONE OF THE BIGGEST THE MOST
PRESSING PROBLEMS ARE
LEGISLATURE NEEDS TO SOLVE THIS
YEAR.
SINCE SB NINE A ONE CONFERENCE
COMMITTEE LAST YEAR I'VE BEEN
WORKING WITH MY COLLEAGUE FROM
YUCCA VALLEY ABOUT A FRAMEWORK
THAT WILL SOLVE THIS COMPLICATED
IN IN NORMAN SLEE EXPENSIVE
PROBLEM.
OF WHO PAYS FOR CATASTROPHIC
WILDFIRES AND HOW IS THAT
PAYMENT FINANCE.
THE CONCEPT OF AN INDEPENDENT
WHILE FAR FUND PROPOSED IN THIS
BILL IS ONE THAT I'M CONVINCED
WOULD BE A PART OF THE OVERALL
SOLUTION.
MEMBERS THE CATASTROPHIC
WILDFIRES HAVE DESTROYED
COMMUNITIES ALL ACROSS OUR STATE
HAVE BEEN A DEVASTATING REMINDER
OF HOW VULNERABLE WE ARE.
HOW MUCH WORK NEEDS TO BE DONE
TO REPAIR KIT COMMUNITIES FOR A
CHANGING CLIMATE?
THAT WORK IS NOT JUST BUILDING
AND HARDENING ARE INFRASTRUCTURE
BUT ENSURING OUR LAWS IN
GOVERNMENT SYSTEMS PROVIDE THE
STABILITY.
AND AGILITY THAT WE REQUIRED IN
A RAPIDLY CHANGING WORLD.
THIS WORK IS BEING DONE IN THIS
BILL AS PART OF A UP THAT LARGER
GOAL I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
I'VE OF THANK YOU DOCTOR
WOULDN'T.
SEE NO ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THE ITEM CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROOM.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE THE DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF A
CLICK WELL.
CLOSE THE ROLE TALLY THE VOTE
AYE AYES FORTY TWO KNOWS.
TO THAT MEASURE PASSES.
FILE ITEM NINETY SEVEN PASS
RETAIN WE ARE FILE ITEM NINETY
EIGHT AB.
TWO FORTY THREE BY MISS
KAMLAGER-DOVE.
COVERAGE.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWO FORTY THREE BY
SOME REMEMBER KAMLAGER-DOVE AND
OTHERS AND ACTUALLY TO PEACE
OFFICERS.
MS KAMLAGER-DOVE.
THANK YOU GOOD MORNING MISTER
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I AM
PRESENTING ASSEMBLY BILL TWO
FORTY THREE WHICH WILL REQUIRE
PEACE OFFICER STANDARDS TRAINING
OPPOSED TO TRAIN PEACE OFFICERS
ON IMPLICIT BIAS.
EVERY TWO YEARS.
ARE WE COME TO THE TERMS AND WE
COME TO THE FACT THATEVERYONE
HAS THEIR OWN UNCONSCIOUS AN
IMPLICIT BIAS AS WE ALL DO.
THIS BILL IS PRAGMATIC IT IS
PREVENTATIVE IN FACT RESEARCHERS
AT STANFORD UNIVERSITY HAVE
EXAMINED ALMOST ONE HUNDRED
MILLION TRAFFIC STOPS FROM
TWENTY ELEVEN TO TWENTY
SEVENTEEN ACROSS.
TWENTY STATE PATROL AGENCIES.
NOTICING THAT BLACK AND LATINO
DRIVERS WERE STOP MORE OFTEN
THAN WHITEDRIVERS BASED ON LESS
EVIDENCE OF WRONGDOING.
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE HAS
EVEN RECOGNIZE THIS AND TAKEN
IMPORTANT STEPS TO DEAL WITH
IMPLICIT BIAS THAT AFFECTS OUR
LAW ENFORCEMENT POLICIES AND%
PROCEDURES.
AB TWO FOUR THREE SIX TO AMPLIFY
THE DOJ'S WORK ON IMPLICIT BIAS
AND MANDATE THAT PEACE OFFICERS
BE TRAINED EVERY TWO YEARS.
LET'S BUILD A CULTURE THAT
CONSTANTLY AND RESPECTFULLY
ADDRESSES BIAS TO STRENGTHEN THE
TRUST BETWEEN LAW ENFORCEMENT
AND OUR COMMUNITIES.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU MS KAMLAGER-DOVE
SEEING NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
COR CLUB THE ROLE.
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE ON MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
YEAH [inaudible]
KIRK WELL.
CLOSE THE ROLE CHAU VOTE AYE
AYES.
FORTY SEVEN KNOWS THREE THAT
MEASURE PASSES FILE ITEM NINETY
NINE IS AB TWO FORTY SEVEN BY
MISTER DALLI CORPORATION.
AS A LEGAL TWO FORTY SEVEN BY
FAMILY MEMBER DALLY AND ACTUALLY
TO DISASTER RELIEF DECLARING
THEIR AND SEE THEIR UP TO TAKE
EFFECT IMMEDIATELY.
MISTER DALLI YOU MAY OPEN THE
MEASURES BIGGER MEMBERS TODAY
I'M PRESENTING AB.
TWO FORTY SEVEN WHICH WILL
REQUIRE THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
TO COVER A 100% OF THE LOCAL
SHARE OF THE COSTS FOR DISASTER
RECOVERY FOR FOR THE CAR FIRE
AND SHASTA COUNTY.
THE KLAMATH ON FIRE IS THIS YOU
COUNTY BY ALLOWING THIS WE WILL
HELP THE COMMUNITIES CLEAN UP
AND REBUILD WHILE THEY ARE
HELPING THEM STAY FINANCIALLY
SOUND SO THEY'RE ABLE TO
CONTINUE. TO PROVIDE SERVICES
SUCH AS FIRE LAW ENFORCEMENT.
LET'S HELP THESE COMMITTEES GET
BACK ON THEIR FEET.
I'M CURRENTLY WORKING THROUGH
THE BUDGET PROCESS TO SECURE
THIS FUNDING.
AS WELL AS I WOULD LIKE TO SEE
THIS BILL CONTINUE MOVING
THROUGH THE PROCESS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER VALLEY SEEING
NO DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE ITEM
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
WORK WELL.
CLOSER ROLE AND TALLY THE VOTE I
SIXTY THREE NO ZERO ON THE
URGENCY.
AYE AYES SIXTY THREE NO ZERO ON
THE BILL THAT MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS WERE FILE ITEM.
ONE HUNDRED AB TWO FIFTY TWO BY
MISTER DALY CORPORATION.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWO FIFTY TWO BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER DALY AND OTHERS
AND ACTUALLY TRANSPORTATION.
MR DAILY.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER IN
MEMBERS THIS BILL ALLOWS
CALTRANS TO CONTINUE TO
PARTICIPATE IN THE NATIONAL
ENVIRONMENTAL PROTECTION AGENCY
ASSIGNMENT PROGRAM.
THIS ENABLES CALTRANS TO
STREAMLINE TRANSPORTATION
PROJECTS WITHOUT COMPROMISING
COMPLIANCE WITH ENVIRONMENTAL
LAWS AND REGULATIONS.
I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS DALY CITY NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE.
COR CLUB THE ROLE ALL MEMBERS OF
WE DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS OF THE DESIRE TO
VOTE [inaudible]
WORK WELL.
CLOSE ROLE TALLY THE VOTE I
SIXTY THREE KNOWS. ZERO THAT
MEASURE PASSES. FIVE LETTERS ONE
OH ONE THROUGH.
ONE OH THREE PASS RETAIN THIS IS.
FILE ITEM.
ONE OH FOUR AB TWO SEVENTY EIGHT
BY MISTER MCCARTY CORPORATION.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWO SEVENTY EIGHT
BY SOMETHING MEMBER MCCARTY AND
OTHERS AND ACTUALLY THE RESOURCE
CONSERVATION.
MR MCCARTY.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER THIS
BILL WOULD SIMPLY EXPAND
ELIGIBILITY AS FAR AS WHO CAN
PARTICIPATE WITHIN OUR
CALIFORNIA CONSERVATION CORPS.
WE KNOW ABOUT THE GREAT CORPS
PROGRAM THE SLOGAN IS HARD WORK
AND LOW PAY.
HELPING PEOPLE LEARN THEIR HIGH
SCHOOL DIPLOMAS FOCUSING ON LIFE
SKILLS BUT ALSO WORKING ON OUR
OUR FORESTRY MANAGEMENT ENERGY
AUDITING AND RIGHT NOW OF COURSE
FIGHTING OUR FIREFIGHTERS.
FIGHTING OUR FOREST FIRES
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA
UNFORTUNATELY PAROLEES ARE
EXCLUDED FROM PARTICIPATING IN
THIS PROGRAM WHICH IS
INTERESTING BECAUSE IF YOU ARE
INCARCERATED.
AND A STATE PRISON YOU CAN GO
AND FIGHT THE FIRES AS FAR AS
YOUR PRISON SENTENCE BUT WHEN
YOU'RE OUT OF PRISON ON PAROLE
YOU CAN'T VOLUNTEER TO SERVE AS
A MEMBER OF THE COURT AT THE
SAME EXACT WORK.
AT THIS WOULD HELP WITH THE
RECIDIVISM GIVE YOUNG PEOPLE AN
OPPORTUNITY AND AGAIN THIS WOULD
NOT BE.
MANDATORY THAT PEOPLE WOULD BE
ABLE TO BE ACCEPTED BUT ALLOW
THE COURT TO FOCUS ON A CASE BY
CASE BASIS ND POTENTIALLY ALLOW.
A PAROLE LEE TO PARTICIPATE.
THIS HAS BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND
ASK YOUR RIVAL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER MCCARTY MISTER
DEEP ERICA.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MISTER
SPEAKER I RISE IN SUPPORT OF AB
TWO SEVENTY EIGHT AND THANK MY
COLLEAGUE FROM.
A SACRAMENTO IN BRINGING THIS
MEASURE FOR A CALIFORNIA HAS ONE
OF THE HIHEST RATES OF
RECIDIVISM IN THE COUNTRY.
ABOUT 65% OF CALIFORNIANS WHO
LEAVE PRISON.
END UP BACK IN THE SYSTEM WITHIN
ONE YEAR.
A LACK OF THE REENTRY PROGRAMS
SUCH AS WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
AND EDUCATION PROGRAMS CONSTRUED
HIGHLY TO THIS PROBLEM.
THE CALIFORNIA CONSERVATION
CORPS IS A GREAT PROGRAM THAT
CAN PROVIDE PAROLEES THE
OPPORTUNITY TO LEARN NEW SKILLS.
AND SUCCESSFULLY INTEGRATE BACK
INTO OUR SOCIETY IN MY DISTRICT
THE ORANGE COUNTY CONSERVATION
CORPS PROVIDE HIGH PAID JOBS --
IN TRAINING PROGRAMS THAT
INSTILL A STRONG WORK ETHIC
WHILE PROVIDING EXPERIENCE AND
SKILLS THAT MAKE THEM EXCELLENT
CANDIDATES.
IN THE WORK FORCE THEY ARE EVEN --
THEY EVEN PROVIDE EDUCATION
OPPORTUNITIES TO HELP HIGH
SCHOOL DROPPED OUT.
EARN THEIR HIGH SCHOOL DIPLOMAS
A MEMBERS THIS IS A SENSIBLE
MEASURE AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISSION DEEP MISTER
MATHIS YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I TO
RISE IN SUPPORT OF THIS MEASURE
OUR CONSERVATION CORPS IS DOING
A GREAT JOB AND THIS IS A GREAT
WAY.
FOR US TO BE ABLE TO REACH OUT
AND REALLY TRULY START BREAKING
THE CYCLE AND GIVING THIS
OPPORTUNITY OUT THERE.
AND AND I JUST WANNA GIVE A
SHOUT OUT TO MY LOCAL
CONSERVATION CORPS THAT'S DOING
A GREAT JOB ON THAT CAME AND
SPOKE TO US ON THIS SO MEMBERS --
I ASK ALL OF YOU TO STAND IN
RISE AND SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER MATHIS.
SEE NO ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION ON
THE ITEM [inaudible]
CLICK LIBERAL.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE -- DESIRED VOTE
ALL MEMBERS VOTED IS OUT OF A
ALL MEMBERS OF DECIDE ABOUT
[inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSE YOUR ROLL TIDE ABOUT ICE
FIFTY SIX NO.
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES FILE
ITEM ONE OF FIVE IS AB TWO
EIGHTY FIVE BY MS FRIEDMAN.
CORPORATION ASSEMBLY BILL TWO
EIGHTY FIVE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
FRIEDMAN AND ACTUALLY THE
TRANSPORTATION PLANNING.
THIS FRIEDMAN.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
CALIFORNIA HAS BEEN OUR WORLD
LEADER IN REDUCING GREENHOUSE
GAS EMISSIONS FROM A LOT OF
SECTORS BUT THE ONE SECTOR WE
SEEM TO BE GOING IN THE WRONG
DIRECTION IS OUR TRANSPORTATION
SECTOR.
CURRENTLY A DIRECT EMISSIONS
FROM TAIL PIPES FROM GAS
VEHICLES WRIST IS RESPONSIBLE
FOR ABOUT 40% OF OUR GREENHOUSE
GAS EMISSIONS IN THE STATE.
WE NEED TO DO MORE AND ALL
AGENCIES HAVE TO HELP THIS BILL
AB TWO EIGHTY FIVE SIMPLY
REQUIRES THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF TRANSPORTATION TO
INCORPORATE CURRENT GREENHOUSE
GAS EMISSION GOALS SUCH AS AB.
THIRTY TWO INTO THE STATE'S AIR
QUALITY PLANS INTO THE
CALIFORNIA TRANSPORTATION PLAN
IT MAKES.
OF IT REDUCING GREENHOUSE GASES
PART OF THAT PLAN IT'S LONG
OVERDUE AND I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MS FRIEDMAN SAYING NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE ITEM
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
MEMBERS VOTERS OUT VOTE ON
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBER SERVICE OUT OF A
QUIRK WELL CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT.
ICE.
FORTY EIGHT YES FOURTEEN THAT
MEASURE PASSES FILE ITEMS ONE OF
SIX ONE OF SEVEN AND ONE OH
EIGHT PASS RETAIN.
FILE ITEM ONE OR NINE IS AB
THREE OH THREE BY MISS CERVANTES
CORKERY.
ASSEMBLY BILL THREE OH THREE BY
SOME REMEMBER CERVANTES AND
ACTUALLY THE MENTAL HEALTH.
MR MONTEZ THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS ASSEMBLY BILL
THREE OH THREE WILL PROVIDE
STATUTORY GUIDANCE ON THE
PROCEDURE FOR ISSUING A
CONTINUANCE AND SB P. TRIAL.
THIS BILL WILL HELP KEEP OUR
COMMUNITY SAFE SAFE ACROSS
CALIFORNIA BY HELPING TO PREVENT
THE RELEASE OF SEXUALLY VIOLENT
PREDATORS WITHOUT A TRIAL THIS
BILL HAS RECEIVED NO OPPOSITION
HAS RECEIVE UNANIMOUS IN
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT THUS FAR I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER MONTESINOS
DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE ITEM
QUIRK LOCAL ROLE [inaudible]
MEMBERS OF THIS OUT OF IT ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS OF OUR DESIRE TO
VOTE [inaudible]
CLICK WELL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT ICE FIFTY
SEVEN NO ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES.
FILE ITEM ONE TEN PASS RETAIN
FILE ITEM ONE ELEVEN AB THREE OH
EIGHT CLERK READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL THREE OH EIGHT BY
SOMETHING MEMBER MURATSUCHI AND
OTHERS AND I PLAN TAXATION TAKE
EFFECT IMMEDIATELY TAX LEVY.
MR MURATSUCHI THANK YOU VERY
MUCH I AM PRESENTING AB THREE OH
EIGHT WHICH IS A MODEST BUT
IMPORTANT BILL TO DEMONSTRATE
OUR SUPPORT NOT ONLY FOR SMALL
BUSINESSES BUT FOR SMALL
BUSINESSES.
SOLELY OWNED BY DEPLOYED MEMBERS
OF THE US ARMED FORCES THIS BILL
WILL RESTORE A PREVIOUSLY
EXISTING TAX EXEMPTION. FOR THE
MINIMUM FRANCHISE TAX FOR SMALL
BUSINESSES SOLELY OWNED BY
DEPLOYED SOLDIERS CURRENTLY
WHILE SOLDIERS DEPLOYED IN
DEFENDING OUR COUNTRY HERE SHE
IS STILL REQUIRED TO PAY.
THE ANNUAL FRANCHISE TAX EVEN IF
THEIR BUSINESS IS NOT MAKING A
PROFIT THIS BILL WILL WAIVE THE
FRANCHISE TAX FOR SMALL BUSINESS
OWNED BY DEPLOYED SOLDIERS.
IN YEARS THAT THEY ARE NOT --
SHOWING A PROFIT I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR A VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER MURATSUCHI DR
CHOI.
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU SPEAKER IN THE MEMBERS
SIDE RISE SO IN SUPPORT ALL OF
ALL -- AB.
THREE OH EIGHT COLLEAGUES SO
THIS BILL -- WILL RE INSTATE THE
ANNUAL TAX AND A MINIMUM
FRANCHISE TAX OF FOR ALL
BUSINESSES OWNED BY THE PAROLE --
DEPLOYED THE MEMBERS OF OUR
ARMED FORCES.
THE SIMPLE FACT THAT THE
CALIFORNIA HAS THE HIGHEST A
SMALLER BUSINESS OF FAILURES TO
RATE IN THE NATION WITH A THREE
OUT OF FOUR BUSINESSES ARE
FAILING IN THEIR FIRST FOUR
YEARS.
ADDRESSED KILEY UP POINTS OUT TO
THE NEED TO REFORM OUR MINIMUM
FRANCHISE TAX.
SMALL BUSINESS IS CURRENTLY A
MAKE UP OF FORTY NINE POINT 6%.
OF THE PROFIT THEIR WORKFORCE --
IN CALIFORNIA.
AND A ZERO SUCCESS IT IS SO YOU
DRIVING ECONOMIC.
GROWTH IN OUR STATE.
WHILE THIS BE ABLE CENTERS ON
THE BUSINESSES ONE THE BIO
SERVICE SERVICE MEMBERS I THINK
BECAUSE THIS DOES DROLL SPECIAL
ATTENTION TO THE ISSUES OF OUR
STATE SOME.
MINIMUM FRANCHISE TAX IN GENERAL.
CLOTHING AND THE OFTEN KILLING A
WERE LOCAL SMALL AND OR FROM
MINORITY OWNED THE BUSINESSES.
THIS IS A SMALL SMALL WAY TO
HELP OUR ALLOW WAS SERVICE
MEMBERS ARE IN OUR COMMUNITY IS
TO KEEP THEIR BUSINESSES ARE
OPEN WHILE THEY ARE.
ARE WHAT SERVING A WAR
[inaudible]
COUNTRY.
THESE ARE THE REASONS ARE I
SUPPORT THAT AND THEN I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I'VE
WORKED.
THANK YOU DOCTOR CHOI.
SEE NO ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION ON
THE ITEM [inaudible]
QUIRK LIBERAL.
ALL MEMBERS OF RESERVE AT ALL
MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE VOTE
[inaudible]
WELL.
CLOSER ALL TIRED BUT I SIXTY TWO
NO ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING.
TO WITHOUT OBJECTION MOVE AHEAD
IN THE FILE TO FILE ITEM NUMBER
FOUR NINETY SEVEN THIS IS FILE
ITEM. FOUR NINE SEVEN BY DOCTOR
WOULD THE CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TO NINETY BY
FAMILY MEMBER WOULD AND ACTUALLY
TO HEALTH CARE COVERAGE.
DOCTOR WOULD.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS THE PROPOSAL
BEFORE YOU IS NOT A NEW ONE AB
TWO NINETY IS SIMILAR TO SB
ELEVEN FIFTY SIX OF LAST YEAR
CARRIED BY SENATOR LEYVA.
CENTER LABORS BILL PASSED THE
LEGISLATURE WAS VETOED BY THE
GOVERNOR MY BILL INCLUDES
LANGUAGE TO ADDRESS THE
GOVERNOR'S CONCERNS.
ADDITIONALLY AFTER CONSULTING
WITH LET'S COUNCIL RECENT
AMENDMENTS WERE TAKEN TO ADDRESS
CONCERNS RAISED BY THE AMERICAN
KIDNEY FOUNDATION REGARDING
THEIR NEED TO READ MAINTAIN
ANONYMITY OF DONORS AND PROTECT
PATIENTS PRIVACY.
WELL A K. F. REMAINS OPPOSED I'M
COMMITTED TO CONTINUE TO WORK TO
ADDRESS OUR CONCERNS AND PROVIDE
ASSURANCE.
THAT THEY MAY CONTINUE THEIR
GOOD WORK IN CALIFORNIA.
ALL OF YOU PROBABLY HEARD THE
ARGUMENTS AND EVEN ADS DESIGNED
TO SCARE PATIENTS ABOUT THIS IS
HOW HOW THE SYSTEM OF CARE WILL
COLLAPSE OR CLINICS WILL CLOSE.
IT THE COMMERCIAL MARKET MOVES
TO A MEDICARE REIMBURSEMENT
LEVEL I CAN TELL YOU THAT LOOK
CAREFULLY AT THIS AND WILL
CONTINUE TO EVALUATE THIS I
REMAIN UNCONVINCED THAT THE
LIMITED NUMBER OF PATIENTS
RECEIVING.
ASSISTANCE UNDER THIS PROGRAM
WILL FUNDAMENTALLY DISRUPT THE
PATIENT CARE THE PATIENTS
CURRENTLY RECEIVE.
MANY OF YOU MAY BE UNCOMFORTABLE
WITH THIS APPROACH WHICH FIXES A
REIMBURSEMENT I UNDERSTAND THAT
DISCOMFORT BUT I'M CONVINCED
THAT THE MARKET DOMINATION BY
TWO LARGE COMPANIES.
HAS MADE COMPETITION VIRTUALLY
NONEXISTENT ALLOW THESE
COMPANIES TO DEMAND
REIMBURSEMENT THAT IS FIVE TIMES
HIGHER THE MEDICARE RATE AN EVEN
HIGHER.
WHEN THE MARKET DOESN'T FUNCTION
COMPETITIVELY IN FOR PROFIT
COMPANIES EXPLOIT THE DOM THEIR
DOMINANCE FOR EXCESSIVE PROFIT
MARGINS IT'S TIME TO PRESS THE
INTERVIEWING WE ALL END UP
PAYING?
THIS BILL DOES NOT PRECLUDE ANY
ENTITY FROM CONTRIBUTING TO A
CHARITABLE ORGANIZATION FOR THE
PURPOSE OF HELPING A PATIENT.
PAY FOR THEIR CARE OR THEIR
COVERAGE IT ONLY PREVENTS THE
ENTITY FROM INCREASING THEIR
PROFITS WHEN MAKING THOSE
CONTRIBUTIONS I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU DOCTOR WOOD MISTER
MAYES YOUR RECOGNIZE THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS I RISE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS -- OF
THIS MEASURE -- LAST YEAR WHEN
THIS CAME UP -- COOK COMING OVER
FROM THE SENATE -- I WAS
INITIALLY OPPOSED THE TO THIS TO
THIS BILL.
AND AFTER MY SIXTH OR SEVENTH
MAYBE EVEN MY EIGHTH MEETING --
IT WAS AT THAT TIME REALLY
UNDERSTANDING WHAT THIS IS ALL
ABOUT.
MADE ME REALIZE WHY THIS IS
ABSOLUTELY NECESSARY.
NOW THE TRUTH IS THERE'S NOTHING
WRONG WITH CHARITIES.
DOING PREMIUM ASSISTANCE IN FACT
I SUPPORT.
I CHARITIES DOING A PREMIUM
ASSISTANCE AS SOMEBODY WHO WAS
RAISED THE SON OF A PASTOR -- I
DIDN'T EAT UNLESS PEOPLE THEY
GAVE TO CHARITY.
THERE'S NOTHING WRONG WITH THAT
AT ALL THE PROBLEM IS WITH THIS --
WITH THE CURRENT STRUCTURE.
IF YOU HAVE A SITUATION IN WHICH
IS NOT CHARITY.
PEOPLE ARE GIVING. TO THIS
ORGANIZATION FOR THE PURPOSES OF
TRYING TO INCREASE [inaudible]
THEIR BUSINESS.
THE MODEL IS FLAWED.
THE MODEL NEEDS TO BE FIXED.
I KNOW THAT FOLKS HAVE GONE
AROUND AND BEEN KNOCKING ON YOUR
DOOR IS ASKING YOU TO OPPOSE
THIS MEASURE BUT IF YOU BELIEVE.
IN.
DECREASING THE COST OF OUR
HEALTHCARE SYSTEM IF YOU BELIEVE
AND TRY TO MAKE OUR HEALTHCARE
SYSTEM MORE EFFICIENT.
THIS IS ONE STEP.
IN THAT DIRECTION SO RESPECT HER
REQUESTS YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU MISTER MAYES MISTER
MATHIS YOUR RECOGNIZE THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS I RISE IN
IN FRONT OF THE VOTERS.
AND IN MY DISTRICT YOU KNOW I'VE
I'VE BEEN ON TOURS I'VE TALKED
TO YOU PATIENTS GETTING DIALYSIS.
AND TALK TO THEM AWAY FROM THE
DIALYSIS CENTERS TALK TO THEM IN
THEIR HOMES.
IT.
IF YOU CAN'T TAKE A CLEAR SIGN
FROM THE VOTERS THEY VOTED THIS
DOWN THEY DON'T WANT THIS
MEASURE I DON'T UNDERSTAND WHY
WE ALL KEEP BRINGING IT BACK
MAYBE THERE'S OTHER MOTIVES OR
WHATEVER.
BUT THE VOTERS HAVE ALREADY
SPOKEN ON THIS I ASK YOU TO
STICK WITH THE VOTERS AND VOTE
NOW THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER MATHIS.
SEE NO ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM DOCTOR WOULD
YOU MAY CLOSE IF YOU WISH --
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I WOULD
JUST SAY THAT THIS IS NOT THE
MEASURE THAT WAS BEFORE THE
VOTERS I WAS VERY IS VERY
DIFFERENT MEASURE -- I WOULD
JUST RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR ABOUT.
THANK ACT WOULD WITH THAT CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ALL MEMBERS VOTE
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE
.
ALL MEMBER SERVICE OUT OF VOTE
[inaudible]
DR WHAT.
DOCTOR WHAT WAS A CALL
.
BACK IN REGULAR FILE ORDER.
FILE ITEM ONE TWELVE AB.
THREE THIRTEEN OPERATORS
ASSEMBLY BILL THREE THIRTEEN BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRAZIER AND
ACTUALLY THE TRANSPORTATION.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE
MISTER FRAZIER EMAIL.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
I'M PROUD TO PRESENT AB THREE
ONE THREE A COMMONSENSE
TRANSPARENCY AND ACCOUNTABILITY
MEASURE FOR SB ONE RESEARCH
DOLLARS [inaudible]
USE ME.
AB THREE THIRTEEN REQUIRES THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA AND THE
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY TO
DEVELOP AN ANNUAL REPORT
DETAILING THE TRANSPORTATION
RESEARCH RESEARCH PROGRAMS THAT
HAVE BEEN FUNDED FROM SB.
ONE THIS BILL HAS RECEIVED
UNANIMOUS SUPPORT AND HAS NO
OPPOSITION I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS FRAZIER SEE NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE.
CLARK LIBERAL.
ALL MEMBERS FROM.
RESERVE THAT ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
AT ABOUT.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE [inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE BUT I SIXTY
THREE NO.
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES.
FILE ITEMS.
ONE THIRTEEN THROUGH.
ONE SIXTEEN PAST RETAIN FILE
ITEM ONE SEVENTEEN IS AB THREE
THREE NINE CORKERY.
ASSEMBLY WILL THREE THIRTY NINE
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER OR WHEN AND
ACTUALLY TO GUN VIOLENCE
RESTRAINING ORDERS.
MS ARE WHEN YOU MAY OPEN.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I RISE
TODAY TO PRESENT AB THREE THREE
NINE WHICH WOULD REQUIRE LOCAL
LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES THAT
POLICIES.
AND STANDARDS RELATING TO GUN
VIOLENCE RESTRAINING ORDERS.
AB THREE THREE NINE WOULD
PROVIDE A JUMPSTART TO LAW
ENFORCEMENT AWARENESS OF THE
TOOL BY REQUIRING LOCAL
DEPARTMENTS TO WORK WITH GUN
VIOLENCE PREVENTION EXPERTS.
AND MENTAL HEALTH PROFESSIONALS
DEVELOP THESE POLICIES AND
STANDARDS THIS PROCESS WILL
RESULT IN A THE COMMAND STAFF
AND PATROL OFFICERS ACQUIRING
THE KNOWLEDGE NEEDED TO USE IT
GBR ROSE.
AND THE COMMUNITY.
OF ACQUIRING THE KNOWLEDGE TO
KNOW NGV ARE OWES ARE AVAILABLE
TO THEM.
SO I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
IPHONE.
THANK YOU MISTER WHEN SEEING NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE ITEM
QUIRK LIBERAL.
ALL MEMBERS OF THE DESIRE TO
VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTED IS OUT OF
THE ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO
VOTE [inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSER ROLE AND TALLY THE VOTE
AYE AYES FIFTY SIX NOW.
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES.
FILE ITEM ONE EIGHTEEN IS AB
THREE FORTY TWO CORPORATE.
ASSEMBLY BILL THREE FORTY TWO BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER MURATSUCHI AND
ACTUALLY THE PUBLIC LANDS.
MISTER MURATSUCHI.
THANK YOU COLLEAGUES THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION IS THREATENING TO
OPEN UP HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF
ACRES OF OUR FEDERAL PROTECTED
LANDS SOME OF OUR MOST BEAUTIFUL
PROTECTED LANDS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. TO FRACKING INTO OIL
DEVELOPMENT.
WE NEED TO FIGHT BACK.
AB THREE FORTY TWO WILL HELP.
CALIFORNIA PROTECT OUR MOST
BEAUTIFUL PROTECTED LANDS IN
NATIONAL MONUMENTS PLACES THAT
INCLUDE THE CARISSA PLANE
NATIONAL MONUMENT.
THE SEQUOIA NATIONAL MONUMENT.
FROM FRACKING IN OIL DEVELOPMENT.
WE DID THIS LAST YEAR BOB
PROHIBITING.
THE BUILDING OF INFRASTRUCTURE
THAT WAS SUPPORT NEW OIL
DEVELOPMENT. TO FIGHT BACK
AGAINST THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION'S.
PROPOSAL TO RE OPEN OFFSHORE OIL
DRILLING WE NEED TO DO THE SAME
TO FIGHT BACK TO PROTECT.
OUR FEDERAL PROTECTED LANDS IN
NATIONAL MONUMENTS I ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER MURATSUCHI
MISTER MATHIS HERE RECOGNIZE
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
HERE IN CALIFORNIA WE HAVE THE
MOST STRINGENT.
ENVIRONMENTAL REGULATIONS PRETTY
MUCH ON THE ENTIRE EARTH.
AND THE IDEA OF TRYING TO BLOCK
OUR DOMESTIC OIL.
BECAUSE YOU JUST DON'T LIKE THE
PRESIDENT I THINK IS NONSENSE.
ONLY SPEAK ON AS A COMBAT
VETERAN.
WHO WAS INJURED?
IN IRAQ WHICH HAS BEEN DUBBED
THE OIL WARS.
AND QUITE FRANKLY I'M SICK OF
SEEING [inaudible]
MY FRIENDS.
THE NEIGHBORS GET DEPLOYED
FOREIGN COUNTRIES OVER OIL WHEN
WE HAVE THE OIL HERE AT HOME IT
IS PRODUCED BETTER HERE AT HOME
CCLEANER HERE AT HOME.
BUT IF YOU ALL WANT TO CONTINUE
TO RELY ON OTHER COUNTRIES LIKE
I DON'T KNOW I RAN.
IN SAUDI ARABIA FOR YOUR OIL GO
AHEAD AND SUPPORT THIS BUT IF
YOU ACTUALLY LIKE.
TO EMPLOY PEOPLE HERE IT.
AT HOME.
IN CALIFORNIA.
AND GET SOME OF THE CLEANEST.
OIL OUT THERE.
WITHOUT SUPPORTING OUR NATIONAL
ADVERSARIES I ASK YOU TO VOTE
NOW THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISS MATHIS MAYES
BARRICADE HAND YOUR RECOGNIZE.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I RISE
IN SUPPORT OF THIS MEASURE I
AGREE WITH MY COLLEAGUES ACROSS
THE AISLE THAT WE SHOULD BE LESS
RELIANT ON OIL AND THAT WE
SHOULD MOVE TO ALTERNATIVE MEANS
SO THAT WE DON'T HAVE TO USE AS
MUCH OIL.
BUT I ALSO KNOW THAT JUST THIS
WEEK THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION
REQUESTED THAT THEY DRILL OIL ON
OPEN SPACE IN MY DISTRICT.
AND WE AREN'T GOING TO TAKE OUR
OPEN SPACE AND START DRILLING
AND SO I SUPPORT THIS BILL AND
ASK YOU TO SUPPORT THIS BILL SO
WE CAN CONTINUE TO PROTECT OUR
ENVIRONMENT.
ARE OPEN SPACES AND STOP THIS
ADMINISTRATION FROM TURNING
CALIFORNIA INTO A SPACE WHERE WE
DRILL AND ALL OF OUR OPEN LAND.
THANK YOU I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU IS PARA QUE HAN.
SEEING NO ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION
ON THE ITEM MISTER MURATSUCHI
YOU MAY CLOSE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I WOULD
AGREE WITH MY COLLEAGUE FROM
BISHOP THAT WE SHOULD NOT FIGHT
WARS FOR OIL.
THE PROBLEM HERE IS THAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT FEDERAL LANDS AND
SO WE DO NOT HAVE DIRECT THREAT
JURISDICTION OVER.
ENVIRONMENTAL PROTECTIONS FOR A
FEDERAL LANDS THAT IS WHY I AM
PROPOSING AN APPROACH THAT WE
TOOK SIMILAR. TO OPPOSING THE
OFFSHORE DRILLING IN FEDERAL THE
FEDERAL WATERS -- WITH THE
OFFSHORE ORDERLY PROPOSAL LAST
YEAR SIMILARLY THIS YEAR TO
FIGHT BACK AGAINST FRACKING IN
OIL DEVELOPMENT ON FEDERAL LANDS
IN CALIFORNIA WE NEED.
TO COME UP WITH A CREATIVE
STRATEGIES TO TO FIGHT THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE VOTE.
WITH THAT CARPOOL OF THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS BETTER DESIRE VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
YEAH [inaudible]
YEAH ALL MEMBERS HER DESIRE TO
VOTE.
CLARK WELL CLOSER ROLE TELL YOU
VOTE AS FORTY ONE NO SIXTEEN
THAT MEASURE PASSES.
FILE ITEM ONE NINETEEN AB THREE
FORTY FOUR BY MISTER CALDERON.
ASSEMBLY BILL THREE FORTY FOUR
BY SOME MEMBER CALDERON AND
ACTUALLY THE PUBLIC SOCIAL
SERVICES.
WHICH CALDERON.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS A MEMBERS THERE ISN'T A
ONE OF US THAT DOESN'T REPRESENT
A COMMUNITY THAT'S BEING
IMPACTED BY HOMELESSNESS.
TODAY IN IN THAT AFTER WE'VE
TRIED TO DO A LOT OF THINGS TO
HELP CURB.
HOMELESSNESS AND MAKE SURE THAT
THESE VULNERABLE INDIVIDUALS GET
THE RESOURCES AND SERVICES THAT
THEY NEED TO HELP BRING
THEMSELVES OUT OF HOMELESSNESS --
AND IT'S GONNA TAKE A
COMPREHENSIVE PLAN BUT IT'S ALSO
GOING TO HAVE TO TAKE CREATIVITY
AND SO IN THAT VEIN I TRY TO
FIND A WAY.
THAT WE COULD ENACT A PROGRAM
THAT COULD HELP CITIES.
THAT HAVE SHOWN SUCCESS WITH A
PROGRAM LIKE THIS -- TO HELP
INDIVIDUALS THAT ARE
HOMELESSNESS AND THE HOMELESS
THERE IN EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS WITHIN OUR CITIES
AND ESSENTIALLY WHAT THIS BILL
DOES IS IT CREATES A I'VE
MATCHING GRANT PROGRAM FOR A
CITY -- TO GET UP TO FIFTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS FROM THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA AS LONG AS THEY
PROVIDE LIKE MONEY.
I TO CREATE A PROGRAM TO HELP
BRING INDIVIDUALS IN THEIR
DISTRICT ARE IN THERE'S A
COMMUNITIES OUT OF HOMELESSNESS
AND ESSENTIALLY PROVIDES THEM AN
OPPORTUNITY HAVE ACCESS
RESOURCES MONEY. TO PUT THEM TO
WORK DOING A CITY SERVICE I THIS
IS SOMETHING THAT HAVE CERTAIN
CERTAIN CALIFORNIA CITIES HAVE
UTILIZED THIS IS SOMETHING THAT --
DOESN'T MATTER WHETHER IT'S A
DEMO.
I DEMOCRATIC CITY COUNCIL
REPUBLICAN CITY COUNCIL BOTH
PARTIES HAVE DONE PROGRAMS LIKE
THIS MULTIPLE STATES WHETHER RED
STATE A BLUE STATE HAVE ENACTED
PROGRAMS.
LIKE THIS AND I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT AS WE CONTINUE TO
WORK ON COMPREHENSIVE PLANS WHEN
IT COMES TO REDUCING
HOMELESSNESS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WE PROVIDE AN OPTION
FOR CITIES -- THAT THEY CAN
CREATE A PROGRAM LIKE THIS OR AN
EXTENT EXPAND ON EXISTING
PROGRAM TO HELP PUT INDIVIDUALS
THAT ARE EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS TO WORK DOING A
CITY SERVICE -- AS LONG AS
THEY'RE PAID AT LEAST MINIMUM
WAGE -- SO THAT'S WHAT THIS BILL
DOES I THINK IT'S A GREAT STEP
THE PASS OFF THIS FLOOR LAST
YEAR WITH.
BIPARTISAN SUS SUPPORT AND I
HOPE THAT WE CAN CONTINUE TO DO
THAT AND AND HAVE THAT SAME
OUTCOME TODAY AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER CALDERON C.
NOTICED KASHER DEBATE.
CAR CLUB THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS REYES ADAM.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS BETTER DESIRE TO
VOTE [inaudible]
QUIRK WELL.
CLOSER TIDE ABOUT AYE AYES FIFTY
EIGHT NO ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES FILE ITEM ONE TWENTY IS
AB THREE FIFTY FOUR CLERK READ.
AS A LEVEL THREE FIFTY FOUR BY
SOMETHING MEMBER QUIRK SILVA AND
OTHERS AND ACTUALLY THE SCHOOL
MEALS.
THIS QUIRK SILVA.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS AB THREE FIVE FOUR
REQUIRE SCHOOL DISTRICTS COUNTY
OFFICES OF EDUCATION OR CHARTER
SCHOOLS THAT VOLUNTARILY OPT OUT
OF THE NATIONAL SCHOOL LUNCH
PROGRAM TO ANNUALLY ANNUALLY
REPORT THE ALTERNATIVE MAIL
PROGRAM.
IT WILL FOLLOW TO ENSURE THAT
OUR STUDENTS IN NEED RE
PROVIDED AT LEAST ONE ADEQUATE
AND NUTRITIOUS MILLER DAY
MEMBERS THIS SIMPLY MEANS THAT
IF A SCHOOL DISTRICT OR OTHER
SCHOOLS.
OPT OUT THAT THEY HAVE A PLAN TO
FEED OUR STUDENTS AND WE BELIEVE
ALL STUDENTS DESERVE EQUITABLE
ACCESS TO THE RESOURCES THAT
WILL ENSURE THEIR SUCCESS AND
PROPER NUTRITION IS ONE OF THEM.
RESEARCH SHOWS WHEN WE FEED OUR
STUDENTS THEY DO BETTER IN
LEARNING AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MS QUIRK SILVA SAY NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE.
COUPLE OF THEIR OWN ALL MEMBERS
VOTE.
YOU DESERVE IT ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF A
QUIRK WELL CLOSE ROLE AND
TALLIED ON ICE FIFTY FOUR NO SAY
THAT MEASURE PASSES. FIVE OUT OF
ONE TWENTY ONE IS AB THREE SIXTY
FIVE DEGREES.
ASSEMBLY BILL THREE SIXTY FIVE
BY SONY MEMBER CRISTINA GARCIA
AND OTHERS AND ACTUALLY THE
STATE EMPLOYMENT.
MS GARCIA.
HI GOOD MORNING HISTORICALLY
WORKING IN I. H. PEOPLE WITH
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES ARE
AMONG THE MOST UNEMPLOYED AND
UNDEREMPLOYED.
MEMBERS OF SOCIETY HERE IN THE
STATE A WE HAVE A PROGRAM KNOWN
AS THE LIMITED EXAMINATION AN
APPLICATION PROGRAM OR LEAVE.
THAT'S DESIGNED TO HELP THOSE
INDIVIDUALS OBTAIN STATE
EMPLOYMENT THERE IS AN AUDIT
DONE NOT TOO LONG AGO HOW TO
IMPROVE THAT PROGRAM.
ON AND THIS BILL IS TAKING A
NUMBER OF THOSE RECOMMENDATIONS
INTO A FACT I HAVE A YOUNG MAN
HAS BEEN IN MY OFFICE FOR THE
LAST FIVE YEARS WITH THE
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITY.
WE HAVE AGGRESSIVELY BEEN
WORKING WITH HIM THROUGH THE LEE
PROGRAM FOR THE LAST TWO YEARS
AND WE HAVE PERSONALLY
ENCOUNTERED THE PROBLEMS THAT
ARE OUT HERE TO MAKE THIS --
ACCESSIBLE I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MS GARCIA SEE NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE.
CAR CLUB -- ALL ALL MEMBERS
VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE?
CLICK WELL CLOSE ROLE TELL VOTE
I SEVENTY NO.
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING.
TO JUMP AHEAD OF THE FILE. TO
FILE ITEM NUMBER.
TWO SIXTY SIX MY MISTER BERMAN
THIS IS FILE ITEM [inaudible]
TO SIXTY SIX AB. THIRTEEN FORTY
ONE CORPORATION.
AS A LEGAL THIRTEEN FORTY ONE BY
SALLY MEMBER BERMAN AND ACTUALLY
THE PRIVATE POSTSECONDARY
EDUCATION.
SIR BERMAN YOU ARE ALWAYS READY.
YOU MAY OPEN A GOOD THING I'M
GLAD I WAS AT MY DESK THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER.
AB THIRTEEN FORTY ONE WILL
PREVENT COVERT FOR PROFIT
COLLEGES FROM EVADING STATE
OVERSIGHT BY REQUIRING THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL TO DETERMINE
WHETHER AN INSTITUTION THAT
CLAIMS TO BE A NONPROFIT COLLEGE
OR A PUBLIC COLLEGE.
ACTUALLY MEETS THE DEFINITION OF
A NONPROFIT CORPORATION OR
PUBLIC INSTITUTION OF HIGHER
EDUCATION.
UNFORTUNATELY SOME FOR PROFIT
COLLEGES ARE TRYING TO GAME THE
SYSTEM BY USING A NON PROFIT OR
PUBLIC LABEL MISLEADING STUDENTS
WHILE AT THE SAME TIME.
DODGING APPROPRIATE OVERSIGHT.
THERE FOR CALIFORNIA MUST STEP
UP AND STEP IN TO PROTECT OUR
STUDENTS AND ENSURE THAT
APPROPRIATE OVERSIGHT REMAINS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THEY GIVE US BERMAN SAYING NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE ALL
MEMBERS VOTE.
DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS OF
THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSER ROLE AND TELL YOU VOTE.
I SIXTY FIVE KNOWS ZERO THAT
MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO MOVE TO
TAKE A FOLLOW ON TO SIXTY SEVEN
AB THIRTEEN FORTY TWO BY MR LOW
CORPORATE.
A SOME A LOT THIRTEEN FORTY TWO
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER LOW AND
ACTUALLY NONPROFIT CORPORATIONS
MAKING A PREPARATION THEREFORE.
MISTER LOW YOU MAY OPEN THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS AT A. B. THIRTEEN FORTY
TWO FALLS ON A PACKAGE OF BILLS.
ON THE ACCOUNTABILITY FOR THESE
FOR PROFIT COLLEGES THIS BILL
WOULD REQUIRE THAT THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL APPROVED THE SALE OF A
FOR PROFIT COLLEGE TO ENSURE
THAT ACCOUNTABILITY AND
TRANSPARENCY FOR STUDENTS.
AND ALL INTERESTED PARTIES I
RESPECTFULLY ASK PRIVATE.
THANK YOU MISTER LO SI NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE.
OR CLUB FOR ALL.
ALL MEMBERS OF THE DESIRE TO
VOTE ON MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF A
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE VOTE.
CLERK WILL CLOSE ROLL TIDE BUT I
FIFTY FOUR KNOWS.
TWELVE THAT MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO TAKE UP
FILE ITEM.
TO SIXTY EIGHT AB THIRTEEN FORTY
FOUR CLICK READ.
ASSEMBLY WILL THIRTEEN FORTY
FOUR BY SOMETHING MEMBER OF OUR
QUE HAN AND OTHERS AND ACTUALLY
PRIVATE POSTSECONDARY EDUCATION.
MS BARRICADE HAN.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER TODAY I
RISE TO PRESENT AB THIRTEEN
FORTY FOUR WHICH WERE RIGHT
CRITICAL CONSUMER PROTECTIONS TO
SAFEGUARD THE NEARLY ONE HUNDRED
THOUSAND CALIFORNIA STUDENTS
ENROLLED IN ONLINE FOR PROFIT
OUT OF STATE INSTITUTIONS.
THE LARGEST SHARE CALIFORNIANS
ROLLED IN ONLINE SCHOOLS ARE
ENROLLED IN FOR PROFIT COLLEGES
ONE OF THE MOST TROUBLE BUSINESS
SECTORS IN MODERN AMERICAN
HISTORY.
CALIFORNIA HAS TAKEN STEPS TO
PROTECT STUDENTS FROM THESE
SCHOOLS IN TWENTY SIXTEEN WE
TOOK STEPS TO PROTECT THEM FROM
THESE POSSIBLE PREDATORY
BUSINESSES BY MAKING THEM
REGISTER WITH THE BPP.
AB THIRTEEN FORTY FOUR EXTENT
THESE REFORMS IN CURRENT LAW AND
ADDS SEVERAL ADDITIONAL
IMPORTANT REQUIREMENTS.
CURRENTLY CALIFORNIA HAS A
REGISTRATION PROCESS FOR OUT OF
STATE SCHOOLS BUT NO WAY FOR THE
STATE TO IDENTIFY PROBLEMS AT
THE SCHOOLS OR REMOVE SCHOOLS
WHICH POSE A RISK TO THE
RESIDENTS OF CALIFORNIA.
THESE INSTITUTIONS ARE NOT
CURRENTLY REQUIRED TO DISCLOSE
INFORMATION TO THE BUREAU WHICH
MIGHT SIGNAL THERE'S A REASON
FOR CONCERN INCLUDING WEATHER
PENDING INVESTIGATIONS --
LAWSUITS AB THIRTEEN FORTY FOUR
WILL REQUIRE THESE DISCLOSURES
AND ADDITIONALLY OFFER A
COMPLAINT PROCESS FOR CALIFORNIA
STUDENTS.
AS WELL AS CREATE KEY ADDITIONAL
PROTECTIONS THAT WILL CLOSE THE
GAP BETWEEN STUDENTS ENROLLED IN
STATE INSTITUTIONS AND THOSE
ENROLLED ONLINE IN PROGRAMS
LOCATED OUT OF STATE.
THIS BILL HAS HAD NO NO VOTES
AND ENJOYED BIPARTISAN SUPPORT
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS BARKING HIM
SAYING NO DISCUSSION DEBATE
CLERK LIBERAL [inaudible]
MEMBERS.
SARAH VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTER
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
WELL CLOSER ROLE.
AND TELL YOU THE VOTE.
HI SIXTY THREE NO ZERO THAT
MEASURE PASSES.
FILE ITEM TWO SIXTY NINE A. B.
THIRTEEN FORTY SIX COOPERATE.
ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTEEN FORTY SIX
BY SOME REMEMBER MEDINA AND
OTHERS AND ACTUALLY TO POST
SECONDARY EDUCATION MAKING A
PREPARATION THEREFORE.
MISTER MEDINA THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS TODAY I
PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL.
THIRTEEN FORTY FORTY SIX AB
THIRTEEN FORTY SIX EXPANDS THE
STUDENT TUITION RECOVERY FUNDS
DEFINITION.
OF ECONOMIC LOSS TO RECOVER
LOSSES BEYOND TUITION EXPENSES
INCLUDING HOUSING TRANSPORTATION
AND CHILDCARE.
AS WELL AS ANY EXPENSES INCURRED
BY THE STUDENT AS A RESULT OF
THE CLOSE SCHOOL SUCH AS
TRANSCRIPT FEES FOR THE COST OF
SERVICES RELATED TO DEBT RELIEF.
THIS BILL HAS ENJOYED BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT WITH NO NO VOTES I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER MEDINA SAY NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBER SERVICE ADAMO.
ALL MEMBERS OF THE DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS BETTER IS THERE TO
VOTE CLERK WILL.
CLOSER ROLE AND TELL YOU WHAT I
SIXTY FIVE NO.
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO MOVE
AHEAD IN THE FILE TO FILE ITEM.
FOR SIXTY FOUR FILE ITEM.
FOUR SIX FOUR THIS IS AB.
THIRTEEN FORTY BY MISTER DAVID
CHIU CORKERY.
ASSEMBLY WILL THIRTEEN FORTY BY
SEVENTY MEMBER DAVID CHIU AND
ACTUALLY A PRIVATE POST
SECONDARY EDUCATION.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
COLLEAGUES I APPRECIATE YOUR
CONSIDERATION OF THIS PACKAGE OF
BILLS RESPONDING TO THE RECENT
ACTIONS OVER FEDERAL
MINISTRATION WHO OF
UNFORTUNATELY.
ABANDONED CRITICAL PROTECTIONS
FOR STUDENTS STUDENTS VICTIMIZED
BY PREDATORY COLLEGES THAT A
PRIORITIZE PROFIT OVER STUDENT
SUCCESS.
THIS BILL WILL PROTECT
CALIFORNIA'S STUDENTS FROM OVER
PRICED INEFFECTIVE CAREER
TRAINING PROGRAMS BY REINSTATING
A VERSION OF THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION'S GAINFUL
EMPLOYMENT RULE.
RECENTLY SCRAPPED BY PRESIDENT
TRUMP.
THIS RULE WAS IMPLEMENTED TO
ADDRESS THE ALL TOO COMMON STORY
OF STUDENTS PROMISED BY
RECRUITERS THAT THEY WILL FIND A
JOB IN AN INDUSTRY.
WHO TAKE OUT TENS OF THOUSANDS
OF DOLLARS IN DEBT?
ONLY TO FIND UPON GRADUATION
THAT THEY CAN'T GET ANY OF THE
PROMISED JOBS THEY'RE UNEMPLOYED
AND FACE ASTRONOMICAL DEBT
REPAYMENT OR EVEN LOAN DEFAULT.
THE FEDERAL GAINFUL EMPLOYMENT
RULE APPLIES TO CREW TRAINING
PROGRAMS A TOOK ADVANTAGE OF
FEDERAL FINANCIAL AID.
UNDER THE RULE A PROGRAM THAT
DIDN'T PASS MUSTER FOR MORE THAN
HALF OF ITS GRADUATES.
WHO HAD STUDENT EXCESSIVE
STUDENT LOAN BURNS WHEN WEIGHED
AGAINST THEIR INCOMES AFTER
COLLEGE WOULD FAIL?
BASED ON INITIAL DATA FROM THE
EDUCATION DEPARTMENT OVER TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY PROGRAMS IN
CALIFORNIA DID NOT PASS THIS
TEST.
THOUGH SHODDY PROGRAMS GRADUATED
OVER FIFTY SIX THOUSAND STUDENTS
WHO LEFT SCHOOL WITH ALMOST A
BILLION DOLLARS IN STUDENT DEBT.
LAST YEAR PRESIDENT TRUMP MOVE
TO SCRAP THE GAINFUL EMPLOYMENT
RULE WITHOUT THE RULE BAD
PROGRAMS WILL CONTINUE TO PREY
UPON OUR STUDENTS WITHOUT
CONSEQUENCE.
THIS BILL WOULD REINSTATE THE
GAME FOR PLANT ROLLER VERSION OF
THAT ROLE AS EMBODIED IN FEDERAL
LAW.
UP BEFORE THE RECENT ACTIONS BY
THE FEDERAL MINISTRATION OUR
STUDENTS DESERVE BETTER AND
CALIFORNIANS MUST PROTECT THEM
WITHOUT A RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHIU SANER
DISCUSSION DEBATE.
QUIRK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE LOW ALL
MEMBERS FOR THE SENATE VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE ABOUT.
CLICK WELL CLOSER ROLE TALLY THE
VOTE ICE FORTY EIGHT KNOWS A
LEVIN [inaudible]
THAT MEASURE.
PRETEND YOU DIDN'T HEAR THAT
MEMBERS.
FILE ITEM.
FOR SIXTY FIVE IS AB THIRTEEN
FORTY THREE BY DOCTOR EGGMAN.
COOKERY.
S. UNABLE THIRTY FORTY THREE BY
SOME NUMBER A WIN AND OTHERS AND
EXPLAIN PRIVATE POST SECONDARY
EDUCATION.
DOCTOR EGGMAN YOU MAY OPEN.
MAKING SURE WE HAVE THE RIGHT
FILE OR UP THERE WAS EVERY GO
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS TODAY I
RISE TO PRESENT A. B.. THIRTEEN
FORTY THREE WHICH IS THE FINAL
BILL IN THIS.
PACKAGE ADDRESSING FOR PROFIT
UNIVERSITIES.
THIS ONE MEMBERS AS A
SUBMERSIBLE BUILT TO PROTECT
BOTH TAXPAYERS AND VETERANS --
HISTORICALLY WE PASSED IN THE
NINETIES -- PROTECTIONS FOR FOR
AGAINST FOR PROFIT COLLEGES THAT
ASK 485% BE PAID BY PUBLIC
DOLLARS. 15% WAS A SCHOOL NEEDS
TO KNOW SHOW THAT IT HAS SOME
VALUE ON THE OPEN MARKET AND NOT
JUST BE ABLE.
TO CHARGE UP TO WHAT THE
GOVERNMENT WILL PAY.
THIS RULE HAS BEEN DIMINISHED
OVER THE YEARS MOST RECENTLY OF
NOT LINING UP EIGHTY FIVE
FIFTEEN WITH THE NINETY TEN THAT
APPLIES TO VETERANS BENEFITS SO
IN ESSENCE OF FOR PROFIT
UNIVERSITY BECOMES LIKE A
GOVERNMENT CONTRACTOR.
AS THEY CHARGE WHATEVER THEY THE
MARKET WHATEVER THEY CAN GET IN
FUNDING.
FROM THE GOVERNMENT WITH NO KIND
OF DEMONSTRATION THAT THE
PROGRAM HAS THE VALUE FOR WHICH
IT IS BEING.
PAID BY ALL GOVERNMENT DOLLARS
THIS IS A DIRECT I THINK ASSAULT
ON OUR VETERANS WHO COME OUT
LOOKING FOR AN EDUCATION.
AGAIN IT IS NOT THE THESE FOR
PROFIT SCHOOLS RESPONSIBILITY TO
TAKE CARE OF TAXPAYERS IT IS OUR
RESPONSIBILITY TO TAKE CARE OF
TAXPAYERS AND TO MAKE SURE.
THAT THE SCHOOLS THAT ARE OUR
VETERANS AND OUR STUDENTS ARE
GETTING A HIGH VALUE ON THE OPEN
MARKET AND NOT JUST WHAT THE
GOVERNMENT WILL PAY -- I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU DOCTOR EGGMAN SEE NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE [inaudible]
CLICK LIBERAL.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
EXACTLY WHAT ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
OUT OF A ALL MEMBERS OTHERS ARE
TO VOTE [inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSE ROTH TELEVOTE ICE FIFTY
FOUR KNOWS FOR THAT MEASURE
PASSES.
MEMBERS BACK IN THE PREVIOUS
FILE ORDER.
FILE ITEMS ONE TWENTY TWO AND
ONE TWENTY THREE PASS RETAIN
WERE FILE ITEM ONE TWENTY FOUR
AB THREE SEVENTY TWO CORKERY.
ASSEMBLY WILL THREE SEVENTY TWO
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER VOEPEL AND
OTHERS AND EXPLAIN THE STATE
EMPLOYEES.
THIS VOEPEL.
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS THIS IS A
BIPARTISAN BILL WITH GREAT
THANKS TO THE CO AUTHOR FROM SAN
DIEGO.
I HAVE THE PLEASURE OF
PRESENTING AB THREE SEVENTY TWO
A BILL THAT WOULD AUTHORIZE A
PILOT PROGRAMAT ANY STATE
AGENCY. TO ADOPT AN INFANT AT
WORK PROGRAM.
WITH A SUNSET DATE OF JANUARY
FIRST.
TWENTY TWENTY TWO THE INFINITE
WORK PROGRAM ALLOWS AN EMPLOYEE
OF AN AGENCY WHO IS A NEW PARENT
OR CARE GIVER TO BRING THE
INFANT AGE SIX WEEKS TO SIX
MONTHS OR UNTIL CRAWLING. TO THE
WORKPLACE AB THREE SEVENTY TWO
CERTAINLY AIMS TO HELP ALLEVIATE
THE STRAIN OF CHILD CARE COSTS
FOR FAMILIES BUT IT IS
IMPERATIVE.
THAT WE RECOGNIZE THAT THE MOST
VITAL STAGE OF BRAIN DEVELOPMENT
OCCURS DURING INFANCY.
A NURTURING BALM BETWEEN AN
INFANT CARE GIVER HAS LONG TERM
EFFECTS ON DEVELOPING HEALTHY
RELATIONSHIPS THROUGHOUT LIFE.
INFINITE WORK PILOT PROGRAMS
CONDUCTED IN ARIZONA WASHINGTON
NEVADA AND OTHER STATES HAVE
FOUND INCREASED PARENT INFANT
BONDING EASIER BREAST FEEDING
ACCESSIBILITY FOR MOTHERS
OVERALL REDUCE HEALTHCARE COSTS
FOR BABIES INCREASE EMPLOYEE
MORALE AND PARENT PRODUCTIVITY.
AB THREE SEVENTY TWO AS
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT ON BEHALF OF
MYSELF AND CALIFORNIA'S FUTURE
BABIES I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER VOEPEL SEE NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE ITEM
OUR GLOBAL ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS OF THIS ADVERT ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF A ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE THE CLARK
WELL.
CLOSER ALL THE TIME THAT I SIXTY
FOUR NO.
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES MEMBERS
I AM PREPARED TO LIFT THE CALL.
ON FILE ITEM.
FOR NINETY SEVEN THIS IS A B..
TWO NINETY CLERK WILL POST.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER WHICH TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER WHICH TO VOTE
[inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSE ROLE TALLY ABOUT ICE FORTY
THREE KNOWS.
FOURTEEN THAT MEASURE PASSES.
FILE ITEMS ONE TWENTY FIVE AND
ONE TWENTY SIX PASS RETAIN.
WE ARE A FILE ITEM ONE TWENTY
SEVEN AB. THREE NINETY THREE
FIVE MISTER NAZARIAN.
CLOCK RATE.
ASSEMBLY BILL THREE NINETY THREE
BY SOME REMEMBER NAZARIAN AND
ACTUALLY THE BUILDING STANDARDS.
MISTER NAZARIAN.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AB
THREE NINETY THREE REQUIRES THE
CALIFORNIA BUILDING STANDARDS
COMMISSION TO ASSEMBLE A WORKING
GROUP.
CONSISTING OF VARIOUS BUILDING
HOUSING AND ENGINEERING EXPERTS
TO DETERMINE NEW POST EARTHQUAKE
BUILDING PERFORMANCE STANDARDS
WITH THE EXCEPTION OF ESSENTIAL
FACILITIES LIKE HOSPITALS AND
FIRE STATIONS CURRENT BUILDING
CODE.
IS ONLY DESIGNED TO PROTECT
AGAINST LOSS OF LIFE IF A MAJOR
EARTHQUAKE HITS.
THE CODE SAYS NOTHING ABOUT
WHETHER.
OR WHEN A BUILDING WILL BE
USABLE AFTER A LARGE SEISMIC
EVENT AB THREE NINETY THREE
WORKS TO ENSURE THAT PEOPLE CAN
ENTER BUILDINGS AND RESUME
NORMAL ACTIVITIES.
SOON AFTER A LARGE EARTHQUAKE
INSTEAD OF HAVING BUILDINGS
CLOSE FOR MONTHS OR YEARS AT A
TIME WHICH WE'VE WITNESSED ALL
OVER THE STATE.
THIS BILL HAS RECEIVED NUMEROUS
BY -- UNANIMOUS BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT.
AND HAS HAD NO REGISTERED
OPPOSITION I ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER NAZARIAN.
SEE NO DISCUSSION DEBATE.
CARPOOL PAROLE.
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS OTHERS OUT OF A ALL
MEMBERS OTHERS OUT OF THOSE.
CLICK WELL CLOSE ROLLS OUT OF A
AYE AYES.
FIFTY EIGHT NO ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES FILE ITEM ONE TWENTY SIX
AB FORO TO COVERAGE.
ASSEMBLY BILL FOUR OH TO BUY
SOMETHING MEMBER QUIRK AND
ACTUALLY DRINKING WATER
[inaudible]
DOCTOR QUIRK.
AB -- FOR TO AUTHORIZES THE
STATE WATER BOARD TO ESTABLISH A
FUNDING PROGRAM TO SUPPORT LOCAL
OVERSIGHT OF SMALL DRINKING
WATER SYSTEMS.
LOCAL HEALTH OFFICERS REGULATE
SMALL PUBLIC DRINKING WATER
SYSTEMS IN THIRTY COUNTRIES.
OVERSIGHT IS FUNDED ENTIRELY BY
FEES YET MOST SMALL WATER
SYSTEMS DO NOT.
GENERATE SUFFICIENT FEE REVENUE
TO COVERAGE COST.
AS A RESULT SIX COUNTIES HAVE
RETURNED OVERSIGHT AUTHORITY
BACK O THE STATE WATER BOARD.
SMALL WATER SYSTEMS NEED THE
MOST OVERSIGHT BECAUSE IT MOST
LIKELY -- TO HAVE PROBLEMS
MEETING THE DRINKING WATER
STANDARDS.
AB FOUR OF TWO SURE AS LONG TERM
SUPPORT FOR LOCAL OVERSIGHT. FOR
SMALL DRINKING WATER SYSTEMS SO
WHAT AGAIN WE'RE DOING IS HAVING
THE STATE WATER BOARD.
FUND LOCAL AGENCIES SO THAT THE
OVERSIGHT WILL BE DONE BY THE
LOCAL AGENCY AND NOT BY THE
WATER BOARD.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU DOCTOR QUIRK SEEING NO
DISCUSSION ON THE ITEM CLICK
LIBERAL [inaudible]
MEMBERS.
IS ADDED THAT ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
OUT OF A ALL MEMBERS VOTERS AT A
VOTE.
CLICK WELL CLOSE REAL TIGHT
ABOUT ICE FORTY FOUR NO ZERO
THAT MEASURE PASSES.
FILE ITEMS ONE TWENTY NINE ONE
THIRTY PASS AND RETAIN FILE ITEM.
ONE THIRTY ONE AB.
FOUR ONE ONE GREGORY.
ASSEMBLY BILL FOUR ELEVEN BY
SOMETHING MEMBER MARK STONE AND
ACTUALLY TO REDEVELOPMENT MR
STONE.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I
MEMBERS ON THE CITY SANTA CRUZ
WOUND UP ITS REDEVELOPMENT
AGENCY DID SO.
ACCORDANCE WITH THE RULES AND
WAS VERY RESPONSIBLE ABOUT IT
RIGHT NOW THOUGH IT HAS A BOND
WERE SIXTEEN MILLION DOLLARS
THAT IS SITTING WITH HIS
SUCCESSOR AGENCY.
THEY'RE ASKING FOR OUR HELP THEY
ARE PROJECTS READY TO GO TO
ADDRESS HOMELESS NEEDS AN
ADDRESS AFFORDABLE HOUSING NEEDS
IN THEIR COMMUNITY.
AND THAT SIXTEEN MILLION DOLLARS
JUST SITS WITH THE SUCCESSOR
AGENCY.
WIDE A. B. FOR ELEVEN WILL DO
WILL FREE UP THAT MONEY TO BE
SPENT ON APPROPRIATE MEANS HELP
ADDRESS THE HOUSING ISSUE IN THE
CITY SANTA CRUZ.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU MUCH DOWN SEE NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE.
CLUB GLOBAL -- ALL [inaudible]
WELL.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSER ROLE TALBOT EYES FIFTY
THREE NO ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES FILE ITEM.
ONE THIRTY TWO AB FOR FIFTEEN
CORKERY.
AS ONLY WILL FOR FIFTEEN BY SOME
REMEMBER MAIENSCHEIN AND OTHERS
AND ACTUALLY THE VICTIM
COMPENSATION MAKING
APPROPRIATION THEREFORE.
MAIENSCHEIN THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER THE CONNECTION BETWEEN
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE AND ANIMAL
CRUELTY IS SO SIGNIFICANT IT IS
COMMONLY REFERRED TO SIMPLY AS
THE LANK.
PERPETRATORS OF DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE OFTEN THREATENED HARM
OR BRING HARM TO THEIR VICTIMS.
AB PETS OR ANIMALS IN ORDER TO
CONTROL THEIR VICTIM OR KEEP
THEM FROM LEAVING.
AB FOR FIFTEEN WOULD ALLOW PET
RELOCATION EXPENSES TO BE PAID
FOR BY THE VICTIMS COMPENSATION
FUND WITH MORE THAN A QUARTER OF
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE VICTIMS
REPORTING THEIR CONCERN FOR
THEIR PETS WELL BEING AS A
BARRIER TO LEAVING THEIR ABUSER
AB FOR FIFTEEN WILL SUPPORT
VICTIMS. TO SEEK THE HELP AND
SHELTER THEY NEED THANK YOU AND
I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS MAIENSCHEIN.
SEE NO DISCUSSION DEBATE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE RIGHT.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE
THIS TAKES.
FIFTY FOUR ALL MEMBERS VOTER
DESIRE TO VOTE.
THIS IS A FIFTY FOUR VOTE
MEASURE [inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSER ALL TALBOT EYES.
FIFTY SIX KNOWS.
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES.
FILE ITEM.
ONE THIRTY THREE IS AB.
FOR NINETEEN THIS IS FILE ITEM.
ONE THIRTY THREE EIGHTY FOUR
NINETEEN BY MAYES AGUILAR CURRY
CLERK WILL READ.
MY APOLOGIES DOCTOR EGGMAN
CHAIRS AG [inaudible]
LOCAL RATE.
ASSEMBLY WILL FOR NINETEEN BY
THE COMMITTEE ON AGRICULTURE AND
ACTUALLY THE FOOD AND
AGRICULTURE [inaudible]
DOCTOR EGGMAN.
I THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
SPEAKER A MEMBERS AB FOR
NINETEEN IS THE AGRICULTURE
COMMITTEE OMNIBUS BILL.
THAT EXTENDS THE SUNSET TO
STANDARDIZE YOUR VEGETABLES
FRUITS AND NUTS I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU DOCTOR EGGMAN SEEING
NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
CLARK WILL OPEN THE ROLE
[inaudible]
ALL MEMBERS.
ZARA VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT
OF THE ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE
TO VOTE.
CLARK WELL.
CLOSER OUTSIDE OF WHAT I SIXTY
ONE NO ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES
FILE ITEMS ONE THIRTY FOUR ONE
THIRTY FIVE PASSED RETAIN.
FILE ITEM ONE THIRTY SIX IS A
BEFORE TWENTY NINE BY MISTER HIS
AREA.
CLOCK RATE ASSEMBLY BILL FOUR
TWENTY NINE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
DOES ARIAN AND ACTUALLY THE
STATE GOVERNMENT.
MR IS AREA.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER A
BEFORE TWENTY NINE WOULD REQUIRE
THE CALIFORNIA SEISMIC SAFETY
COMMISSION TO CREATE AN
INVENTORY OF POTENTIALLY
SEISMICALLY VULNERABLE BUILDINGS
LOCATED IN THE TWENTY NINE
COUNTIES OF MOST SEISMIC RISK.
CALIFORNIA HAS THOUSANDS OF
BUILDINGS THAT ARE KNOWN TO
PRESENT A HEIGHTENED EARTHQUAKE
RISK OF DEATH INJURY AND DAMAGE
BASED ON THEIR AGE STRUCTURAL
SYSTEM SIZE AND LOCATION WELL
SOME CITIES MOST NOTABLY LOS
ANGELES AND SAN FRANCISCO.
HAVE IDENTIFIED VULNERABLE
BUILDINGS AND IMPLEMENTED
MANDATORY RETROFITS LARGE PARTS
OF THE STATE STILL HAVE NOT AN
ACCURATE INVENTORY IS AN
ESSENTIAL FIRST STEP IN
DEVELOPING LONGER TERM SOLUTIONS
TO MITIGATE THE EFFECTS.
OF A MAJOR EARTHQUAKE -- I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER NAZARIAN SEE NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE ON
MEMBERS.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTE.
WHO DESIRED TO VOTE?
ALL MEMBER SERVICE ARE VOTE
[inaudible]
CLICK WELL.
CLOSER ROLE AND TALLY THE VOTE
AYE AYES FIFTY I SIXTY NO ZERO
THAT MEASURE PASSES MEMBERS I AM
PREPARED TO LIVE THE CALL.
ON FILE ITEM.
THIRTY FIVE THAT IS.
AB FOURTEEN THIRTEEN THE
CORPORAL POST.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHICH TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED WISH TO VOTE
[inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSER ROLE IN TALLY THE VOTE
AYE AYES FORTY TWO KNOWS.
TWENTY TWO THAT MEASURE PASSES.
FILE ITEMS ONE THIRTY SEVEN
THROUGH ONE THIRTY NINE PASS AND
RETAIN.
FILE ITEM ONE FORTY AB FOR SIXTY
THREE CERVANTES CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL FOUR SIXTY THREE
BY FAMILY MEMBERS CERVANTES AND
ACTUALLY TO COMMUNITY COLLEGE
EMPLOYEES.
MR BY TESS THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS AB FOURTH
SIXTY THREE REQUIRES COMMUNITY
COLLEGES TO CREDIT PART TIME
FACULTY EMPLOYEES WITH THREE
POINT THREE FIVE HOURS WORKED
FOR EACH HOUR OF LECTURE CLASS
FROM TIME.
MAKING IT EASIER FOR COMMUNITY
COLLEGE PART TIME FACULTY
MEMBERS TO QUALIFY FOR THE
FEDERAL PUBLIC SERVICE LOAN
FORGIVENESS PROGRAM.
AB FOUR SIX THREE SIX TO INSURE
THAT WE RECOGNIZE THE PUBLIC
SERVICE A PART TIME FACULTY BY
ALLOWING THEM TO HAVE AN EQUAL
OPPORTUNITY TO PARTICIPATE IN
THE FEDERAL PUBLIC SERVICE LOAN
FORGIVENESS PROGRAM.
A BENEFIT AVAILABLE TOO MANY
FULL TIME FACULTY THIS IS
RECEIVED BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND
I ASK FOR YOUR RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER MARTIN SEE NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE ITEM
COR CLUB IN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
USE OUR VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS HEADED DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE A DESIRE TO
KIRK WELL CLOSER ROLE AND TELL
YOU ABOUT AYE AYES [inaudible]
FIFTY ONE KNOWS.
TEN THAT MEASURE PASSES FILE
ITEM ONE FORTY ONE PASS RETAIN
FILE ITEM.
ONE FORTY TWO A BEFORE SEVENTY
SIX CORPORATE.
ASSEMBLY BILL FOUR SEVENTY SIX
BY FAMILY MEMBER BLANCA RUBIO
AND I PLAN TO PROFESSIONS OF
LOCATIONS.
MS RUBIO YOU MAIL.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
TO THEIR I'M PRESENTING AB FOR
SEVENTY SIX WHICH CREATES A TASK
FORCE THAT WILL STUDY AND MAKE
RECOMMENDATIONS.
ON HOW TO INTEGRATE FOREIGN
TRAINED PROFESSIONALS AND HOW TO
ELIMINATE UNNECESSARY BARRIERS
FOR FOREIGN PROFESSIONALS.
CURRENT LAW PROVIDES FOR THE
LICENSURE AND REGULATIONS OF
VARIOUS PROFESSIONAL PROFESSIONS
AND VOCATIONS BY BOARDS WITHIN
THE DEPARTMENT OF CONSUMER
AFFAIRS.
SOME IMMIGRANTS HAVE MENTIONED
THAT THE EVALUATION PROCESS HAS
MULTIPLE BARRIERS IN TERMS OF
PROCESS TIME TIMELINESS AND
DEGREE EVALUATION.
AND THE ACCEPTANCE OF FOREIGN
CREDENTIALS MY BILL AB FOR
SEVENTY SIX CREATES A STARTING
POINT FOR REMEDYING THIS ISSUES.
BY TAKING REASONABLE STEPS TO
IDENTIFY A SOLUTION TO THESE
BARRIERS THREE TASK FORCE AB FOR
SEVENTY SIX IS SPONSORED BY
CHIRLA I THANK YOU AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MS RUBIO SEE NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF A ALL
THE RESEARCHERS ARE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
CLERK WILL.
CLOSER ALL TIED ABOUT ICE FIFTY
FOUR KNOWS NINE THAT MEASURE
PASSES.
FILE ITEM ONE FORTY THREE IS A
BEFORE SEVENTY SEVEN CORPORATION
ASSEMBLY BILL FOUR SEVENTY SEVEN
BY SOME REMEMBER CERVANTES AND
ACTUALLY EMERGENCY SERVICES.
THIS CERVANTES YOU MAY OPEN
HANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
AFTER THE FIRE DISASTERS OF THE
PAST SEVERAL YEARS THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA HAS BEEN WORKING. TO
DEVELOP BEST PRACTICES FOR
EMERGENCY RESPONSES YEAH
EMERGENCY DISASTERS HAVE
DISPROPORTIONATELY AFFECTED
INDIVIDUALS WITH ACCESS AND
FUNCTIONAL AND FUNCTIONAL NEEDS.
AB FOR SEVEN SEVEN ONE SURE
ABOUT THE IMPLEMENTATION
EXECUTION OF EMERGENCY PLANNING
WORKS FOR ALL OF OUR COMMUNITY
MEMBERS BY VALUE IN
COLLABORATION WITH STAKEHOLDERS.
THAT DIRECTLY WORK WITH OUR
ACCESS AND NEEDS POPULATION
BEFORE AN UNFORTUNATE EVENT
OCCURS  RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AIBO.
THANK YOU MISTER MONTESINOS
DISCUSSION DEBATE.
QUIRK LIBERAL.
MEMBERS.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS OF THE DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF A
CLICK WELL CLOSER ROLL TIDE BUT
I SIXTY FOUR NO ZERO THAT
MEASURE PASSES FILE ITEM.
ONE FORTY FOUR IS AB FORTY
CORRECT.
ASSEMBLY BILL FOUR EIGHTY BY
SOME REMEMBER SALAS AND ACTUALLY
MENTAL HEALTH.
MR SALAS.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
I RISE TODAY TO PRESENT ASSEMBLY
BILL FOUR EIGHTY WHICH WOULD
ESTABLISH AN OLDER ADULT MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES ADMINISTRATOR TO
OVERSEE MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
FOR OLDER ADULTS.
THE SILVER TSUNAMI IS COMING
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR EITHER.
THANK YOU MISTER SALAS SEE NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE.
CLICK WELL OPEN THE ROLE.
MEMBERS BETTER DESIRE TO VOTE ON
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE [inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSER ROLE.
TALLY THE VOTE I SIXTY FIVE NO.
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES MEMBERS
ARE PREPARED TO LIVE THE CALL ON
FILE ITEM.
TWENTY TWO THIS IS AB FOURTEEN
SEVENTY EIGHT CARILLO CARPAL
POST.
ALL MEMBERS WOULD WISH TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED WISHED OF A
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
WHO WISH TO VOTE [inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSE THE ROLAND TELL ABOUT ICE
FORTY THREE KNOWS.
EIGHTEEN THAT MEASURE PASSES.
EVEREST BACK ON THE FILE FILE
ITEM ONE FORTY FIVE IS AB FORTY
NINE BY MR STONE CORPORATION.
AS A LEGAL FOR EIGHTY NINE BY
SIMPLY MEMBER MARK STONE AND
ACTUALLY TO WATER.
MR STONE THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS THIS BILL
CLARIFIES HOW THE STATE FUNDS
CERTAIN FLOOD CONTROL PROJECTS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR I'VE OF
THANK YOU FOR YOUR BREVITY
MISTER STYLE.
SEEING NO DISCUSSION DEBATE
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS SARAH VOTE ON
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLARK WELL.
CLOSER ALL TIED ABOUT AYE AYES.
SIXTY FOUR NO ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES FILE ITEMS ONE FORTY SIX
THROUGH ONE FORTY EIGHT PASS
RETAIN.
WHERE FILE ITEM ONE FORTY NINE
EIGHTY FIVE TWENTY ONE BY MISTER
BERMAN CORKERY?
ASSEMBLY BILL FIVE TWENTY ONE BY
SOMETHING MEMBER BERMAN AND
OTHERS AND ACTUALLY THE HEALING
ARTS [inaudible]
MR BERMAN.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES AB FIVE TWENTY ONE
WOULD TASK THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA FIREARM VIOLENCE
RESEARCH CENTER WITH RESEARCHING
DEVELOPING IMPLEMENTING AND
EVALUATING.
EDUCATION AND TRAINING PROGRAMS
FOR HEALTH CARE PROVIDERS ON
PREVENTING FIRE ARM RELATED
HARLEM.
WELL HEALTHCARE PROVIDERS
RECOGNIZE THAT THEY HAVE A ROLE
IN HELPING PREVENT FARM RELATED
INJURY AND DEATH.
MANY CITE LACK OF KNOWLEDGE
REGARDING WHEN AND HOW TO
COUNSEL PATIENTS AS A PRINCIPAL
BARRIER TO ACTION.
AB FIVE TWENTY ONE RECOGNIZES
THAT HEALTH CARE PROVIDERS ARE
UNIQUELY POSITIONED TO HELP
PREVENT FIREARM RELATED ARM.
AND THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
FIRE ARM VIOLENCE RESEARCH
CENTER IS UNIQUELY QUALIFIED TO
EQUIP THEM WITH THE EDUCATION
TRAINING AND RESOURCES NEEDED TO
MITIGATE RISK AND INTERVENE IN
SITUATIONS OF IMMINENT DANGER.
THIS BILL RECEIVED BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT INTO POLICY COMMITTEES
AND HAS NO OPPOSITION I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER BERMAN.
SEE NO DISCUSSION DEBATE.
CLARK WELL OVER THERE ALL.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBER SERVICE AT A VOTE
[inaudible]
CLERK WILL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE BUT I FIFTY FOUR
KNOWS.
TO THAT MEASURE PASSES WE'RE
GOING TO PASS RETAIN.
ON FILE ITEMS ONE FIFTY THROUGH.
ONE FIFTY THREE WE'RE GOING TO
TAKE UP. ONE FIFTY FOUR AB.
FIVE FIVE TWO CORPORATE RATE.
ASSEMBLY BILL FIVE FIFTY TWO BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER MARK STONE AND
ACTUALLY THE COASTAL RESOURCES
MR STONE YOU MAY GET OPEN.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER SINCE
NINETEEN NINETY SEVEN THE STATE
HAS BEEN COLLECTING LEASE
REVENUES IN THE TIDELANDS FROM
OIL PRODUCTION TWO THOUSAND SIX
OF THOSE REVENUES GOT SWEPT INTO
THE GENERAL FUND.
THEY HAD BEEN DESIGNATED TO
PROTECT COASTAL RESOURCES BUT
THIS BILL WILL DO IS TAKE 30%.
OF THOSE TYPE OF THOSE THAILAND
LEASE REVENUES ABOUT TWENTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS A YEAR AND MAKE
THEM AVAILABLE TO LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS AND STATE AGENCIES
TO DO THE ADAPTATION WORK THAT
THEY NEED IN THE FACE OF THE
CHANGING CLIMATE.
THAT IMPACTS LIKE SEA LEVEL RISE
IN THE COASTAL ZONE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS DOWN SEE NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE [inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSER ALL TELL YOU BUT I FIFTY
TWO KNOWS TEN THAT MEASURE
PASSES PASS RETAIN A FILE ITEM.
ONE FIFTY FIVE FILE ITEM ONE
FIFTY SIX A. B..
FIVE FIVE SIX CORPORATION
ASSEMBLY BILL FIVE FIFTY SIX BY
SOME REMEMBER CARILLO AND OTHERS
AND ACTUALLY THE PUBLIC
RESOURCES MS CARILLO.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS I'M PROUD TO PRESENT AB
FIVE FIVE SIX WHICH WILL HELP
PROVIDE OUTDOOR EXPERIENCE TO
DISADVANTAGED YOUTH AND IMPROVE
THEIR OVERALL HEALTH AND WELL
BEING.
THIS BILL IS SIMILAR TO AB
TWENTY SIX FOURTEEN THAT I
AUTHORED LAST YEAR WHICH I
ENJOYED BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND
MADE IT TO THE GOVERNOR'S DESK.
MANY YOUNG PEOPLE FROM URBAN AND
RULE DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES
ACROSS CALIFORNIA HAVE LITTLE TO
NO ACCESS TO OUTDOOR EXPERIENCES
EVEN WHEN THEY LIVE MINUTES
WITHIN THE SPACES.
AB FIVE FIVE SIX WILL TASK THE
NATURAL RESOURCE AGENCY WITH
CREATING A COMMUNITY ACCESS
PROGRAM TO ENABLE CALIFORNIANS
TO REACH.
AND UTILIZE NATURAL EDUCATION
AND RECREATIONAL RESOURCES THIS
BILL WILL ALSO ALLOW FOR THE
CREATION OF A GRANT PROGRAM
PROVIDING SUPPORT FOR INNOVATIVE
TRANSPORTATION PROJECTS TO
FOSTER.
MORE ACCESS TO THOSE WHO ARE
OFTEN DENIED.
INCREDIBLE OUTDOOR EXPERIENCES
ACROSS OUR STATE AND I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS PREDICT WHAT
YOU'RE RECOGNIZED YES QUESTION
OF THE AUTHOR -- WITHOUT
OBJECTION THE QUESTION IS -- I
HAVE CONCERNS WITH THE THE
ENVIRO SCAN WHICH IS PART WHICH
ARE BASED ON AND I UNDERSTAND
YOU ARE COMMITTED.
TO LOOKING FOR ADDITIONAL WAYS
TO HELP WITH THIS PROGRAM.
IS ACT PASS OR OR WOULD YOU
COMMIT TO LOOKING WE ARE
COMMITTED TO MAKING SURE THAT WE
ARE LOOKING AT EVERYTHING TO
MAKE SURE THAT FOLKS HAVE ACCESS
TO THE OUTDOORS.
AND I WOULD THE REASON FOR
ASKING IT THANK YOU THANK YOU
FOR THAT COMMENDED REASON RASKIN
IS I HAVE A LOT OF POOR PEOPLE
IN MY COMMUNITIES.
WHO CAN'T ACCESS PARKS IS EASILY
AS I'D LIKE THEM TO BE ABLE TO
AS WELL?
BUT IF THIS IS BASED ON THE
ENVIRO SCANNED.
MY COMMUNITIES DON'T.
FALL UNDER THAT BECAUSE IT JUST
SIMPLY DOESN'T IT DOESN'T WORK
IN THE IN THE CURRENT SYSTEM SO
SO WE'RE GOING TO REALLY OPEN
THIS UP TO ALL DISADVANTAGED
PEOPLE WE NEED TO BE LOOKING AT
AT SOMETHING OTHER THAN JUST IN
VIRUS SCAN ON ISSUES LIKE THIS
ARE.
RISK I I I RESPECT THAT --
MITCHELL LET'S TAKE A LOOK AT
THAT THANK YOU ABSOLUTELY THANK.
THEY ATTACK WOULD MISTER MATHIS
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS --
WANT TO THANK MY COLLEAGUE FROM
ACROSS THE AISLE FOR BRINGING
THIS FORWARD.
ON GETTING OUR CHILDREN ACCESS
TO PARKS IN GETTING OUTDOORS IS
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT.
OF SPECIALLY FOR EDUCATING THEM
ON HOW THE ENVIRONMENT WORKS AND
WHAT ELSE OUT THERE -- THE HIGH --
THE SIDES THE CONCRETE JUNGLES --
THIS COMPLIMENTS THE BILL THAT I
WORKED ON EARLIER THIS YEAR --
TO GET EVERY FOURTH GRADER --
PARK PASS -- WHICH DIDN'T MAKE
IT THROUGH -- JUST TRYING.
TO YOU KNOW FIGURED THE FEDERAL
SIDE IN OUR PRESIDENT DONALD
TRUMP IS DOING THIS FOR OUR
FOURTH GRADERS SO I THOUGHT
CALIFORNIA WANT TO DO IT BUT
THIS IS ALSO A GREAT WAY TO GET
KIDS IN THE PARKS LAST FOR AN
AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER MATHIS SEE NO
ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION.
MISS KOREA YOU MAY CLOSE IF YOU
WISH.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU AND WE WILL OPEN THE
ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF THE
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLICK WELL.
CLOSER ROLE TOWN ABOUT EYES
[inaudible]
FIFTY FIVE KNOWS.
TO THAT MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS WHERE FILE ITEM.
ONE FIFTY SEVEN AB FIVE SIXTY
SEVEN BY MISTER CALDERON.
KERKORIAN.
ASSEMBLY WILL FIVE SIXTY SEVEN
BY SOME REMEMBER CALDERON AND
ACTUALLY TO INSURANCE MISTER
CALDERON.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
AB FIVE SIXTY SEVEN ESTABLISHES
A LONG TERM CARE INSURANCE TASK
FORCE CONVENED BY THE INSURANCE
COMMISSIONER THE PURPOSE OF THE
TASK FORCE IS TO PROVIDE EXPERT
RECOMMENDATIONS IT'LL INSURANCE
COMMISSIONER.
THE LEGISLATURE AND THE GOVERNOR
AND THE COMPONENTS NECESSARY TO
ESTABLISH A STATEWIDE LONG TERM
CARE INSURANCE PROGRAM
CALIFORNIA THIS IS IMPORTANT TO
ME I'VE WORKED ON THESE ISSUES
EVER SINCE I GOT ELECTED TO THE
LEGISLATURE I VERY MUCH SEE LONG
TERM CARE INSURANCE.
AS A MILLENNIAL ISSUE BECAUSE
OUR FAMILIES AND OUR PARENTS
THAT LOST THEIR JOBS LOST OUR
BUSINESSES LOST THEIR HOMES.
DURING THE GREAT RECESSION AND
ULTIMATELY WHEN THEY DON'T HAVE
THE SUPPORT THAT THEY NEED FOR
THEIR RETIREMENT THAT ENDS UP
FALLING ON US THE KIDS WHO ARE
GRADUATING COLLEGE WITH
MOUNTAINS WORTH OF CALLS.
STUDENT LOAN DEBT CAN'T GET A
JOB PAYING ABOVE MINIMUM WAGE
STILL HAVING TO MOVE BACK IN
WITH YOUR PARENTS SO THAT'S A
LOT OF RESPONSIBILITY SO IT'S
ABOUT A FUTURE GENERATIONS AND
MAKING SURE THAT OUR PARENTS AND
OUR FAMILY.
DESERVES YEAH AND GET THE
RESOURCES THAT THEY NEED -- TO
MAKE SURE THAT THEY'RE TAKING
CARE OF IN THE EVENT THAT THEY
NEED IT I THINK THIS IS
IMPORTANT I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER CALDERON.
SEE NO DISCUSSION DEBATE.
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF VOTE
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS OTHERS OUT OF A
CLERK WELL.
CLOSER ALL AND TALLY THE VOTE I
SIXTY TWO KNOWS ONE THAT MEASURE
PASSES.
PASS TO RETAIN A FILE ITEM.
ONE FIFTY EIGHT FILE ITEM.
ONE FIFTY NINE AB FIVE EIGHTY
ONE BY MR LEVINE CORKERY.
ASSEMBLY BILL FIVE EIGHTY ONE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER LEVINE AND
ACTUALLY THE SENTENCING THE SHOW
ME THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS WE'VE WORKED
TOGETHER TO PASS A COUPLE OF
LAWS TO PROTECT VETERANS WHO.
HAVE SUFFERED SERVICE INDUCED
MENTAL HEALTH ILLNESSES DRAMATIC
BRAIN INJURY POSTTRAUMATIC
STRESS -- THIS BILL EIGHTY FIVE
EIGHTY EIGHTY ONE WILL EXTEND
THOSE PROTECTIONS VETERANS WHO
HAD A DIAGNOSIS AFTER THEY WERE
SENTENCED -- AND I ASK
RESPECTFULLY FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER LEVINE SAYING
NO DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE ITEM
QUIRK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS OF IT IS OUT OF OUT
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF A
CLICK WELL CLOSER ROLE.
TELL YOU VOTE AYE AYES.
SIXTY TWO NO ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES FILE ITEMS.
ONE SIXTY THREE ONE SIXTY THREE
PASS RETAIN.
FILE ITEM ONE SIXTY FOUR IS AB
SIX THIRTY FIVE AYE MR BIGELOW.
QUICKLY.
ASSEMBLY BILL SIX THIRTY FIVE BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BIGELOW AND
ACTUALLY THE DISTRICT
AGRICULTURAL ASSOCIATIONS MISTER
BIGELOW.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
AB SIX THIRTY FIVE IS BEFORE YOU
FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SIR SAY NO DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE.
CLARK WELL OVER THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS OF DESIRE TO VOTE
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ADDED THOUGH.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLARK WELL CLOSE ROAD TIME OUT I
SIXTY THREE KNOWS.
ONE THAT MEASURE PASSES.
FILE ITEM ONE SIXTY FIVE A. B.
SIX THIRTY NINE FOR COREY
ASSEMBLY BILL SIX THIRTY NINE BY
SOMETHING MEMBER CERVANTES AND
ACTUALLY THE CLIMATE CHANGE.
MR MONTEZ THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS THE STATE IS
CURRENTLY IN THE PROCESS OF
TRANSITIONING TO A LOWER CARBON
ECONOMY INCLUDING TRANSFORMING
THE STATE'S GOODS MOVEMENT
SYSTEM.
AB SIX THIRTY NINE REQUIRES THE
CALIFORNIA AIR RESOURCE BOARD
WHEN ADOPTING THE GHG SCOPING
PLAN TRIDENTINE FIND RECOMMEND
AND RECOMMEND ACTIONS TO
MITIGATE THE NEGATIVE IMPACTS ON
INCUMBENT WORKERS.
IN ORDER TO ADDRESS ONE OF THE
STATE'S MOST PRESSING NEEDS THE
BILL ALSO ESTABLISHES A
COMMISSION TO ADVICE STATE
AGENCIES ON POLICIES AND FUNDING
TO MITIGATE THE EMPLOYMENT
IMPACTS OF TRANSITIONING.
SEE POOR OPERATION TWO ZERO AND
NEAR ZERO MISSIONS THIS BILL
WILL HOW CALIFORNIA DEVELOP A
WORKABLE GAME PLAN THAT SUPPORTS
AN INCLUSIVE ECONOMY AN UPWARD
MOBILITY FOR ALL CALIFORNIANS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR I ABOUT
THANK YOU MISTER MONTESINOS
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
QUIRK WELL THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS BETTER CEREMONY.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ACTIVO.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
QUIRK WELL CLOSER ALL TIE VOTE I
FIFTY NINE ONE SIXTY SIX IS AB
SIX FORTY TO THE MONTGOMERY.
ASSEMBLY BILL SIX FORTY TWO BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER LOW MOAN AND
ACTUALLY THE FINANCE LENDING.
MS LAMONT.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AB SIX
FOR TWO WILL PROVIDE IMPORTANT
CONSUMER PROTECTIONS FOR THE
THOUSANDS OF CONSUMERS AND SMALL
BUSINESS OWNERS.
WHO ARE SIR BY THE FINANCE
LENDERS AND BROKER LICENSES
UNDER THE CALIFORNIA FINANCING
LAW?
THE BILL DOES THREE BASIC THINGS --
ONE IT ALLOWS FOR BUSINESS
LICENSES FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF
BUSINESS OVERSIGHT TO PROVIDES
TRANSPARENT DISCLOSURES FOR
CUSTOMERS AND THREE OBTAINS.
REQUIRES OBTAINING CUSTOMERS
CONSENT BEFORE SELLING IN
TRANSMITTING CONFIDENTIAL
INFORMATION I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK IS AMONG SAY NO DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
THE CEREMONY ALL MEMBERS VOTED
TO SARAH VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE
.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
KIRK WELL CLOSER ALL TELL ABOUT
AYE AYES FORTY TWO NO.
SIXTEEN THAT MEASURE PASSES FILE
ITEM ONE SIXTY TO EIGHTY SIX
FIFTY ONE CORKERY.
ASSEMBLY BILL SIX FIFTY ONE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GRAYSON AND
OTHERS AND ACTUALLY TO AIR
AMBULANCE SERVICES.
MR GRAYSON.
MISTER SPEAKER AND COLLEAGUES SB
SIX FIFTY ONE WILL INCREASE MEDI
CAL REIMBURSEMENT RATES FOR
EMERGENCY ERR AMBULANCE
PROVIDERS WITHOUT PASSAGE OF
THIS LEGISLATION AND TWENTY
NINETEEN REIMBURSEMENT WILL
REVERT TO NINETEEN NINETY THREE
LEVELS.
EMERGENCY ERR AMBULANCE
PROVIDERS ARE AN ESSENTIAL PART
OF THE STATEWIDE EMS SYSTEM AND
CURRENT MEDICAL RATES PAY
PROVIDERS FAR BELOW THE RATE
NEEDED TO PROVIDE THE SERVICES.
AB SIX FIFTY ONE WILL RE BASE
THE MEDI CAL RATE FOR AIR
AMBULANCE PROVIDERS TO THE RULES
OF MEDICARE LEVEL WHICH WILL
BRING AIR AMBULANCE PROVIDERS
CLOSER TO ACTUAL COST.
IN DOING SO SB SIX FIVE ONE WILL
ENSURE AIR AMBULANCE PROVIDERS
CAN CONTINUE PROVIDING
LIFESAVING SERVICES TO RESIDENTS
THROUGHOUT OUR STATE THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME AND ATTENTION
EVERY RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
AYE.
THANK YOU IS GRAYSON SEEN NO
DISCUSSION ON THE ITEM CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
REVERSAL.
THESE ARE VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE THE ALL MEMBERS VOTER
DESIRE TO VOTE [inaudible]
CLICK WELL [inaudible]
CLOSER ALL.
HOWEVER I SIXTY THREE NO.
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSED THE
FILES ONE SIXTY EIGHT THROUGH
ONE SEVENTY TO PASS RETAIN FILE
ITEM.
ONE SEVENTY THREE AB SIX SEVENTY
ONE FRIEDMAN HARPER READ
ASSEMBLY BILL SIX SEVENTY ONE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRIEDMAN AND
ACTUALLY LAND USE MS FREEMAN.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS.
I KNOW YOU ALL LOVE EIGHTY USE
HERE'S ANOTHER EIGHTY YOU BILL
FOR YOU THIS BILL ASKAR
LOCALITIES TO PLAN FOR AT
INCENTIVIZING LOW AND MODERATE
INCOME EIGHTY USE.
BY PARTNERING WITH OUR SINGLE
FAMILY HOMEOWNERS SO THAT THEY
CAN HAVE SOME SMALL SUBSIDY
POSSIBLY TO BUILD THEIR EIGHTY
YOU AND THEN IN EXCHANGE RENTED
OUT TO LOW INCOME COMMUNITY
MEMBERS.
THIS BILL IS RECEIVED NO NO
VOTES IN COMMITTEE AND HAS
STRONG BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND I
REQUEST AN AYE VOTE TODAY THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU MS FRIEDMAN SEE NO
DISCUSSION.
LOCAL OF THE ROLE [inaudible]
MEMBERS DESIRE BUT ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS OUT OF A ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLICK WELL CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT
AYE FIFTY EIGHT NO ZERO THAT
MEASURE PASSES FILE ITEMS ONCE
EVERY FOUR THROUGH ONE SEVENTY
SIX PASS.
AND RETAIN FILE ITEM.
ONE SEVENTY SEVEN AB SIX EIGHTY
FOUR BY MISTER LEVINE.
COVERAGE.
ASSEMBLY WILL SIX EIGHTY FOUR BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER LEVINE AND OTHERS
AND ACTUALLY BUILDING STANDARDS
MISS PHILIPPINES.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS THIS BILL WILL
ASK THE BUILDING -- STANDARDS
COMMISSION TO UPDATE THEIR EVEY
E. CAPABLE PARKING SPACE
STANDARDS FOR MULTI FAMILY AND
COMMERCIAL HOUSING ALSO ASK FOR
EACH CD TO REVIEW THOSE
REQUIREMENTS AND UPDATE THEM AS
REQUIRED I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER LEVINE SEE NO
DISCUSSION ON THE ITEM.
COR CLUB IN THE ROLE ALL MEMBERS
OF THE SENATE AT ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED A SATIRE TO
VOTE.
CLICK WELL CLOSER ALL TIED ABOUT
AYE SIXTY THREE NO ZERO THAT
MEASURE PASSES FILE ITEMS ONE
SEVENTY EIGHT A ONE SEVENTY NINE
PASS RETAIN.
FILE ITEM.
ONE EIGHTY AB SEVEN OH EIGHT BY
MR FRAZIER CORKERY.
ASSEMBLY WILL SEVEN OH EIGHT BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRAZIER AND
ACTUALLY TRAFFIC VIOLATORS
SCHOOL.
MISTER FRAZIER THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS AB SEVEN AWAIT
CLOSES A LOOPHOLE THAT ALLOWS
ONLINE TRAFFIC VIOLATORS SCHOOLS.
TO CREATE HUNDREDS OF SIMILAR
NAME SCHOOLS FOR THE PURPOSE OF
DOMINATING THE DMV REFERRAL LIST.
THEREBY INCREASING THE ODDS OF
VIOLATORS PARTICIPATING THE
STATE PROGRAM WILL RANDOMLY
SELECT ONE OF THE REGISTERS
SCHOOL NAMES.
THIS BILL HAS RECEIVED UNANIMOUS
SUPPORT IN COMMITTEE AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR RIVAL.
THANK YOU MISTER FRAZIER SEE NO
DISCUSSION ON THE ITEM CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS OF OUR DESIRE TO
VOTE
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLARK WELL CLOSER ROLE.
AND TALLY THE VOTE I SIXTY FIVE
NO.
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES.
FILE ITEM IS ONE EIGHTY ONE AND
ONE EIGHTY TWO PASS RETAIN FILE
ITEM TWENTY THREE A. B. SEVEN
TWENTY MURATSUCHI CARPOOL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL SEVEN TWENTY BY
FAMILY MEMBER MURATSUCHI AND
OTHERS AND ACTUALLY COMMUNITY
COLLEGES MR MURATSUCHI.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
SPEAKER I'M PRESENTING AB SEVEN
TWENTY WHICH PROPOSES A
COMMONSENSE FIX.
THAT IS SUPPORTED BY
FIREFIGHTERS AS WELL AS MANY
COMMUNITY COLLEGES THROUGHOUT
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
AND THIRTY TWO OVER SEVENTY
THREE COMMITTEE COLLEGE
DISTRICTS THERE ARE AGREEMENTS
TO ALLOW STUDENTS IF THE
FIREFIGHTERS OR POLICE OFFICERS
TO RECEIVE ONGOING TRAINING.
THROUGH THEIR LOCAL COMMUNICABLE
IS HOWEVER LAST SHOULD THE
LEGISLATURE ADOPTED A NEW.
COMMITTEE CALL THIS FUNDING
FORMULA THAT -- THAT PENALIZES
DISTRICTS THAT THAT PROVIDE
THESE PROGRAMS BECAUSE OUR
PUBLIC SAFETY PERSONNEL NEITHER
ARE NEITHER LOW INCOME NOR
RECEIVE A TWO YEAR DEGREE OR
CERTIFICATE.
THIS BILL HAS RECEIVED STRONG
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND IS
SUPPORTED AGAIN BY OUR
FIREFIGHTERS AND CAN YOU
COLLEGES AND HAS NO OPPOSITION.
I ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER MURATSUCHI
SAYING NO DISCUSSION ON THE ITEM
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBER SERVICE OUT OF THOSE
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBER SERVICE AT A VOTE
[inaudible]
WELL.
CLOSER ROLES HOWEVER I SIXTY
FOUR NO ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES
FILE ITEM ONE EIGHTY FOUR AS AB
SEVEN TWENTY TWO BY MISTER
BIGELOW CORKERY.
ASSEMBLY WILL SEVEN TWENTY TWO
BY SOME THEM A BIGELOW AND
ACTUALLY TO WATER.
MR BIGELOW.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
A. B. SEVEN TWENTY TWO
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
IT'S NOT A COMPETITION MISTER
BIGELOW BUT IF IT WERE YOUR
WINNING.
SEE NO DISCUSSION ON THE ITEM.
WORK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS OF DESIRE TO VOTE
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF A ALL
MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE [inaudible]
QUIRK WELL [inaudible]
CLOSER ALL.
AND TELL YOU WHAT I SIXTY TWO
KNOWS ONE THAT MEASURE PASSES
FILE ITEMS ONE EIGHTY FIVE
THROUGH.
ONE EIGHTY SEVEN PASS A RETAIN.
FILE ITEM.
ONE EIGHTY EIGHT AB.
SEVEN EIGHTY THREE ASSEMBLY BILL
SEVEN EIGHTY THREE BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BIGELOW AND ACTUALLY THE
STATE PARKS.
BACK TO YOU MISTER BIGELOW.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS OUT OF RESPECT FOR THE
TIME OF THE DAY I WOULD JUST
ENCOURAGE AN AYE VOTE ON A. B..
SEVEN EIGHTY THREE IS THERE ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SEEING NONE CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS OF USER TO VOTE ON
MEMBERS BETTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
DESIRE TO VOTE [inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSER ALL TALLY THAT I SIXTY
TWO KNOWS.
ONE THAT MEASURE PASSES.
FILE ITEM IS.
ONE EIGHTY NINE AND ONE NINETY
PASS RETAIN MORE FILE ITEM.
ONE NINETY ONE AB SEVEN NINETY
EIGHT CORPORATION ASSEMBLY BILL
SEVEN NINETY EIGHT BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CERVANTES AND
ACTUALLY THE PUBLIC HEALTH.
MR MANTAS THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS AB SEVEN NINETY
EIGHT WILL CREATE A PILOT
PROGRAM TO PROVIDE PSYCHIATRY
TELE CONSULTATION OR VIRTUAL
MENTORING SERVICES BY.
INCREASING THE AVAILABILITY A
TELE CONSULTATION THIS BILL WILL
ADDRESS THE KEY ISSUES OF
IMPROVING ACCESS FOR MATERNAL
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES FOR WOMEN
SUFFERING FROM INTERNAL MENTAL
HEALTH DISORDERS I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER MONTEZ SEE NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE ITEM.
LOCAL OPEN THE ROLE [inaudible]
MEMBERS.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE ON MEMBERS
VOTERS OUT OF A ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
DESIRE TO VOTE [inaudible]
QUIRK WELL.
CLOSE ROLES HOWEVER I SIXTY SIX
NO.
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES.
FILE ITEMS ONE NINETY TWO AND
ONE NINETY THREE PASS RETAIN
FILE ITEM ONE NINETY FOUR IS AB
EIGHT TWENTY SIX OPERATE.
AS A LEGAL EIGHT TWENTY SIX BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER REYES AND
ACTUALLY MEDI CAL.
MS RACE.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS I RISE TODAY TO PRESENT
AB EIGHT TWENTY SIX WHICH WILL
ENSURE THE FOSTER YOUTH WERE
PLACED OUT OF COUNTY.
INTO SHORT TERM RESIDENTIAL
THERAPEUTIC PROGRAMS.
ALSO KNOWN AS STR TEEPEES WILL
RECEIVE TIMELY ACCESS TO MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES.
THEY'RE ENTITLED TO UNDER STATE
AND FEDERAL LAW.
SPECIFICALLY AB EIGHT TWENTY SIX
EXEMPTS THESE PARTICULAR FOSTER
YOUTH FROM THE REQUIREMENT A
PRESUMPTIVE TRANSFER WITH
CERTAIN EXCEPTIONS.
EXEMPTION EXCEPTIONS.
INSTEAD WOULD REQUIRE WHEN A
YOUTH IS PLACED OUT OF COUNTY
INTO A GROUP CARE SETTING.
BUT THE RESPONSIBILITY FOR
PROVIDING AND ARRANGING FOR
THEIR MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
REMAINS WITH THE COUNTY IN WHICH
THE YOUTH ENTERED FOSTER CARE.
THIS BILL HAS ENJOYED UNANIMOUS
SUPPORT IN HUMAN SERVICES HELP
AND APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEES I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR RIVAL.
THANK YOU WAS RAISING THEIR
DISCUSS OR DEBATE CLERK WILL
OPEN ROLE.
ALL MEMBER SERVICE ARE TO VOTE
ON MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE THE CLARK
WELL.
CLOSE THE ROLE AND TALLY THE
VOTE.
I SIXTY SEVEN KNOWS.
ONE THE MEASURE PASSES.
FILE ITEMS ONE NINETY FIVE A ONE
NINETY SIX PASS RETAIN.
FILE ITEM ONE NINETY SEVEN AB
EIGHT FORTY ONE BY MR TANG
CORPORATE.
ASSEMBLY WILL EIGHT FORTY ONE BY
SOME THE MEMBER TING AND
ACTUALLY THE DRINKING WATER.
MR TANK MAILED WHEN THEY GIVE A
SPEAKER AB EIGHT FORTY ONE WOULD
REQUIRE THE OFFICE OF THE BARN
MENTAL HEALTH AND HAZARD
ASSESSMENT. TO ADOPT A WORK PLAN
TO DETERMINE WHICH SUBSTANCES
WITHIN CLASS OF P. FAST
CHEMICALS SHOULD BE ASSESSED AS
A RISK TO HUMAN HEALTH.
AND WHETHER OR NOT NOTIFICATION
LEVELS SHOULD BE ADOPTED.
FACETS ARE SYNTHETICS THAT ARE
USED IN FRYING PANS AS WELL AS
IN FOOD WRAPPERS THAT WE ARE ALL.
TOO MUCH TO IN COMMON.
COME IN CONTACT WITH A TIMES ARE
VERY DANGEROUS BUT THERE'S BEEN.
REALLY NO -- NO DECISION AS TO
HOW MUCH IS OKAY TO BE EXPOSED
TO SO WITH THAT WE'RE ASKING --
WE HA TO TAKE A LOOK AT THE
STUDY AND GET BACK TO OUR SITE
WITHOUT I RESPECTFULLY ASK
PRIVATE ON AB.
EIGHT FORTY ONE THANK YOU MISTER
TANG.
SEEING NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THE ITEM.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS OF THE DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSE ROLE TELL YOU WHAT I SIXTY
FIVE NO.
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES.
FILE ITEM. ONE NINETY EIGHT PASS
RETAIN WE'RE GOING TO TAKE A
MISTER GRAY'S FILE ITEM. ONE
NINETY NINE AB EIGHT FORTY EIGHT
CORPORATION ASSEMBLY WILL EIGHT
FORTY EIGHT BY SOMETHING MEMBER
GRAY AND OTHERS AND ACTUALLY
MEDI CAL.
NAME IS.
MISTER GRAY YOU MAIL.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
ABA FORTY EIGHT MANDATES THAT
MEDI CAL PROVIDE COVERAGE FOR
CONTINUOUS GLUCOSE MONITORS WHEN
MEDICALLY NECESSARY I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER GRAVES SAYING
NO DISCUSSION ON THE ITEM.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
CLICK WELL.
CLOSER ROLAND TALLY THE VOTE I
SIXTY FOUR KNOWS.
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES MEMBERS
WITHOUT OBJECTION WE'RE GOING TO
STAY WITH MISTER GRAY TO TAKE UP
FILE ITEM. THREE NINETY EIGHT
THIS IS FILE ITEM.
THREE NINETY EIGHT AB.
SIX THIRTY EIGHT CORPORATION.
ASSEMBLY BILL SIX THIRTY EIGHT
BY SOMETHING MEMBER GRAY AND
ACTUALLY THE WATER RESOURCES.
MR GRAY YOU MAY OPEN.
THANK YOU RESPECT MEMBERS AB SIX
THIRTY IT REQUIRES THE PART OF
OUR RESOURCES TO IDENTIFY
THREATS TO WATER RELIABILITY AS
RELATES TO CLIMATE CHANGE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER GRAY SAYING NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE.
SHE GRAY IS CALDERON WHATEVER
WORK WITH YOU.
SEE NO DISCUSSION BATES CLARK
WELL OVER THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS OF IS THAT A VOTE
ALL MEMBERS OF DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS HAVE A DESIRE TO
VOTE.
CLARK WELL CLOSER ALL TIED ABOUT.
I SIXTY THREE NO.
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES.
FILE ITEM TWO HUNDRED PASS
RETAIN FILE ITEM TWO OH ONE
EIGHT SEVEN FIVE A. B. EIGHT
SEVEN FIVE MISS WICKS CORPORAL
READ.
SOMETHING WILL EIGHT SEVENTY
FIVE BY SOMETHING MEMBER WICKS
AND ACTING PEOPLE HEALTH.
THIS WHICH EMAIL.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER A
MEMBERS.
I RISE TODAY FOR AND ASK FOR
YOUR SUPPORT OF AB EIGHT SEVEN
FIVE EIGHT SEVEN FIVE IS HERE TO
REESTABLISH THE HEALTHY START
INITIATIVE THE HEALTHY START
INITIATIVES AROUND FROM.
NINETEEN NINETY TWO TO TWO
THOUSAND AND SEVEN AND IT
PROVIDED CONFERENCE OF ACADEMIC
AND HEALTH SUPPORT TWO CHILDREN
THROUGH SCHOOL LINK SERVICES.
SO THAT OUR LOW INCOME STUDENTS
ARE CHILDREN THAT ARE A LIVING
AT BELOW THE POVERTY LEVEL COULD
ACCESS HEALTH RESOURCES MENTAL
HEALTH RESOURCES.
CAL FIRST PROGRAMS AND THINGS OF
THIS NATURE.
AB EIGHT SEVEN FIVE ALL MODERN
AND MODERNIZE AND RESTORE THE
HEALTHY START INITIATIVE AND ONE
SURE THAT ARE LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES HAVE HAVE ACCESS TO
THESE RESOURCES IT'S ABOUT
CREATING THAT SOCIAL SAFETY NET.
THAT I KNOW THAT MANY OF US
BELIEVE IN AND FRANKLY MANY OF
US HAVE BENEFITTED FROM.
THIS HAS RECEIVED A BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MS WICKS SAY NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE [inaudible]
CLARK LIBERAL [inaudible]
MEMBERS.
SARAH VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
OUT OF THOSE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLICK WELL.
CLOSER ROLE TALLY THE VOTE I
SIXTY FIVE NO.
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES FILE
ITEM TWO OH TWO IS AB EIGHT
EIGHT FIVE SEPARATE.
ASSEMBLY WILL EIGHT EIGHTY FIVE
BY SOME THE MEMBER IRWIN AND
ACTUALLY TO TAXATION.
MR WENT.
THANK YOU AB EIGHT EIGHT FIVE
WILL HELP VICTIMS OF THE RECENT
CALIFORNIA WILDFIRES AND OTHER
NATURAL DISASTERS GET BACK ON
THEIR FEET BY PROVIDING MUCH
NEEDED PROPERTY TAX RELIEF.
THIS BILL SPONSORED BY THE
CALIFORNIA ASSESSORS ASSOCIATION
ENCOURAGES RESIDENTS TO STAY AND
REBUILD AND THEIR COMMUNITIES
AFTER A NATURAL DISASTER.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR NIGHT OF
THANK YOU MISTER ONC NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
DESIRE TO VOTE ON MEMBERS SO
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
CLARK WELL CLOSER ALL TIE BUT I
SIXTY THREE NO.
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES FILE IN
TWO OR THREE AB EIGHT NINETY
FOUR BY MISTER OR SANTIAGO
CORPORATE.
ASSEMBLY WILL EIGHT NINETY FOUR
BY SOME A MEMBER SANTIAGO AND
OTHERS AND ACTUALLY STATE
GOVERNMENT.
MR SANTIAGO.
I THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER --
THIS BILL WOULD INCREASE THE
NUMBER OF ATTORNEY GENERAL
EXEMPTION POSITIONS WITHIN THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR EITHER.
SEE NO DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBER SERVICE ARE TO VOTE
ON MEMBERS OF THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO THE
CLARK WELL.
CLOSER ALL TALBOT EYES FORTY
FIVE NO SEVENTEEN THAT MEASURE
PASSES FILE ITEM TO A FOR AB.
EIGHT NINE EIGHT OPERATE A SOME
LEGAL EIGHT NINETY EIGHT BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WICKS AND
ACTUALLY MEDI CAL.
MS WICKS THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS.
RESEARCH DEMONSTRATES THAT
POVERTY EARLY CHILDHOOD
ADVERSITY AND SOCIAL SOCIAL
ISOLATION COULD CONTRIBUTE TO
SHORT AND LONG TERM BEHAVIOR
HEALTH CONSEQUENCES.
ACROSS OUR LIFE AND IN
CALIFORNIA MORE THAN 60% OF
CALIFORNIA CHILDREN EXPERIENCED
AT LEAST ONE ADVERSE CHILDHOOD
EVENT.
ESTIMATES ESTIMATES SUGGEST THAT
22% OF LOW INCOME CHILDREN HAVE
A BEHAVIOR HEALTH DISORDER THAT
NEGATIVELY IMPACTS.
THEIR HEALTH AND WELL BEING AND
WE KNOW THAT WE'RE NOT SERVING
THESE CHILDREN IN THE WAY THAT
WE CAN.
MY BILL AB EIGHT NINE EIGHT
WOULD DIRECT THE HEALTH AND
HUMAN SERVICES AGENCY TO CONVENE
THE CHILDREN'S BEHAVIOR HEALTH
ACTION TEAM. TO ASSESS AND
ADDRESS THE SYSTEMATIC PROBLEMS
THAT LIMIT ACCESS TO MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES FOR OUR NEEDIEST
YOUNG PEOPLE.
AB EIGHT NINE EIGHT IS AN
IMPORTANT FIRST STEP TO
IMPROVING THE SYSTEM THAT SERVES
CHILDREN WITH BEHAVIOR HEALTH
NEEDS.
AND IT IS BEING SUPPORTED BY
DOZENS OF ORGANIZATIONS ACROSS
THE STATE WHO CARE ABOUT OUR
YOUNG CHILDREN I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MS WICKS C. NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE ITEM.
WILL OF THE ROLE.
LETTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO THE
CLARK WELL.
CLOSER ROLE TALLY THE VOTE I
SIXTY FOUR NO.
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES PASS
RETAIN A PHONE.
TWO OH FIVE PHYLON TWO OH SIX IS
AB NINE SEVENTEEN BY MS REYES
CORKERY.
ASSEMBLY WILL NINE SEVENTEEN BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER REYES AND
ACTUALLY THE VICTIMS OF CRIME.
THIS RACE.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS AB NINE SEVENTEEN WILL
UPDATE THE TIMELINE FOR LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES AND
CERTIFICATION ENTITIES TO
PROVIDE THE PROPER DOCUMENTATION
TO THE VICTIM OF A CRIME.
OR THE REPRESENTATIVE FOR THE
PURPOSES OF OBTAINING YOU VISA.
OR TV'S A CERTIFICATION.
THIS BILL HAS RECEIVED UNANIMOUS
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND HAS NO NO
VOTES ON THE RECORD. EIGHTY NINE
SEVENTEEN WILL ENHANCE THE
OVERALL PUBLIC SAFETY OF
CALIFORNIANS TO ENSURE THAT
IMMIGRANTS WHO ARE VICTIMS OF
CRIMES AND WILL COOPERATE WITH
LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT IN GOOD
FAITH.
RECEIVE THE NEEDED DOCUMENTATION
THAT PROTECTS THEM FROM
DEPORTATION I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MS REYES SAY NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE.
WORK WELL OVER THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS OF THE SATIRE TO
VOTE ALL MEMBERS OF OUR DESIRE
TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS SO.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE CLERK WILL.
CLOSE THE ROLE TALLY THE VOTE
ICE FIFTY FOUR NO ZERO THAT
MEASURE PASSES FILE ITEM TO US I
HAVE A TWO OH SEVEN AB NINE ONE
NINE CREEK RATE.
ASSEMBLY WILL NINE NINETEEN BY
SOME REMEMBER PETRIE-NORRIS AND
ACTUALLY THE DRUG AND ALCOHOL
PROGRAMS.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
I RISE TODAY TO ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT FOR AB EIGHT NINE ONE
NINE THIS BILL WILL ESTABLISH A
ENFORCEMENT PROGRAM AT THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES.
IN ORDER TO PREVENT AND STOP
BODY BURKE GREEN SCHEMES THAT
ARE PREYING ON VULNERABLE
PATIENTS WHO ARE SEEKING
LEGITIMATE SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDER TREATMENT.
THIS WILL ENABLE THE DH CS TO
IMPLEMENT AND ENFORCE RECENTLY
PASSED STATE AND FEDERAL LAWS.
THIS BILL IS RECEIVED UNANIMOUS
SUPPORT IN BOTH THE ASSEMBLY
HEALTH AND THE ASSEMBLY
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS PRC NO DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE WRONG.
ALL MEMBERS PHONE DESIRE TO VOTE
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS OTHERS ARE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
CLERK WILL.
CLOSER ROLE TALLY THE VOTE I
SIXTY FIVE NO.
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES.
FILE ITEMS TO AWAIT TWO OF NINE
HOUSE RETAIN.
FILE ITEM TO TENNIS AB NINE FOUR
FOUR BY DR QUIRK CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY WILL NINE FORTY FOUR BY
FAMILY MEMBER QUIRK AND OTHERS
AND ACTUALLY THE PUBLIC SOCIAL
SERVICES.
DOCTOR QUIRK.
THANK YOU SPEAKER IN MEMBERS.
IF THE COUNTY DETERMINES A
SPONSORED NON CITIZEN WOULD GO
HUNGRY AND HOMELESS WITHOUT AID.
AB NINE FORTY FOUR WOULD REQUIRE
COUNTIES TO RENEW CAL WORKS
BENEFITS TO AN ELIGIBLE
SPONSORED INDIGENT NON CITIZEN.
THIS CHANGE WILL ALLOW CALTRAIN
ALIGN.
CAL WORKS EXCEPTION PROVISIONS
SIMILARLY WITH THOSE USED FOR
CALIBRATION TO THE EXTENT
PERMITTED BY FEDERAL LAW.
OUR EX RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR
AYE VOTE ON THIS MEASURE THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU THAT WORK SEE NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE.
WORK WILL OPEN THE ROLE
[inaudible]
MEMBERS.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
OF THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
DESIRE TO VOTE [inaudible]
CLERK WILL.
CLOSE ROLE TALBOT EYES FIFTY NO.
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES.
FILE ITEMS TO ELEVEN TO TWELVE
PASS RETAIN PHONE TWO THIRTEEN
AB NINE SEVENTY CORKERY.
ASSEMBLY BILL NINE SEVENTY BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER SALAS AND
ACTUALLY TO AGING MR SALAS.
THANK WAS SPEAKER MEMBERS
ASSEMBLY BILL NINE SEVENTY WILL
HELP US GET OUR SENIORS IN ARE
DISABLED -- CONSTITUENTS TO
THEIR APPOINTMENTS RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
FAMOUS SHALL SEE NO DISCUSSION
DEBATE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE ALL MEMBER
SERVICE OUR TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS OF DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLICK WELL CLOSER ALL TIED UP
BUT I SIXTY ONE NO.
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES. FIVE
ELEVEN TO FOURTEEN IS AB NINE
SEVEN SIX BY MR CHOW
[inaudible]
CORPORATE.
ASSEMBLY BILL NINE SEVENTY SIX
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHAO AND
OTHERS AND ACTUALLY IN STATE
GOVERNMENT.
MR CHOW YOU MAY OPEN THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
EIGHTY NINE SEVEN SIX WOULD
ESTABLISH THE ARTIFICIAL
INTELLIGENCE OR A AYE IN STATE
GOVERNMENT SERVICES COMMISSION.
TO GATHER INPUT ON HOW A AYE AND
DATA SCIENCE COULD BE USED TO
IMPROVE STATE SERVICES.
A I HAS BEEN AN INCREDIBLE A
BILL HAS THE BILL INCREDIBLE
ABILITY TO CREATE A GLOBAL
PARADIGM SHIFT.
THAT MAY PROPEL SOCIETY INTO AN
AUTOMATION H. M. PROPOSE UNIQUE
SOLUTIONS TO SOME OF THE WORLD'S
GREATEST PROBLEMS.
ITS APPLICATION MAY SOON BECOME
IMMERSED IN EVERY MAJOR AREA OF
OUR WORK AND PERSONALIZED SUCH
AS TRANSPORTATION COMMUNICATIONS
FINANCE JUST TO NAME A FEW.
WELL THIS EMERGING TECHNOLOGY
PRESENTS OPPORTUNITIES IT ALSO
COMES WITH ITS OWN CHALLENGES
INCLUDING POTENTIALLY DISPLACING
WORKERS LOSS OF PRIVACY.
AMONG OTHER THINGS SO THESE
CHALLENGES WILL REQUIRE
INVOLVEMENT FROM ALL
STAKEHOLDERS TO ADDRESS AS A
RESULT WE MUST FACILITATE THAT
DIALOGUE TO FIND A BALANCE.
BETWEEN PROTECTING OUR STATE'S
POPULATION WHILE SIMULTANEOUSLY
DRIVING INNOVATION AND
PRODUCTIVITY AS A LEADER IN THE
GLOBAL MARKETPLACE WITHOUT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR ABOUT.
THANK YOU MISS CHELSEA NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLE.
WHERE IS OUR VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE?
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLICK WELL CLOSE ROLL TIDE BUT I
SIXTY SIX NO.
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES FILE
ITEMS. TO FIFTEEN TO SIXTEEN
PASS RETAIN FILE ITEM TO
SEVENTEEN AB TEN NINETEEN MISTER
FRAZIER CORPORATION.
AS A LEGAL TEN NINETEEN BY
SOMETHING MEMBER FRAZIER AND
ACTUALLY TO EMPLOYMENT.
MR FRAZIER.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
AB TEN NINETEEN CREATES AN
APPRENTICESHIP OPPORTUNITY FOR
CALIFORNIANS WITH DISABILITIES
BY ADDING THE DEPARTMENT OF REAL
ABILITY ATION AND THE STATE
COUNCIL AND DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES TO THE STATE'S.
INTER AGENCY ADVISORY -- THEIR
AGES HERE.
TONGUE TIED ADVISORY COMMITTEE
ON APPRENTICESHIP.
THIS BILL ENJOYS UNANIMOUS
SUPPORT IN A RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS FRAZIER SEE NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE ITEM
CLERK WILL OVER THE ROLE.
I MEMBERS VOTED TOSARAJEVO ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS OTHERS OUT OF A
CLERK WELL [inaudible]
CLOSER ROLE.
TALLY THE VOTE I SIXTY FOUR NO
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES FILE
ITEMS TO EIGHTEEN THROUGH.
TWO TWENTY PASS RETAIN FILE ITEM
TO TWENTY ONE IS AB TEN TWENTY
EIGHT COVERAGE.
AT SOME LEVEL TEN TWENTY EIGHT
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER GONZALEZ AND
OTHERS AND ACTUALLY TO ENERGY.
MISS GONZALES THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER THIS IS A GREAT BILL
THAT SIMPLY EXPANDS A CLEAN
ENERGY JOB CREATION PROGRAM
CALIFORNIA CAN TAKE STEPS TOWARD
MEETING OUR CLIMATE GOALS.
REDUCING ENERGY COSTS ARE SCHOOL
PROVIDE A PIPELINE FOR SKILLED
WORKERS WHAT'S NOT TO LIKE ABOUT
THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
NIGHT OF THANK YOU MS GONZALEZ.
SAYING NO DISCUSSION DEBATE ON
THE ITEM CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS OF THE DESIRE TO
VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSER ALL TELL ABOUT AYE SIXTY
TWO NO ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES
FILE OUT OF TWO TWENTY TWO THREE
TO TWENTY FIVE PASS RETAIN.
FILE ITEM.
TO TWENTY SIX FILE ITEM TO
TWENTY SIX IS AB TEN FIFTY EIGHT
CORPORATION.
ASSEMBLY WILL TEN FIFTY EIGHT BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER SALAS AND
ACTUALLY MEDI CAL MISTER CELIS.
THE RESTRICTOR MEMBERS AYE RICE
RISEN ASSEMBLY BILL TEN FIFTY
EIGHT WHICH WOULD ESTABLISH A
STAKEHOLDER PROCESS.
WITHIN THE DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH
CARE SERVICES TO IMPROVE AN
INTEGRATED TREATMENT FOR CO
OCCURRING.
SUBSTANCE USE DISORDERS A MENTAL
HEALTH ISSUES RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN IRA.
FAMOUS SALAS SAY NO DISCUSSION
DEBATE ON THE ITEM CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBER SERVICE OUR TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS OF THE SENATE OF THE
ALL MEMBERS HER DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLICK WELL CLOSE YOUR ROLL TIDE
ABOUT I SIXTY SIX NO ZERO THAT
MEASURE PASSES.
FILE ITEM TO TWENTY SEVEN IS AB.
TEN SIXTY ONE ASSEMBLY BILL TEN
SIXTY ONE BY SOMETHING MEMBER
GIPSON AND ACTUALLY TO FOSTER
CARE MISTER GIBSON.
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS I RISE TO
PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL TEN SIXTY
ONE WHICH WILL ENSURE FOSTER YOU.
HAVE A CONSISTENT AND STRONG
HOME FOUNDATION AND ARE NOT ON
EASILY REMOVED FROM PLACEMENT TO
PURSUE ANOTHER PLACEMENT.
LAST YEAR GOVERNOR BROWN SIGNED
IN -- MY BILL -- TWENTY TO FORTY
SEVEN WHICH ECSTATIC GUIDELINE
FOR FOSTER YOUTH PLACEMENT
TRANSITION BUT EXCLUDED YOUTH
WHO ARE INVOLVED WITH THE
JUSTICE SYSTEM.
ASSEMBLY BILL TEN SIXTY ONE
SIMPLY TAKES THE PROCESS AND
PROTECTIONS ECSTATIC IN --
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY TWO FORTY
SEVEN AND APPLY THEM TO
PROBATION SUPERVISION YOU THE TO
INSURE THEM. FOR THE BALL SO
YOU'D HAVE THE SAME BENEFITS AND
THE SAME TRANSITIONAL PROCESS
ASSEMBLY BILL TEN SIXTY ONE IS A
THOUGHTFUL BILL DEVELOP BY
FOSTER YOU.
SUPPORTED BY FOSTER YOUTH ENOUGH
IS ENOUGH WE ASK FOR A STRONG
VOTE ON ASSEMBLY BILL TEN SIXTY
ONE IS RECEIVED BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU MISS GIPSON
SEE NO DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE
ITEM CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
SARAH VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS OF MISERABLE
[inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
AS A ROLL TIDE OF VOTE I SIXTY
THREE NO ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES FILE I'M TO TWENTY EIGHT
IS AB TEN SIXTY SIX CORPORATE.
ASSEMBLY BILL TEN SIXTY SIX BY
SOMETHING MEMBER GONZALEZ AND
ACTUALLY TO UNEMPLOYMENT
COMPENSATION MAKING
APPROPRIATION THERE.
FOR IT'S GONZALEZ THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER.
MEMBERS I WANT TO TAKE A MOMENT
TO TALK ABOUT AN EMPLOYMENT
INSURANCE BECAUSE IT'S IMPORTANT
TO REMEMBER WHAT THIS IS ABOUT.
WE PROVIDE UNEMPLOYMENT
INSURANCE IT ITS HEYDAY WAS
DURING THE GREAT DEPRESSION
BECAUSE WE REALIZE WHEN PEOPLE
ARE OUT OF WORK ESPECIALLY WHEN
THERE'S A LARGE NUMBER OF PEOPLE
OUT OF WORK.
IT AFFECTS NOT ONLY THEIR
LIVELIHOOD BUT THE LIVELIHOOD OF
SMALL BUSINESSES IN A COMMUNITY
OF THEIR CHILDREN.
IT IT IT IT SHOULD IT ACTUALLY
CAN CAUSE -- WHEN A LOT OF
PEOPLE ARE UNEMPLOYED AND THEY
HAVE NO UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE
IT COULD CAUSE HOPE HOMELESSNESS
PEOPLE?
RUIN THEIR CREDIT AND YET IN
CALIFORNIA WE HAVE SOME RULES
AROUND UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE
WHEN IT COMES TO LABOR DISPUTES
THAT AREN'T ALWAYS CLEAR.
I WE SOMETIMES IF YOU'RE LOCKED
OUT AS AN EMPLOYEE YOU GET.
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE SOMETIMES
IN THE PAST YOU HAVEN'T.
STRIKING WORKERS HAVE NOT HAD
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE.
WHAT WE'RE DOING WITH THIS BILL
IS TRYING TO LEVEL THE PLAYING
FIELD INSANE IF YOU'RE LOCKED
OUT FROM YOUR EMPLOYER THAT YOU
CAN GET AN EMPLOYMENT INSURANCE
AFTER ONE WEEK?
IF YOU'RE ON STRIKE WITH YOUR
EMPLOYER YOU CAN FILE FOR
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE AFTER
FOUR WEEKS.
MEMBERS I'D ASK YOU TO THINK
WHAT IT BE LIKE TO BE ON STRIKE
FOR FOUR WEEKS THIS IS NOT
SOMETHING THAT WORKERS DO.
EASILY IT'S NOT SOMETHING THAT
THEY WANT TO DEAL IN THERE'S NO
INCENTIVE FOR A REDUCED PAYMENT
TO STAY OUT ON STRIKE OVER FOUR
WEEKS IT'S VERY RARE THAT WE
HAVE THESE KINDS OF STRIKES IN
CALIFORNIA.
BUT ONCE IN AWHILE WE DO.
AND WHEN WE DO MASS DEVASTATION
HAPPENS TO THOSE FAMILIES AND TO
THOSE COMMUNITIES.
THIS IS A VERY BAD I THINK
COMPROMISED BILL I WORKED HARD
WITH THE CHAIR OF INSURANCE TO
MAKE SURE THIS IS SOMETHING THAT
WE COULD PUT BRING FORWARD.
BUT THIS HELPS TO LEVEL THE
PLAYING FIELD AND IF YOUR
BIGGEST CONCERN IS THAT LARGE
CORPORATIONS DON'T HAVE ENOUGH
POWER AND LEVERAGE DURING LABOR
WORKERS.
HAVE TOO MUCH INCENTIVE.
IN A LABOR DISPUTE TO STAY ON
STRIKE THEN DON'T WORK.
FOR DON'T VOTE.
FOR IF YOU CARE ABOUT WORKERS
AND YOU THINK THAT MIDDLE CLASS
WORKERS AND LOW INCOME WORKERS
MIGHTNEED A LITTLE BIT OF
LEVELING I ASK YOU TO CONSIDER
THIS BILL TODAY.
THANK YOU MS GONZALEZ MR DAILY
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER I RISE IN SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL.
IT WILL HELP MAKE THE RIGHT TO
STRIKE A REALITY FOR LOWER
INCOME WORKERS BY EASING THE
FINANCIAL PAIN OF A LONG LABOR
DISPUTE.
VERY FEW WORKERS WILL EVER BE ON
STRIKE FOR MORE THAN FOUR WEEKS.
AND THEN BE ELIGIBLE TO RECEIVE
THE BENEFITS UNDER THIS BILL AS
I SAID VERY VERY FEW WORKERS.
WOULD EVER.
WANT TO BE ON STRIKE FOR MORE
THAN FOUR WEEKS.
BUT FOR THE WORKERS WHO FEEL
COMPELLED TO TAKE THE STEP OF
GOING ON STRIKE THE DIFFICULT
STEP.
THIS BENEFIT MAY WELL ALLOW THEM
TO LEAST FEED THEIR FAMILIES.
OR PAY THEIR BILLS.
I URGE AN AYE VOTE ON A. B..
TEN SIXTY SIX THANK YOU MISTER
DALY CITY NO ADDITIONAL
DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE ITEM
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS HER DESIRE TO VOTE
.
ALL MEMBERS
FOR CLICK WELL.
CLOSER.
OVER THE ROLE CLERK WILL CLOSE
THE ROLE.
TELL YOU VOTE ICE FORTY TWO
KNOWS.
THIRTEEN THAT MEASURE PASSES
[inaudible]
FILE ITEM. TWO TWENTY NINE IS AB
TEN EIGHTY FOR THE PURPOSE OF
AMENDMENTS CLERK WILL READ WITH
AMENDMENTS ASSEMBLY BILL TEN
EIGHTY WITH AMENDMENTS BY
SOMETHING MEMBER GONZALEZ.
IS GONZALEZ ON THE MINUTES.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER.
AB TEN EIGHTY WE WILL ENSURE
CALIFORNIA'S AT THE FOREFRONT OF
REDUCING POLLUTION FROM SINGLE
USE PACKAGING AND PRODUCT SPICED
APPLE ESTABLISHING COMPREHENSIVE
GOALS FOR THE SOURCE REDUCTION
RECYCLING OF THESE ITEMS IN THE
STATE.
SPECIFICALLY THOSE MADE OF
PLASTIC.
THESE AMENDMENTS WOULD NARROW
THE SCOPE OF THE REGULATORY
AUTHORITY GRANTED CAL RECYCLE TO
COVER ALL SINGLE USE PACKAGING
AND THE TOP TEN PROBLEMATIC
SINGLE USE PLASTIC PRODUCTS IN
THE STATE.
THIS TOP TEN LIST WOULD BE
DETERMINED BY CAL RECYCLE BASED
ON LITTER SURVEYS IN THE STATE
BETWEEN.
TWENTY SEVENTEEN TO TWENTY
TWENTY BY FOCUSING ON PACKAGING
AND THE TOP TEN SINGLE USE
PLASTIC ITEMS FOUND IN LATER WE
ENSURE THAT THE BILL FOCUSES ON
THE MATERIALS CAUSING THE MOST
PROBLEMS IN OUR WAY STREAMS FOR
LOCAL WASTE HAULERS AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS.
THE ITEMS CAUSING PROBLEMS FOR
OUR ENVIRONMENT AND HUMAN HEALTH
AS IT DEGRADES.
THE AMENDMENTS ALSO PUSH BACK
THE DATES FOR SINGLE USE PLASTIC
PACKAGING PRODUCTS TO MEET IN
TRUMP 20% 40% RECYCLING RATES BY
TWO YEARS.
THESE AMENDMENTS WILL ALSO
ENSURE THAT THE BILL'S MORE
FEASIBLE FOR CAL RECYCLE TO
IMPLEMENT.
AND FOR MANUFACTURERS AND
RETAILERS TO COMPLY WITH I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
ON THE AMENDMENTS.
THANK YOU MS GONZALEZ.
WITHOUT OBJECTION WE MAY TAKE A
VOICE VOTE ON THESE AMENDMENTS
ALL THOSE IN FAVOR SAY AYE.
AYE OPPOSED SAY NAY.
THE AYES HAVE IT THE MEMBERS ARE
ADOPTED THE BILLS UP TO PRINTER
BACK ON FILE.
FILE ITEMS TO THIRTY THROUGH.
TWO THIRTY FOUR PASS RETAIN THAT
BRINGS US TO FILE ITEM TO THIRTY
FIVE A. B. ELEVEN OH FOUR FOUR
COREY.
AS ONLY THE ELEVEN FOR BY FAMILY
MEMBER CALDERON AND ACT WHEN
INSURANCE.
MISTER CALDERON YOU MAY OPEN.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS AB ELEVEN OH FOUR WILL
ADD TO PUBLIC MEMBERS TO THE
BOARD OF THE CALIFORNIA LIFE AND
HEALTH INSURANCE GUARANTY
ASSOCIATION OTHERWISE KNOWN AS
KLAY GOT AND CREATE AN
ASSESSMENT TO FIND FINANCIAL
OVERSIGHT.
OF LONG TERM CARE INSURANCE
COMPANIES CURRENTLY CLICK AS
BOARD OF DIRECTORS IS ONLY MADE
UP OF INSURANCE INDUSTRY FOLKS
THERE ARE NO NON INSURANCE
INDUSTRY INTEREST THAT'S
REPRESENTED ON THE BOARD.
THIS BILL WILL ENSURE THAT THE
INTERESTS OF THE PUBLIC AT LARGE
NOT JUST THE INSURANCE INDUSTRY
ARE PART OF THE DELIBERATIONS
LIKELY GOT.
ADDITIONALLY AB ELEVEN OH FOUR
INCLUDES AN ASSESSMENT TO FUND
THE REPORT THAT LAST YEAR'S A.
B. TWO TWENTY THREE NINETY FIVE
MANDATED AB TWENTY THREE NINETY
FIVE REQUIRE THE DEPARTMENT OF
INSURANCE TO CONDUCT ADDITIONAL
FINANCIAL OVERSIGHT OF LONG TERM
CARE INSURERS.
THESE NEW FILING REQUIREMENTS
ARE DESIGNED TO ENACT TO ENABLE
THE DEAL I TO BETTER UNDERSTAND
THE FINANCIAL POSITION OF LONG
TERM CARE.
INSURERS AND HOPEFULLY ACT EARLY
ENOUGH TO HEAD OFF POTENTIAL
INSOLVENT SEES THIS ASSESSMENT
WAS NEGOTIATED OVER THE FALL
BETWEEN THE INDUSTRY AND THE
DEPARTMENT OF INSURANCE AND
ENJOYS SUPPORT.
FROM BOTH I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE ON THIS MEASURE.
THANK YOU MISTER CALDERON SAYING
NO DISCUSSION.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
RESERVE VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
KIRK WELL.
CLOSER ALTOGETHER BUT I SIXTY
FOUR NO ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES
FILE OUT OF TWO THIRTY SIX AND
TWO THIRTY SEVEN PASS RETAIN.
FILE ITEM TWO THIRTY EIGHT AB.
ELEVEN THIRTY SEVEN COVERAGE.
ASSEMBLY BILL ELEVEN THIRTY
SEVEN BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
NAZARIAN AND ACTUALLY TO AGING.
MISTER NAZARIAN.
EMAIL YOU MISTER SPEAKER I RISE
ON BEHALF OF AB ELEVEN THIRTY
SEVEN WHICH UPDATES THE OLDER
CALIFORNIANS ACT WHICH HAS NOT
BEEN UPDATED SINCE THE NINETEEN
NINETIES.
I ALSO IT ALSO REQUIRES THE
DEPARTMENT OF AGING TO PROVIDE
AREA AGENCIES ON AGING THE
FLEXIBILITY TO DEVELOP AND
MANAGE PROGRAMS BASED ON LOCAL
NEED WHICH INCLUDES PROVIDING
BLOCK GRANTING FOR FUNDS. FOR
THE ALZHEIMER'S DAYCARE RESOURCE
CENTER THE BROWN BACK PROGRAM
FOSTER CARE GRAND A GRANDPARENT
PROGRAM THE LINKAGES PROGRAM THE
RESPITE PROGRAM AND THE SENIOR
COMPANION PROGRAM.
UP WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AYE VOTE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER NAZARIAN SAYING.
NO MEMBERS SEEKING RECOGNITION.
CAR CLUB THE ROLE ALL MEMBERS
OTHERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS OF DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLICK WELL BECAUSE ROLL TIDE
ABOUT AYE.
SIXTY EIGHT KNOWS ZERO THAT
MEASURE PASSES.
FILE ITEMS TO THIRTY NINE
THROUGH TO FORTY TO PASS RETAIN
FILE ITEM.
TO FORTY THREE IS AB ELEVEN
EIGHTY CORPORATE.
ASSEMBLY BILL ELEVEN EIGHTY BY
SOMETHING MEMBER FRIEDMAN AND
ACTUALLY TO WATER.
THIS FRIEDMAN.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
I BRING TO YOU AB ELEVEN EIGHTY
A VERY WALKIE AND NOT FOR MOST
PEOPLE PARTICULARLY INTERESTING
BILL -- IN LESS YOU'RE A REAL
WATER GEEK LIKE MYSELF THIS BILL
AS THE STATE WATER BOARD TO
UPDATED REGULATIONS THAT HAVEN'T
BEEN UPDATED IN ABOUT TWENTY
YEARS SO THAT ALL OF THOSE.
REALLY GREAT POTABLE REUSE
SYSTEMS THE PEOPLE OF INSTALLED
INSIDE BUILDINGS WILL ACTUALLY
BE CODIFIED IN THE REGULATIONS
WILL BE UP TO DATE.
I WON'T BORE YOU WITH THE
DETAILS IT HAS A LOT TO DO WITH
DIFFERENT TYPES TYPES OF PIPES
VERY BODIES INTERESTED I CAN
GIVE YOU THE FULL LIST OF PIPES
THAT ARE IMPACTED BY THIS BILL.
I IT'S RECEIVED WIDE BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT AND I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST AN AYE VOTE.
SEEING NO WATER DIG SEEKING
RECOGNITION.
CLARK WELL OVER THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS OF DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS OF THE DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
DESIRE TO VOTE CLERK WELL.
CLOSER ALL.
TIED UP.
I SEVENTY NO.
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES FILE
ITEM TO FORTY FOURS AB ELEVEN
NINETY ONE COOKERY.
ASSEMBLY BILL ELEVEN NINETY ONE
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER BONTA AND
ACTUALLY TO THE GRANT A PUBLIC
TRUST LANDS TO THE CITY OF
OAKLAND.
MR BONTA.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES AB ELEVEN NINETY ONE
WILL SUPPORT THE DEVELOPMENT OF
THE HOWARD TERMINAL SITE IN
OAKLAND TO INCLUDE A PRIVATELY
FINANCED BASEBALL.
BALLPARK FOR THE OAKLAND
ATHLETICS A DEVELOPMENT THAT
WOULD ALSO BRING MUCH NEEDED
HOUSING INCLUDED AFFORDABLE
HOUSING ENVIRONMENTAL REAP
MEDIATION AND JOBS. TO WEST
OAKLAND THE PROJECT WILL CREATE
MORE THAN TWO THOUSAND JOBS THIS
WILL BE GOOD UNION JOBS WITH
FULL BENEFITS.
THE CITY AND PORT OF OAKLAND
ALONG WITH THE ETS THE SAN
FRANCISCO BAY CONSERVATION
DEVELOPMENT COMMISSION AND THE
STATE LANDS COMMISSION WILL
CONTINUE TO WORK COOPERATIVELY
ON THIS IMPORTANT BILL AS IT
MOVES FORWARD.
THIS PROJECT MEANS A GREAT DEAL
TO OAKLAND AND THE EAST BAY IT'S
NOT JUST ABOUT BASEBALL IT'S
ABOUT DELIVERING ECONOMIC AND
OTHER BENEFITS TO OUR
COMMUNITIES THAT NEED HELP.
AB ELEVEN NINETY ONE IS VITAL TO
KEEPING THE OAKLAND ATHLETICS
ROOTED IN OAKLAND IT'S RECEIVED
NO NO VOTES OUT OF TO POLICY
COMMITTEES AND THE FISCAL
COMMITTEE.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU WISH BONTA.
SEEING NO DISCUSSION DEBATE.
WORK WILL OPEN THE ROLE
[inaudible]
SARAH VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS OTHERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBER SERVICE ARE TO VOTE.
CLICK WELL CLOSE ROLE TELL THE
VOTE I FIFTY FIVE NO ZERO THAT
MEASURE PASSES
.
WITHOUT OBJECTION WE ARE GOING
TO MOVE TO FILE ITEM. TWO EIGHTY
THREE THIS IS AB. FOURTEEN FORTY
FOR THE PURPOSE OF AMENDMENTS.
CORKERY WITH AMENDMENTS AS SOME
PEOPLE FOURTEEN FORTY WITH
AMENDMENTS BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
LEVINE.
MR LEVINE ON THE MAMMOTHS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS ABOUT
AMENDMENTS ON EIGHTY FOURTEEN
FORTY HOPEFULLY BRINGING PEACE
AMONG THE STAKEHOLDERS AS
REQUIRE.
FIVE THE MISSION OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF OIL GAS AND
GEOTHERMAL RESOURCES THANK YOU
SO MUCH.
THANK YOU MISS LIVING.
WITHOUT OBJECTION WE MAY TAKE A
VOICE VOTE ON THESE AMENDMENTS
ALL THOSE IN FAVOR SAY AYE.
AYE OPPOSED SAY NAY.
THE AYES HAVE IT THE MEMBERS ARE
JOB DID.
BILLS OUT TO PRINT.
IN BACK ON FILE.
MEMBERS WE ARE WITHOUT OBJECTION
GOING TO MOVE TO TAKE OUT FILE
ITEM. THREE FIFTY TWO THREE
FIFTY TWO IS AB ONE FORTY TWO
FOR THE PURPOSE OF AMENDMENTS.
CLERK WILL READ WITH AMENDMENTS.
AS UNABLE ONE FORTY TWO WITH
AMENDMENTS BY SELLING MEMBER
CRISTINA GARCIA.
MISTER C. ON THE MINUTES THANK
YOU THE AMENDMENTS AT OVERSIGHT
BEFORE MONEY CAN BE SPENT ON
SITE CLEAN UP.
AND THEY ALSO REMOVED THE
INDUSTRY OPPOSITION I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS GARCIA WITHOUT
OBJECTION WE MAY TAKE A VOICE
VOTE ON THESE AMENDMENTS ALL
THOSE IN FAVOR SAY AYE.
AYE OPPOSED SAY NAY.
THE AYES HAVE IT THE AMENDMENTS
ARE ADOPTED THE BILLS UP TO
PRINT.
AND BACK ON FILE.
MEMBERS WE HAVE A CONSENT
CALENDAR WE ALSO HAVE ONE
REMAINING ITEM ON CALL I BELIEVE
[inaudible]
WE'RE NOT.
CORRECTION WE'VE LIVED AT ALL
THE CALLS.
MEMBERS WE ARE AT THE CONSENT
CALENDAR.
MEMBERS THERE IS A RESOLUTION ON
TODAY'S CONSENT CALENDAR.
BEFORE WE VOTE ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR WILL FIRST TAKE UP THE
RESOLUTION THAT IS ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. FOR THE
PURPOSE OF ADDING CO AUTHORS.
WITHOUT OBJECTION WE WILL TAKE
ONE ROLL CALL VOTE AND ALLOW ANY
MEMBER TO ADD ON AS A CO AUTHOR
TO THE RESOLUTION.
THE CLERK WILL READ THE
RESOLUTION ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR.
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
NINETY TWO BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
WALDRON IT RELATIVE TO MATERNAL
MENTAL HEALTH AWARENESS MONTH.
THE CLERK WILL NOW OPEN THE ROLE
TO ALLOW ANY MEMBER TO ADD ON AS
A CO AUTHOR TO THE RESOLUTION.
THIS IS CO AUTHORS TO THE
RESOLUTION.
THAT IS ON CONSENT.
IF YOU WISH TO ADD YOUR NAME IS
CO AUTHOR PLEASE [inaudible]
VOTE I CLARK WELL.
CLOSER ROLE THERE ARE SEVENTY
TWO CO AUTHORS ADDED TO THE
RESOLUTION IN QUESTION.
WE WILL NOW MOVE TO VOTE ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR ITSELF IS ANY
MEMBER WISH TO REMOVE AN ITEM
FROM THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE.
READ THE SECOND A CONSENT
CALENDAR.
I SOME PEOPLE TO A ONE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CERVANTES AND
OTHERS AND CTUALLY THE
POLITICAL REFORM ACT OF NINETEEN
SEVENTY FOUR AND THE CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLE.
THIS IS THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE
THIS IS THE CONSENT CALENDAR
[inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSE THE ROLE.
TALLY THE VOTE.
HI.
SIX SEVENTY ONE NO.
ZERO THE CONSENT CALENDAR IS
ADOPTED IN THE CLERK WILL READ
THE REMAINING ITEMS ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR.
ASSEMBLY BILL SEVEN SIXTY TWO TO
ONE HI SEVENTY NO ZERO SOME
PEOPLE EIGHT TWENTY FIVE FIVE
SEVENTY NO ZERO SOMETHING WILL
EIGHT SEVENTY TWO I SEVENTY NO
ZERO AS LEGAL NINE FORTY EIGHT
I. SEVENTY NO ZERO AS ONLY.
ONE NINE EIGHTY ONE I SEVENTY NO
ZERO SO YOU'LL TEN FIFTY FOUR I
SEVENTY KNOWS YOU'RE A SINGLE.
TEN EIGHTY NINE I SEVENTY KNOWS
HERE I SAW A LEVIN SIXTY I
SEVENTY NO ZERO AS SOME PEOPLE
CALL FORTY EIGHT I. SEVENTY NO
ZERO AS AN EVIL TWELVE FIFTY
SEVEN HI SEVENTY NO ZERO A
SIMILAR TWELVE SIXTY NINE WITH
URGENCY. FIVE SEVENTY KNOWS
YOU'RE ON THE URGENCY EYES
SEVENTY NO ZERO ON THE MEASURE.
A SUNNY Là FORTINO SIX I
SEVENTY NO ZERO ESSENTIAL FORTY
FIFTY SIX HI SEVENTY KNOWS ZERO
SOME REAL. FIFTEEN SIXTY FIVE
SEVENTY NO ZERO ESSENTIAL
SIXTEEN FORTY THREE I SEVENTY NO
ZERO ASSEMBLE SIXTEEN FORTY FOUR
I SEVENTY DOES ZERO A SINGLE
EIGHTY TWENTY THREE FIVE SEVENTY
NO ZERO AS A ONE EIGHTY TWENTY
FOUR I SEVENTY NO ZERO A SINGLE
EIGHTEEN THIRTY WITH URGENCY.
I SEVENTY KNOWS HERE ON THE
URGENCY I SEVENTY KNOWS YOU'RE
ON THE MEASURE AS ON THE
RESOLUTION EIGHTY EIGHT I
SEVENTY NO ZERO AS ANY CAR
RESOLUTION.
NINETY TWO HI SEVENTY NO ZERO
AND SENATE CONCURRENT RESOLUTION.
TWENTY FIVE I SEVENTY NO.
ZERO MEMBERS WE STILL HAVE
BUSINESS BEFORE THE HOUSE.
MEMBERS WHILE WE ARE AWAITING
DIRECTION.
I WOULD LIKE TO ACKNOWLEDGE ON
BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER MARC
LEVINE.
THE ASSEMBLY WELCOMES VISITORS
FROM THE SANTA ROSA METRO
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE AS WELL AS
ADDITIONAL NORTH BAY CHAMBERS OF
COMMERCE WHO HAVE.
JOINED US IN THE GALLERY PLEASE
WELCOME THEM TO THE ASSEMBLY.
AND I'VE BEEN TOLD THAT IT'S
MISTER BRIAN MAIN CHAINS
BIRTHDAY TODAY HAPPY BIRTHDAY
SIR
.
MEMBERS WE MAY ENTERTAIN VOTE
CHANGES AT THIS TIME.
MS BAUER K. HAND YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
AB TWO THIRTY FIVE FROM I TO NOT
VOTING.
VOTE CHANGE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BARRICADE HAN AS A LABEL TO
THIRTY FIVE I TO NOT VOTING
[inaudible]
YEAH.
MR MEDINA YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
VOTE CHANGE FILE ITEM ONE NINETY
FOUR AB EIGHT TWO SIX NOTE TO I
THE CHANGE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MEDINA ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHT
TWENTY SIX NO TO A HIGH.
MR BLOW.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AB ONE
ONE ONE TWO I DO NOT VOTING.
THE CHANGE ASSEMBLY MEMBER BLOOM.
ASSEMBLY WILL.
ELEVEN TWELVE I TO NOT VOTING
[inaudible]
MISS WALDRON.
FILE ITEM TWO OH SIX AB NINE
SEVENTEEN HI TO NOT PHONING.
VOTE CHANGE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WALDRON AS ONLY ONE NINE
[inaudible]
THE DOCTOR CHEN.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER.
AB SEVENTY FOUR FILE ITEM.
FIVE NO TO NOT VOTING.
VOTE CHANGE ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHEN
ASSEMBLY BILL SEVENTY FOUR NO TO
NOT VOTING [inaudible]
MR GALLAGHER.
ASSEMBLY BILL.
SIX FORTY TWO I TO NOT VOTING.
THE CHANGE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GALLAGHER SOME ABLE SIX FORTY
TWO I TO NOT VOTING.
AND MISTER CUNNINGHAM.
THANK YOU VOTE CHANGE FILE ITEM
ONE EIGHTEEN AB THREE FORTY TWO
NO TWO I VOTE CHANGE A SINGLE
[inaudible]
THREE FORTY TWO NO T<c.cyan>.</c>
OKAY MEMBERS WE HAVE AN ITEM.
THAT WE ARE GOING TO BE TAKING
UP.
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO TAKE A
FIVE ITEM.
TO NINETY FOUR A. B.. FIFTEEN OH
FIVE BY MISTER O'DONNELL.
CLOCK RATE.
ASSEMBLY BILL FIFTEEN OH FIVE BY
SOME THE MEMBER O'DONNELL AND
OTHERS AND ACTUALLY CHARTER
SCHOOLS.
MR O'DONNELL THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER THE BILL BEFORE YOU
TODAY SEEKS TO REFORM THE
CHARTER SCHOOL AUTHORIZATION.
APPEALS.
IN RENEWAL PROCESSES.
NOW I SHOULD NOTE IF YOU WANT TO
CLOSE EXISTING CHARTER SCHOOLS
THIS BILL IS NOT FOR YOU.
IF YOU WANT TO REVISIT THE
AUTHORIZATION AND RENEWAL
PROCESS FOR CHARTER SCHOOLS THIS
BILL IS FOR YOU.
BUT AGAIN THIS BILL IN OF ITSELF
WILL NOT CLOSE ANY CHARTER
SCHOOL IN CALIFORNIA.
AND I WANT TO MAKE IT CLEAR THAT
I HAVE COMMITTED TO TAKING
AMENDMENTS IN THE SENATE TO
FURTHER REFINE THE CHARTER
APPEAL PROCESS AGAIN THIS BILL
WILL BE AMENDED.
I HAVE ALSO COMMITTED TO TAKING
A MEMBERS TO CLARIFY THAT
CHARTER SCHOOLS ON TRIBAL LAND
WILL BE ELIGIBLE FOR AN APPEAL
BECAUSE THEY HAVE.
UNIQUE SITUATIONS.
THERE ARE WEAKNESSES IN CURRENT
LAW WHICH ARE HURTING OUR
STUDENTS AND WE NEED TO TAKE
ACTION.
IT IS THE DUTY OF THIS
LEGISLATURE TO TAKE ACTION.
CURRENT LAW ALLOWS THOSE SEEKING
TO OPEN A CHARTER SCHOOL TO GO
AUTHORIZES.
SIMPLY PUT THIS MEANS THAT AFTER
BEING REJECTED BY ONE BOARD.
THEY CAN GO SEARCHING FOR
ANOTHER BOARD FOR FOR APPROVAL
OFTEN FAR FROM HOME.
THIS CAN RESULT IN OVERSIGHT BY
A BODY THAT IS HUNDREDS OF MILES
AWAY.
A LACK OF LOCAL OVERSIGHT CAN
LEAD TO POOR FISCAL MANAGEMENT
AND CERTAINLY.
POOR STUDENT OUTCOMES.
THIS BILL SEEKS TO ALLOW SCHOOL
DISTRICTS TO CONSIDER FISCAL
ACADEMIC OR FACILITY IMPACT THAT
A NEW CHARTER SCHOOL MAY HAVE.
ON A NEIGHBORHOOD PUBLIC SCHOOL
THAT'S A NEW CHARTER SCHOOL
THAT'S NOT A RE AUTHORIZED
CHARTER SCHOOL THAT'S NOT WHEN
IT'S EVEN EXISTENCE TODAY.
DISTRICTS WILL NOT BE ABLE TO
CONSIDER FISCAL IMPACT FOR
EXISTING CHARTER SCHOOLS THAT
WILL NOT.
BE PART OF THE RE AUTHORIZATION
PRESENT PROCESS.
ONCE THE CHARTER COMES BACK FOR
RENEWAL AUTHORIZES WILL CONSIDER
THE FINANCIAL STABILITY OF THE
CHARTER SCHOOL ITSELF.
THIS WILL ALLOW THE AUTHORIZED
OR TO IDENTIFY AND RESPOND TO A
PROBLEM BEFORE IT BECOMES AN
EMERGENCY. FOR EXAMPLE ONE
SCHOOL WAS DENIED BY BOTH THE
DISTRICT AND THE COUNTY AND WAS
APPROVED BY THE STATE.
BUT CLOSED DUE TO FISCAL
MANAGEMENT.
PARENTS WERE NOTIFIED THAT THE
SCHOOL WAS CLOSING IN THE MIDDLE
OF THE SCHOOL YEAR.
THIS SCHOOL CLOSURE LESS
STUDENTS STRANDED AND UNDER THIS
BILL THIS COULD HAVE BEEN
AVOIDED.
THERE WOULD HAVE BEEN WARNINGS.
ADDITIONALLY THIS BILL REQUIRES
ALL TEACHERS IN CHARTER SCHOOLS
TO HOLD REQUIRED CREDENTIAL. FOR
THEIR TEACHING ASSIGNMENT.
FINALLY THE BILL ALLOWS CHARTER
STREE SO TO RECEIVE HELP WHEN
THEY'E STRUGGLING ACADEMICALLY.
AND ONCE AGAIN THIS BILL WILL
NOT CLOSE CHARTER SCHOOLS.
AND I SHOULD NOTE THAT WHEN THE
SUPERINTENDENT OF PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION STATS WORK IS
COMPLETE WE WILL CONTINUE THE
ROBUST DISCUSSION WITH ALL
PARTIES.
AND I WANT TO STRESS ALL PARTIES
ALL STAKEHOLDERS.
THE S. P. I. AS URGE THE
LEGISLATURE TO MOVE FORWARD DO
NOT WAIT FOR HIS TASK FORCE BUT
CERTAINLY WE WILL CONTEMPLATE
THEIR RECOMMENDATIONS AS WE
SHOULD.
CHARTER SCHOOLS ARE PUBLIC
SCHOOLS AND MUST BE HELD
ACCOUNTABLE TO PROTECT ALL
STUDENTS I ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK.
THANK YOU MISTER O'DONNELL
MISTER MERCH SUSHI YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
YOU KNOW I'M I'M REALLY TORN
WITH THIS BILL BECAUSE I'VE
ALWAYS BEEN A BIG SUPPORTER OF
OUR TRADITIONAL PUBLIC SCHOOLS
[inaudible]
AND I I AM VERY CONCERNED ABOUT
HOW THE CHARTER SCHOOLS ARE
[inaudible]
CREATING FINANCIAL FISCAL
CHALLENGES FOR DISTRICTS.
MANY OF OUR LARGE URBAN
DISTRICTS.
I ALSO WANT TO MAKE SURE I I I I
WANT TO SUPPORT ANY MEASURE THAT.
WILL CRACK DOWN ON BAD CHARTER
SCHOOLS BECAUSE WE KNOW THAT
THERE ARE TOO MANY BAD CHARTER
SCHOOLS OUT THERE.
AND THAT WE SHOULD SHUT THEM
DOWN [inaudible]
MY CONCERN.
IS THAT THIS BILL MAY RISK
SHUTTING DOWN [inaudible]
GOOD.
EXISTING CHARTER SCHOOLS AND I
ALTHOUGH.
THE AUTHOR [inaudible]
STATED THAT.
THIS WILL NOT.
YOU KNOW I WENT OVER A SPECIFIC
PROVISION AND THE BILL.
SECTION FOUR SEVEN SIX OH FIVE
SUBDIVISIONS J. [inaudible]
THAT LIMITS.
THE APPEAL PROCESS [inaudible]
FOR ANY ADVERSE DECISION BY THE
GOVERNING AUTHORITY TO THE
COUNTY BOARD OF EDUCATION TO BE
LIMITED ONLY TO PROCEDURAL
VIOLATIONS.
SO IN OTHER WORDS.
IF A GOOD CHARTER SCHOOL.
IS PERFORMING WELL ACADEMICALLY
IS IS IS PRODUCING BE.
ACADEMIC RESULTS AND YET.
IS SHUT DOWN.
FOR POLITICAL OR OTHER REASONS
THAT MAY BE ON SPECIFIED.
THEY WOULD HAVE NO RIGHT TO AN
APPEAL.
IF IT WAS NOT FOR ANYTHING OTHER
THAN A PROCEDURAL VIOLATION
THAT'S THE FIGHT IN THE BILL
[inaudible]
SO.
I HAVE A QUESTION TO THE AUTHOR
[inaudible]
WITHOUT OBJECTION.
WELL THE AUTHOR COMMIT
[inaudible] TO AN AMENDMENT.
THAT WILL ENSURE THAT GOOD
CHARTER SCHOOLS THAT ARE
PRODUCING.
GOOD ACADEMIC OUTCOMES.
WE'LL HAVE A RIGHT TO APPEAL TO
THE COUNTY BOARD OF EDUCATION.
MR O'DONNELL.
I THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR -- WELL
WHAT I'VE ALREADY SAID IS THIS
BILL IS HALF DONE BECAUSE WE
NEED TO HAVE A LOT OF
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE WITH A
VARIETY OF DIFFERENT
STAKEHOLDERS WE HAVE THE S. P.
EYES COMMITTEE COMMISSION OUT
THEIR TASK FORCE I GUESS IS WHAT
THEY CALL IT.
AND I AM ABSOLUTELY COMMITTED TO
MAKING SURE THAT WE HAVE A REAL
AUTHORIZATION PROCESS BECAUSE
THAT'S REALLY WHAT YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT.
THAT WORKS FOR EVERYBODY.
THAT WORKS FOR EVERYONE RIGHT
TUNING IN AGAIN -- IT AND I
COULD JUST MISTER SPEAKER AND
THAT NEEDS TO BE FURTHER
CLARIFIED I UNDERSTAND THAT AND
I UNDERSTAND THAT IS A POINT OF
CONTENTION FOR MANY.
AND I AM COMMITTING TO HAVING
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT THAT AND
AMENDING THE BILL FURTHER.
MISTER SPEAKER MISTER MURATSUCHI
IF I MAY I FIND THAT RESPONSE
INSUFFICIENT.
YOU KNOW THIS IS.
I I I I'VE SPOKEN WITH THE
AUTHOR ON THIS THIS IS OUR
OPPORTUNITY TO ADDRESS A YOU
KNOW.
OBVIOUSLY VERY COMPLICATED AND
VERY CONTROVERSIAL ISSUE.
AND ON TOP OF THAT WE KNOW THAT
THERE IS A TASK FORCE THAT IS.
PREPARING TO ISSUE THE
RECOMMENDATIONS.
IF THE AUTHOR IS WILLING TO
COMMIT TODAY RIGHT NOW THAT HE
WILL.
AMEND THE BILL TO INSURE THAT
GOOD CHARTER SCHOOLS PRODUCING
GOOD ACADEMIC.
RESULTS WILL NOT BE SHUT DOWN
THEN I WILL BE WILLING TO
SUPPORT THIS BILL ANYTHING SHORT
OF THAT I WILL NOT BE ABLE
SUPPORT THE BILL TODAY.
THANK YOU MISTER MURATSUCHI.
MR BONTA YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES I RISE IN SUPPORT OF
AB FIFTEEN OH FIVE AS A PROUD.
JOINT AUTHOR OF THE MEASURE.
THE CHARTER SCHOOLS ACT HAS
LARGELY BEEN UNTOUCHED SINCE IT
WAS ENACTED IN NINETEEN NINETY
TWO AND IT'S HARD TO IMAGINE.
THAT WE NAILED IT NEARLY THIRTY
YEARS AGO THAT WE GOT IT EXACTLY
RIGHT IT IS CERTAINLY
APPROPRIATE. TO REVIEW.
MODERNIZE AND IMPROVE THE LAW TO
LOOK AT OUR EXPERIENCE OVER THE
LAST COUPLE OF DECADES PLUS
IDENTIFY UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES.
AND ADJUST ACCORDINGLY THIS BILL.
IS IMPORTANT BECAUSE IT SEEKS TO
STRENGTHEN LOCAL CONTROL LOCAL
SCHOOL BOARDS ARE DEMOCRATICALLY
ELECTED BY AND ARE ACCOUNTABLE.
TO LOCAL COMMUNITIES THEY ARE
ENTRUSTED TO MAKE FINAL
DECISIONS ABOUT THE EDUCATION OF
THE STUDENTS LIVING WITHIN THE
DISTRICT BOUNDARIES AND TO DO
WHAT IS BEST. FOR STUDENTS
PARENTS TEACHERS OTHER SCHOOL
EMPLOYEES AND COMMUNITIES AS A
WHOLE THIS BILL IS NOT ABOUT
CLOSING CHARTER SCHOOLS IT'S
ABOUT ENSURING THAT WE'RE
PROVIDING A QUALITY EDUCATION.
TO OUR STUDENTS AND DOING WHAT'S
BEST FOR THE DISTRICT AND THE
COMMUNITY AS A WHOLE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK THE AYE VOTE ON
AB.
FIFTY TO FIVE THANK RESPOND TO
MR PATERSON NEW YORK MEMBERS A
SPEAKER THANK GOD RISE -- YEAH
Là RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION HERE --
THE UNIVERSITY HIGH SCHOOL
CHARTER SCHOOL IN FRESNO
CHARTERED BY FRESNO UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT.
IS AN ABSOLUTELY AWARD WINNING
CHARTER SCHOOL.
AND YET BECAUSE OF THE POLITICAL
IN WORKINGS.
OF THE FRESNO UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT BOARD AND A RECENT
ELECTION.
THE FRESNO UNIFIED SCHOOL BOARD.
A FEW MEMBERS ATTEMPTED.
AND WE'RE GAINING SOME TRACTION.
TO SIMPLY DE CHARTER.
PROBABLY ONE OF THE BEST A
CHARTER SCHOOLS IN UNITED STATES.
IT WAS BECAUSE THE FRESNO COUNTY
OFFICE OF EDUCATION.
STEPPED UP AND SAID CLEARLY.
IF YOU DE CHARTER THIS SCHOOL WE
WILL IMMEDIATELY.
REACH CHARTER IT.
AND SO I'D LIKE.
TO SUGGESTED THAT THERE ARE
LEGITIMATE REALLY GOOD REASONS
FOR PROTECTING [inaudible]
QUALITY PERFORMING [inaudible]
CHARTER SCHOOLS.
FROM MISGUIDED POLITICAL
INTERVENTION.
AND IT WAS THE ABILITY OF THE
FRESNO COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION.
AND IF YOU KNOW FRESNO COUNTY IT
IS A BIG.
GEOGRAPHIC PLACE LOTS OF MILES.
AND IT WAS BECAUSE THERE WAS
[inaudible]
AN ABILITY.
I TO RE.
TO TO PUSH BACK ON WHAT AMOUNTED
TO A A MISGUIDED EFFORT TO UNDO
A REALLY QUALITY -- AT A
PRACTICE ON THE CAMPUS OF FRESNO
STATE UNIVERSITY IT'S RENOWNED
IN AND AWARD WINNING.
SO I THINK THAT WHEN WE START TO
MOVE IN THE DIRECTION OF
SUGGESTING THAT.
ONLY OF A FRESNO UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT.
OR ONLY SOME OTHER SCHOOL
DISTRICT IS DEMOCRATICALLY
ELECTED AND THEREFORE -- WE
OUGHT TO JUST.
ESSENTIALLY HANDS OFF AND LET
THEM DECIDE WHAT THEY WANT TO DO
WHAT I REALLY THINK IS IMPORTANT
IS AND WHY I'M GOING TO BE A
RESPECTFUL NO HERE.
IS THAT THERE REALLY I THINK
MUST BE.
A REALLY SAFE HARBOR. FOR
QUALITY CHARTER SCHOOLS.
THAT FIGHTING THE THE WINDS OF
SOME POLITICAL.
POINT OF VIEW OUR BIAS.
HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO GO TO
FRESNO.
COUNTY OFFICE OF THAT YOU AND
IT'S AND IT'S BEEN MORE THAN
JUST ONCE WHERE FRESNO COUNTY OF
OFFICE EDUCATION HAS STEPPED IN
[inaudible]
AND SAID. TO FRESNO UNIFIED YOU
WILL NOT THE CHARTER DECERTIFY
OR WE WILL STEP IN.
AND CERTIFY SO I THINK THERE'S A
REAL GOOD BALANCE GOING ON AT
LEAST IN THE AREA THAT I
REPRESENT AND I FEAR THAT THIS.
BILL REALLY WENT ON DO THAT
OPTION.
SO I'M GONNA BE A RESPECTFUL --
NO HERE OF HOPE OTHER MEMBERS
WOULD THINK SERIOUSLY AND ALSO
OPPOSE.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISS PATTERSON
[inaudible]
MS CARILLO [inaudible]
MISS KOREA [inaudible]
MR OF DONALD -- IF YOU DRESS ANY
QUESTIONS IN YOUR CLOTHES MS
CARILLO.
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MISTER
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I WASN'T
SURE IF I WAS GOING TO SPEAK ON
THIS BILL TODAY.
MY DISTRICT ASSEMBLY DISTRICT
FIFTY ONE IS HOME TO THE HIGHEST
DENSITY CHARTER DISTRICT IN THE
STATE.
THIS IS WHAT I'VE INHERITED AS A
NEW MEMBER OF THIS LEGISLATURE.
AND SINCE I'VE BEEN HERE WE HAVE
VOTED ON SEVERAL BILLS.
THAT HOLD CHARTERS ACCOUNTABLE.
I BELIEVE IN LOCAL CONTROL.
I BELIEVE IN OUR TEACHERS.
BUT I ALSO KNOW FIRST HAND WHAT
IT'S LIKE TO GO TO PUBLIC
SCHOOLS IN MY DISTRICT.
I KNOW WHAT IT'S LIKE TO BE IN A
GOOD CLASSROOM.
MAGNET PROGRAM.
I ALSO KNOW WHAT IT'S LIKE TO BE
KICKED OUT OF THAT MAGNET
PROGRAM.
PUT INTO AN HONORS PROGRAM GET
KICKED OUT OF THAT.
AND THEN FINALLY GET PLACED INTO
A REGULAR CLASSROOM.
I KNOW WHAT IT'S LIKE TO BE
KICKED OUT OF SCHOOL.
I KNOW WHAT IT'S LIKE TO BE RE
ENROLLED.
I KNOW WHAT IT'S LIKE TO HAVE A
TEACHER.
THE LOOKED OUT FOR ME THE
PRINCIPLE THAT LOOKED OUT FOR ME.
THAT MADE SURE THAT I GRADUATED.
I WENT TO ROOSEVELT HIGH SCHOOL
IN BOYLE HEIGHTS WHICH HAD AT
THE TIME IN THE NINETIES. THREE
TRACKS AB AND C.. FIVE THOUSAND
STUDENTS OVERCROWDED.
HALF OF MY CLASS MORE THAN HALF
OF MY CLASS DROPPED OUT I WAS
ONE OF THEM.
BUT I WAS FORTUNATE TO HAVE BEEN
ABLE TO GRADUATE ON TIME.
I THINK ABOUT THOSE CLASSMATES.
WHAT HAPPENED TO THEM WHY WERE
THEY FORGOTTEN?
IN ITS BECAUSE WE HAD A SYSTEM
OF EDUCATION.
THAT WASN'T LOOKING OUT FOR THEM.
IN NINETEEN SIXTY EIGHT WHICH
I'VE SPOKEN ON THIS FLOOR ABOUT
BEFORE SOMETHING INCREDIBLE
HAPPENED IN MY DISTRICT.
THE CHICANO STUDENT WALKOUTS
WHICH THIS BODY RECOGNIZED FOR
THE FIRST TIME [inaudible]
LAST YEAR.
IN THIS STUDENT PROTEST.
WAS ABOUT THREE THINGS.
THAT WERE THE MOST PRIORITY.
LACK OF RESOURCES OVERCROWDED
CLASSROOMS.
AND RUN DOWN FACILITIES THAT WAS
NINETEEN SIXTY EIGHT BATHROOMS
WERE LOCKED IN STUDENTS HAD TO
RELIEVE THEMSELVES IN BUSH'S.
THERE WAS NO DIGNITY TO BEING A
STUDENT ON THE EAST SIDE.
LINCOLN WILSON FRANKLIN GARFIELD
ALL IN MY DISTRICT ROOSEVELT.
WHICH IS WHERE I WENT TO SCHOOL.
ALL PRO TESTED IN.
NINETEEN SIXTY EIGHT WHAT HAS
CHANGED SINCE [inaudible]
ABSOLUTELY NOTHING.
WE HAVE DE FUNDED OUR PUBLIC
SCHOOLS.
WE HAVE PRIORITIZED
INCARCERATION.
THERE WASN'T A NEW HIGH SCHOOL
BUILT IN MY COMMUNITY.
UNTIL THE LATE NINETEEN NINETIES
EARLY TWO THOUSANDS.
SO FOR DECADES.
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA FAILED.
STUDENTS LIKE ME.
IN MY COMMUNITY.
I CANNOT.
IN GOOD CONSCIOUS.
IN BEING A RESPONSIBLE MEMBER OF
THIS BODY.
CONTINUED TO POLITICIZE
[inaudible]
EDUCATION. FOR KIDS LIKE ME
ACROSS THE STATE.
IT.
HURTS MY HEART.
THERE WE PICKED PARENTS AGAINST
EACH OTHER I HAVE PARENTS IN MY
DISTRICT.
THAT SEND THEIR KIDS TO
TRADITIONAL SCHOOLS.
CHARTER SCHOOLS AND PAROCHIAL
SCHOOLS CHOICE HAS ALWAYS BEEN.
AN A THING THAT PEOPLE CAN HAVE
IF THEY COULD AFFORD IT.
MY PARENTS WANTED TO SEND MY
SISTERS AND I TO A PAROCHIAL
SCHOOL BECAUSE THEY KNEW.
OUR TRADITIONAL SCHOOLS IN OUR
COMMUNITY FOR FAILING KIDS THEY
JUST COULDN'T AFFORD IT.
AND I WAS LUCKY THAT I HAD A MOM
THAT FIGURED OUT HOW TO WORK THE
MAGNET PROGRAM.
AND SHE FIGURED IT OUT FOR ME IN
MY YOUNGER SISTERS.
THAT'S NOT THE CASE FOR EVERYONE.
AND IT'S CERTAINLY NOT THE CASE.
FOR NEW IMMIGRANT AMERICANS WHO
ARE LEARNING THE SYSTEM FOR THE
FIRST TIME.
AND I'M TRYING TO UNDERSTAND.
WHY WE CONTINUE TO POLITICIZE
EDUCATION WHEN THE ISSUE REALLY
IS ABOUT FUNDING?
THE REAL ISSUE IS A WHY HAVE WE
NOT PRIORITIZE.
PUBLIC EDUCATION IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA IS IT BECAUSE KIDS
LOOK MORE LIKE ME.
BECAUSE THERE IMMIGRANT ENGLISH
LANGUAGE LEARNERS BLACK OR BROWN
KIDS ACROSS THE STATE.
I LOOK AT THE NUMBERS.
AND THE NUMBERS DO NOT LIE.
AND I WANT TO GET US TO A PLACE.
WHAT WE THOUGHT HAVING THIS
POLITICAL FIGHT THIRTY SECOND
AND HAVE THE FIGHT THAT WE NEED
TO HAVE WHICH IS ABOUT FUNDING
OUR PUBLIC SCHOOLS?
I CANNOT IN GOOD CONSCIOUS.
SUPPORT ANY ADDITIONAL PIECE OF
LEGISLATION.
THE PITS PARENTS AGAINST EACH
OTHER.
IN KIDS AGAINST A SYSTEM.
THAT HAS FOR DECADES
[inaudible]
NOT SERVICE [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU IS CARILLO.
THERE'S NO APPLAUSE DURING
DEBATE MEMBERS MISTER SMITH.
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER.
COLLEAGUES I RISE TODAY AS
SOMEONE WHO HAS SPENT MY ENTIRE
CAREER.
IN THE EFFORTS TO SUPPORT.
AND IMPROVE PUBLIC EDUCATION
MUCH TO MY COLLEAGUE FROM LOS
ANGELES CONCERNS.
I HAVE HEARD THE CONCERNS OF
EVERYONE IN THIS BODY WHOSE
COMMUNITY CONTAINS FAMILIES WHO
WANT A BETTER OPTION.
WHO WANT CHOICE WHO WANT TO BE
AWAY FROM WHAT THEY PERCEIVE AND
SOMETIMES RIGHTFULLY SO? TO BE A
FAILING.
LOOK SCHOOL SYSTEM.
IT IS UNAVOIDABLE IN THIS MOMENT.
THAT WE ARE POLITICIZING.
THIS ISSUE.
BECAUSE WE ARE AT A POINT WHERE
WE HAVE TO MAKE CRITICAL
DECISIONS.
GIVEN THE FACT THAT WE DON'T
HAVE A NEW FUNDING STREAM TO
INCREASE OUR LOCAL CONTROL BASS
GRANT NOR THE SUPPLEMENTAL
GRANTS.
THAT SPECIAL EDUCATION
INCREASINGLY CHALLENGES EVERY
SCHOOL DISTRICT IN THE STATE TO
DO MORE WITH LESS AND VERY OFTEN
CHARTERS ARE NOT SERVING THOSE
STUDENTS WITH SPECIAL NEEDS. TO
THE POINT WE ARE NOW.
WHERE IF WE DON'T MAKE THESE
CRITICAL DECISIONS IF WE DO NOT
ALLOW LOCALLY ELECTED SCHOOL
BOARDS? TO MAKE THESE DECISIONS
AND WE SAY WE KNOW BETTER HERE
IN SACRAMENTO.
THEN WE ALSO DO NEED TO BE
WILLING TO STEP WHAT UP WITH THE
FUNDING. TO IMPROVE EVERY SINGLE
PUBLIC SCHOOL.
BUT WHAT THIS MEASURE SPEAKS TO
RIGHT NOW IS ALLOWING US TO TAKE
A PAUSE. TO HAVE A VEHICLE TO
SEND OVER TO THE SENATE WHILE WE
WAIT FOR THE RECOMMENDATIONS
FROM A TASK FORCE. TO SET US ON
A COURSE ON HOW WE MERGE BOTH OF
THESE WORLDS.
BECAUSE I COME FROM A TIME WHEN
I WORKED AT THE US DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION WHERE I SPENT MY
WEEKENDS SERVING INTERCITY
SCHOOLS TRYING TO MAKE IT JUST.
BUILDING IMPROVEMENTS PAINTING
REINSTALLING BATHROOM DOORS AND
AT THE TIME THE CHARTER SCHOOL
MOVEMENT WAS IN ITS INFANCY AND
I WOULD HAVE DONE ANYTHING.
STOP AT NOTHING FOR THOSE KIDS
TO BE LED BY INNOVATIVE TEACHERS
AND ADMINISTRATORS IN WHAT WAS
THE BEGINNING OF A CHARTER
MOVEMENT.
IT SHOWED PROMISE AND IN MANY
CASES AND IN MANY OF YOUR
COMMUNITIES YES IN FACT IT HAS
DELIVERED THAT PROMISE.
BUT WHERE WE COMPLETELY DROPPED
THE BALL IS IN ENSURING THAT
WHAT WAS SUPPOSED TO BE A
CHARTER SCHOOL MOVEMENT.
AIMED AT INFORMING A FEEDBACK
LOOP OF IMPROVING SCHOOLS FOR
ALL KIDS HAS NOW BECOME ABOUT
POLITICS AND SILOS WE HAVE A
UNIQUE MOMENT HERE TO TAKE THAT
NEXT STEP.
IN GETTING US IN THAT DIRECTION
I IS ONE OF THE CO AUTHORS WILL
TELL YOU THAT I AM COMMITTED. TO
MOVING THIS VEHICLE ALONG TO
CONTINUE TO HAVE THAT
CONVERSATION TO HONOR AND
RECOGNIZE THE WORK THAT IS BEING
DONE EVERY DAY RIGHT NOW IN
GREAT CHARTERS I HAVE SOME IN MY
COMMUNITY.
I HAVE GRANADA HILLS CHARTER
HIGH SCHOOL ACADEMIC DECATHLON
TOP PERFORMER EVERY YEAR
NATIONALLY.
SCV AYE INTERNATIONAL DOES
FANTASTIC AN INNOVATIVE THINGS
WITH THEIR STUDENTS WE HAVE TO
HONOR THAT.
BUT WE ALSO HAVE TO TAKE THE
KNOWLEDGE BASE OUT OF THOSE
CLASSROOMS.
AND GET SERIOUS ABOUT FUNDING
THE REST OF PUBLIC EDUCATION SO
THAT NO FAMILY HOUSE TO MAKE A
CHOICE.
THAT'S THE POINT WE'RE AT
COLLEAGUES.
FAMILIES SHOULDN'T HAVE TO MAKE
A CHOICE SO LET US GET THERE LET
US CONTINUE TO REFINE THIS
PROCESS TO HAVE THESE
CONVERSATIONS AND TO MAKE SURE
THAT EVERY PUBLIC SCHOOL.
IS A GOOD PUBLIC SCHOOL THIS
MEASURE HELPS US GET THERE
[inaudible]
DOCTOR WEBER [inaudible]
YOUR RECOGNIZED.
MISTER SPEAKER IN MEMBERS I RISE --
IN OPPOSITION.
TO FIFTEEN OH FIVE I THINK MOST
OF YOU KNOW THAT -- SO IS NO
NEWS TO ANYONE I DID NOT GO FOR
THIS BILL.
AND I WAS GREATLY CONCERNED EVEN
IN THE COMMITTEE THAT WHEN THE
BILL CAME FORWARD IT ALREADY HAD
WAS PASSED WOULD SEEM LIKE A
KANGAROO COURT IN MANY WAYS
BECAUSE THERE WERE HUNDREDS AND
HUNDREDS OF PEOPLE THERE TO
SPEAK.
BUT THE BILL HAVE FOUR AUTHORS
ON IT AND ALL OF THOSE FOR MOST
THAT FIVE BUT FOR THOSE
INDIVIDUALS ARE RIGHT ON THE
COMMITTEE.
THE ONLY FOUR VOTES TO PASS IT
SO THE DONE DEAL IN THE
COMMITTEE WAS NOT EVEN WORTH
HAVING CONVERSATION ABOUT.
BUT MY CONCERN IS FAIRLY SIMPLE
THIS IS -- THIS IS A SERIOUS
CONVERSATION.
THAT SHOULD BE HAPPENING.
IN THIS HOUSE.
AMONG A LOT OF PEOPLE AND NOT
JUST AMONG THE FEW A ONE
ORGANIZATION OF TWO
ORGANIZATIONS THAT DECIDE THEY
WANT TO DO SOMETHING ABOUT
CHARTER SCHOOLS.
THERE'S VERY LITTLE IN THIS TO
TALK ABOUT KIDS.
THE ONE PIECE THAT DOES TALK
ABOUT KIDS SAYS BUT IT WILL
REMOVE FROM THE CHARTER
LEGISLATION.
WOULD DELETE THE PROVISION
RELATING A AND I'M MAY I HAVE
PERMISSION TO READ THE BILL
OBVIOUSLY TO EVERYBODY.
WITHOUT OBJECTION THANK YOU IF
YOU LOOK AT PAGE NINETY FIVE
SAYS THIS BILL WILL DELETE THE
PROVISION RELATING TO INCREASES
IN PUPIL ACADEMIC ACHIEVEMENT.
AS THE MOST IMPORTANT FACTOR.
THE MOST IMPORTANT FACTOR IN
DETERMINING WHETHER TO REVOKE A
CHARTER.
THE BILL WOULD ALSO DELETE THE
PROVISION FOR APPEAL OF THE
REVOCATION OF A CHART ABOUT
CHARTERING AUTHORITY. FOR ME THE
MOST IMPORTANT THING WE SHOULD
BE TALKING ABOUT A STUDENT
PERFORMANCE.
THAT IS THE MOST IMPORTANT THING.
NOT ALL THE OTHER STUFF BUT MOST
IMPORTANT THAT BECAUSE THAT IS
WHAT IS IMPORTANT MY COMMUNITY.
AND WE CAN TALK ABOUT HOW
CHARTERS HAVE DONE WHATEVER THAT
WE THINK THEY'VE DONE TO THE TO
THE DISTRICTS.
BUT I CAN ALSO TELL YOU THAT
PRIOR TO CHARTERS COMING TO
EXISTENCE THAT WAS ALSO UNDER
PERFORMANCE IN THOSE COMMUNITIES.
THAT THAT WASN'T THIS GREAT
EXPERIENCE IN THE SCHOOLS BUT
MOST OF THE KIDS WERE IN INNER
CITIES.
AND SO IT IT MAKES IT SEEM LIKE
ALL OF A SUDDEN CHARTER COMES IN
THEN OBVIOUSLY THINGS HAPPENING
IN SCHOOLS THAT IS NOT THE CASE
AND WE KNOW THAT TO BE TRUE.
BECAUSE YOU ALL AROUND IN THE
NINETIES AND YOU KNOW WHAT
HAPPENED IN SCHOOLS IN THE
ISSUES OF UNDER PERFORMANCE WAS
STILL THERE.
I AM CONCERNED THAT THERE ARE A
LOT OF ISSUES THAT WE NEED TO
ADDRESS.
AND AS I STATE IN THE COMMISSION
THESE THESE RECOMMENDATIONS ARE
PREMATURE WHY WOULD YOU FORM A
TASK FORCE YOU WILL SAY GO AHEAD
AND WE CAN MAKE CHANGES AS WE GO
ALONG BUT WHY WOULD YOU FORM A
TASK FORCE.
WHOSE JOB IS TO ADDRESS THE
ISSUES OF CHARTERING AN
AUTHORIZATION AND FINANCES.
AND BRING TOGETHER PEOPLE FROM
CHARTERS FROM SCHOOL DISTRICT
FROM LEADERSHIP ALTHOUGH SO
TOGETHER TO LOOK AT THIS VERY
COMPLEX ISSUE.
WE TRY TO BE FAIR ABOUT IT AND
THEN WE ALSO LEGISLATION PUSH IT
FORWARD WITH THE IDEA THAT WE AS
A SOMETHING WILL HAPPEN IN THE
NEXT FEW MONTHS.
PUSH IT FORWARD.
SO THEN IT BECOMES EVEN MORE
DIFFICULT TO AMEND AND TO CHANGE.
AND WE ALL KNOW THAT.
AND THAT'S WHY THE EVIDENCE IS
IN HERE BECAUSE WE KNOW THAT
THIS THERE'S VERY LITTLE IN THIS
BILL THE TALKS ABOUT WHAT'S
GOING TO HAPPEN FOR KIDS IN
TERMS OF PERFORMANCE ACADEMIC
EXCELLENCE.
THOSE KINDS OF THINGS THAT ARE
THE MOST OF OUR COMMUNITIES ARE
CLAMORING FOR BETTER SCHOOLS.
AND WITH US TO COME IN AND
CREATE A PROCESS THAT ONE MAY
DID NOT THEM AN OPPORTUNITY
THERE SOME DISTRICTS TO DO VERY
GOOD JOB AND I SOMEHOW DON'T.
AND WE NEED TO BE AWARE OF THAT
IN TERMS OF THE BOARDS
THEMSELVES IN CHARTERING AND IF
THE MAIN REASON TO ACCEPT OR
DENY A CHARTER IS BASED ON HIS
FINANCIAL ISSUES WITH THE
CURRENT SCHOOL DISTRICTS.
MANY MANY OF OUR CHARTS WOULD
NEVER GET CHARTER.
BECAUSE OF THE FACT THAT IT
WOULD IS GOING TO IMPACT THE
ECONOMICS AS THEIR WE THOUGHT
CHARTERS WE'RE GOING TO INFORM
DISTRICTS ABOUT HOW TO BE BETTER.
AND INSTEAD THEY HAVE BECOME THE
ENEMY OF EACH OTHER.
AND WE NEED TO GET BACK TO THAT
BUT THISBILL WILL MAKE THEM
EVEN MORE ENEMIES.
BECAUSE I CHARTERS ARE CONCERNED
THAT THEY WERE NOT INCLUDED IN
THE CONVERSATION.
THEY'RE CONCERNED THAT THIS
WOULD MAKE IT MORE DIFFICULT FOR
THEM TO ACTUALLY GET A CHARTER
BECAUSE NOW THEY ONLY HAVE THE
BOARD TO DEAL WITH IN THE
POLITICS OF THE LOCAL BOARD TO
HAVING BEEN ON ONE BEFORE I KNOW
WHAT THEY ARE.
AND NO APPEAL PROCESS THAT
SOUNDS SO UNFAIR TO ME AND IN A
DEMOCRACY THAT YOU CAN MAKE A
DECISION AND I DON'T EVEN HAVE
AN OPPORTUNITY TO APPEAL TO A
HIGHER POWER. TO ANOTHER BOARD
WE HAVE A STATE BARD THAT'S
BEEN AUTHORIZED TO DO TO
BASICALLY HANDLE THE EDUCATION
OF THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
AND SO WITH WOOD WHAT CUTTING
OFF THOSE AVENUES AND MAKING IT
ONLY SO THAT THEY CAN ONLY GO
ONE WAY.
I THINK THIS IS PREMATURE.
I THINK THAT THE ISSUES ARE MUCH
MORE DIFFICULT AND COMPLEX AND
OUR CONSTITUENTS ARE TELLING US
THAT.
AND THAT WE ARE NOT PREPARED TO
MAKE THESE KINDS OF DECISIONS
ABSENCE OF A REPORT THAT COMES
OUT TO TELL US HOW ARE STE
WHAT'S GOING ON IN OUR CHARTERS
HOW TO BEST AUTHORIZES CHARTERS
WHAT KIND OF ISSUES NEED TO BE
THERE.
CERTAIN ASSUMPTIONS WE MAY WE
MADE ASSUMPTIONS IN HERE THAT
THE CHARGES ARE BREAKING THE
SCHOOLS FINANCIALLY WE MAY
DISCOVER THE REPORT THAT THAT'S
NOT TRUE.
THAT THAT IS NOT TRUE.
BECAUSE THEY'RE TAKING THE
CHILDREN OBVIOUSLY THEY NEED THE
RESOURCES TO WORK WITH THE KIDS.
JUST A LOT OF DIFFERENT THINGS
THAT WE ARE UNPREPARED TO ANSWER
AND TO RUSH THIS BILL THROUGH
EVEN HANG IT UP THE AND WHAT
WE'VE DONE EVERYTHING ELSE AND
ALL WAS A SURPRISE AND NOW IT'S
COMING FORWARD.
YOU KNOW THAT IN ITSELF IS
RATHER INTERESTING.
BUT MORE IMPORTANTLY WE ARE NOT
PREPARED TO MAKE THIS DECISION
AND I WOULD ARGUE I WOULD URGE
YOU NOT TO EITHER TO ABSTAIN
WHICH REALLY NOT TO VOTE FOR
THIS BILL AT THIS TIME BECAUSE
THERE'S MUCH MORE INFORMATION
NECESSARY.
AND WE TO INCLUDE MORE PEOPLE IN
THE CONVERSATION THANK YOU SO
VERY MUCH.
THANK GOD WEBER MISTRUST AN
OLDIE YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
COLLEAGUES I RISE IN RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION TO FIFTEEN OH FIVE
AND I'D LIKE TO RELATE A
PERSONAL STORY I DON'T THINK
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT ANYONE IN
THIS CHAMBER KNOWS ABOUT ME BUT
MY OLDEST SON.
HAD SOME SEVERE BEHAVIORAL
PROBLEMS WHEN HE WAS YOUNGER HE
WAS BORN WITH A ADVANCED
INTELLECTUAL CAPACITY IN A
DIMINISHED EMOTIONAL CAPACITY.
AND LIKE MANY GIFTED CHILDREN
THAT CAUSED HIM A LOT OF
PROBLEMS EARLY IN HIS LIFE.
WHEN IT CAME TIME TO SEND HIM TO
KINDERGARTEN?
WE HAD A REALLY STARK DECISION
TO MAKE BECAUSE SENDING HIM TO
SCHOOL WITH OTHER CHILDREN WOULD
HAVE REQUIRED MEDICATING HIM.
AND MY WIFE AND I WERE UNWILLING
TO DO THAT.
SO WE MADE THE CHOICE TO HOME
SCHOOL HIM BUT IT WAS A
DIFFICULT CHOICE BECAUSE I DON'T
HAVE A TEACHING CREDENTIAL I
DON'T.
THINK THAT I'M QUALIFIED TO
TEACH A CHILD.
YEAH MY WIFE FELT THE SAME WAY
SO WE HOME SCHOOLED WITH THE AID
OF A CHARTER SCHOOL AND WAS A
VIRTUAL ACADEMY IT TURNED OUT TO
BE PERFECT FOR US WE COULD GO
ONLINE EVERY DAY.
WE HAD A LESSON PLAN WE GOT
WEEKLY VISITS FROM A CERTIFIED
TEACHER WE PARTICIPATED IN
STANDARDIZED TESTING THEY GAVE
US THE CONFIDENCE THAT WE NEEDED.
TO BE ABLE TO DO THAT.
AND WHEN IT CAME TIME. FOR HIM
TO GO -- TO HIGH SCHOOL HE SAID
TO HIS HIS BEHAVIORAL PROBLEMS
HAD RESOLVED HE EXPRESSED.
A DESIRE TO GO TO PUBLIC HIGH
SCHOOL AND WE AGREED AND HE WENT
TO HIGH SCHOOL.
HE WENT ON HE GOT STRAIGHT IS
FROM HIS FIRST DAY THERE HE WAS
VALEDICTORIAN OF HIS CLASS.
I HE'S NOW CAL TECH.
HE'S GETTING STRAIGHT IS THERE
IS MAJORING IN COMPUTER SCIENCE
AND BUSINESS ECONOMICS YOU CAN
TELL I'M VERY PROUD OF HIM.
WE WOULD NOT HAVE BEEN ABLE TO
DO THAT.
WITHOUT THE AID OF THE CHARTER
SCHOOL THAT WE PARTICIPATED IN.
AND THAT'S ONE OF THE REASONS I
FEEL SO STRONGLY ABOUT THIS AND
THIS BILL ACTUALLY HAS A LOT OF
SUPPORTABLE THINGS AT IT I'M NOT
AGAINST.
HOLDING CHARTER SCHOOLS
ACCOUNTABLE I'M NOT AGAINST
SHUTTING DOWN CHARTER SCHOOLS
THAT FAIL THE CHILDREN THAT
THEY'RE SERVING I'M NOT AGAINST
CHAU SHUTTING DOWN CHARTER
SCHOOLS THAT FAIL TO ACHIEVE
HIGHER ACADEMIC RESULTS.
THAN -- OTHER SCHOOLS IN THE
PUBLIC SCHOOL SYSTEM BUT THERE
ARE A LOT OF KIDS FOR WHOM
CHARTER SCHOOLS ARE THE BEST
OPTIONS AND THERE ARE OTHER
THINGS IN THIS BILL OTHER
PROVISIONS.
THAT ARE CLEARLY INTENDED TO
LIMIT THE NUMBER OF CHARTER
SCHOOLS IN CALIFORNIA TO MAKE
SURE THAT CHARTER SCHOOLS DON'T
GET THEIR CHARTERS RENEWED AND A
LOT OF THE CHARTERS WILL BE SHUT
DOWN.
UNDER THIS BILL ARE THE GOOD
CHARTERS LIKE THE ONES THAT
HELPED ME AND MY FAMILY WHEN WE
WERE IN NEED TO SO I URGE YOU TO
VOTE NO.
ON FIFTEEN OH FIVE THANK YOU
METRO MILE T..
MR MEDINA YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS I RISE IN SUPPORT.
OF ASSEMBLY BILL.
FIFTEEN OH FIVE I VERY MUCH
AGREE WITH MY COLLEAGUE FROM LOS
ANGELES THE NINETEEN SIXTY EIGHT
AND THE CHICANO STUDENT WALKED
OUT.
IN EAST LA.
IS OF HISTORICAL SIGNIFICANCE.
AND IF THIS BODY CHOOSES AND THE
GOVERNOR SIGNS.
DOCTOR WEBER BILL TO TEACH
ETHNIC STUDIES AND COMMUNITY
COLLEGE AND MY BILL TO TEACH
ETHNIC STUDIES IN THE HIGH
SCHOOLS WILL MAKE SURE.
THAT STUDENTS LEARN ABOUT THAT
HISTORICAL OF THAT IN.
NINETEEN SIXTY EIGHT AND I KNOW
FOR A FACT THAT IT WAS TRUE.
THE BEFORE IN.
NINETEEN SIXTY EIGHT LATINO
STUDENTS IN CALIFORNIA
[inaudible]
WERE TRACKED.
AND MOST OF THEM WERE TRACKED.
IN THE IN.
NOT COLLEGE BOUND NINETEEN SIXTY
EIGHT I THINK THERE WERE LESS
THAN [inaudible] TEN COLLEGE
LATINO COLLEGE STUDENTS
ATTENDING UCLA.
YESTERDAY MONDAY WE CELEBRATED.
THE HUNDRED YEAR.
OF UCLA.
AND THE NUMBER OF LATINOS IT
UCLA TODAY.
IS MANY MANY TIMES MORE THAN IT
WAS IN.
NINETEEN SIXTY EIGHT BUT THE
STUDENTS THAT WALKED OUT IN.
NINETEEN SIXTY EIGHT WE'RE VERY
SIMILAR TO THE STUDENTS THAT
WALKED OUT IN LA UNIFIED
[inaudible]
THIS YEAR.
AND I WAS IN LA.
I WAS AT MADISON HIGH SCHOOL IN
LOS ANGELES.
AND WHEN I WALKED MARCHED AND
CHANTED WITH THE STUDENTS
PARENTS [inaudible]
AND TEACHERS.
OF UC OF OF OF LA UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT I WAS VERY MUCH
REMINDED.
OF THE WALKED OUT OF NINETEEN
SIXTY EIGHT AND I DO THINK THAT
WE ARE AT A JUNCTURE.
WHERE WE DO NEED TO DECIDE?
ARE WE OR ARE WE NOT GONNA
SUPPORT PUBLIC SCHOOLS.
THE HISTORY OF PUBLIC SCHOOLS IN
THIS NATION.
IS THIS A SYSTEM THAT SAID IT
WAS FOR EVERYONE.
BEFORE THE PUBLIC SCHOOLS IT WAS
ONLY THE FEW WHO WERE EDUCATED.
BUT THE PUBLIC SCHOOLS CAME
ABOUT IN THIS NATION WHEN
IMMIGRANTS.
WITH IMMIGRANTS.
CAME ONTO THE SHORES.
AND THE UNITED STATES NEW AND
RECOGNIZE THAT WE HAD TO EDUCATE
ALL.
AND THAT IS WHEN THE PUBLIC
SCHOOL STARTED IN THE UNITED
STATES.
SO WE NEED TO DECIDE
[inaudible]
TODAY.
WILL WE CONTINUE TO SUPPORT
PUBLIC EDUCATION.
I VERY MUCH AGREE.
THAT IT IS A DECISION THAT WE
HAVE TO MAKE AND THAT.
BEING NUMBER FORTY ONE IN THE
NATION.
IN FUNDING PUBLIC SCHOOLS AND
HAVING THE LARGEST CLASS SIZE
[inaudible]
PER TEACHER.
HAVING THE LESS.
AMOUNT OF COUNSELORS PER STUDENT.
IS NOT ACCEPTABLE.
AND WE SAW.
DURING THE LA UNIFIED.
TEACHERS STRIKE.
THAT CHARTERS DO DRAW UPON.
AND TAKE AWAY FROM PUBLIC
SCHOOLS AND WHAT BEGAN AS A
MODEL IS NOW BECOME AN INDUSTRY.
AN INDUSTRY THAT TAKES AWAY FROM
PUBLIC SCHOOLS I THINK IT IS
IMPORTANT THAT WE RECOGNIZE THAT
WHEN IT COMES TO EDUCATION.
DECISIONS ARE MADE BASS WHEN
THEY ARE CLOSE TO HOME THERE IS
NO BETTER ENTITY TO MAKE THE
DECISIONS THAT THE SCHOOL BOARD
AND I SAY THAT BOTH.
AS A TEACHER AND A PAST SCHOOL
BOARD MEMBER I URGE YOU TO VOTE
YES ON A. B..
FIFTEEN OH FIVE MS GONZALEZ YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED.
I'M GONNA START BY ADMITTING
THIS IS A TOUGH SUBJECT.
A LOT OF YOU KNOW OBVIOUSLY I
CAME FROM THE LABOR MOVEMENT.
I REPRESENTED -- TEACHERS.
I'M ALSO A CHARTER SCHOOL
PARENTS.
AND AND THAT'S NOT ALWAYS EASY
TO ADMIT.
THERE'S A CONFLICT THERE
[inaudible]
AND I COULD PROBABLY TELL YOU IN
DOUBT.
EVERYTHING GOOD OR BAD.
ABOUT MY KIDS SCHOOLS.
I SEE IT UP CLOSE.
I SEE THE FACT.
THAT MY KIDS GO TO A SCHOOL
DESPITE A DISTRICT THAT
OVERWHELMINGLY LATINO IN SPANISH
SPEAKING. TO A SCHOOL THAT I'VE
NEVER SEEN AN ENGLISH LEARNER AT
I'VE NEVER SEEN A SPECIAL ED
STUDENTS.
ON THE ONE HAND I COMPLETELY
AGREE WITH THE INNOVATION.
THAT SOME CHARTER SCHOOLS ARE
ENGAGING IN.
AND MY UNDERSTANDING OF THE
MOVEMENT IS IT WAS SUPPOSED TO
BE VERY LIMITED.
IN THAT WE WERE SUPPOSED TO TAKE
THAT INNOVATION AND SCALE IT.
SO THAT EVERY KID IN EVERY
PUBLIC SCHOOL WOULD HAVE THOSE
SAME OPPORTUNITIES.
MY KIDS ATTEND.
COOPERATIVE CHARTER SCHOOLS IT
DIDN'T START THAT WAY.
START WITH ONE OR TWO IT'S
CALLED HIGH TECH HIGH IT'S VERY
FAMOUS.
AND WHEN IT STARTED THERE WAS
NOTHING TO NOT LOVE ABOUT IT
BESIDES THE LACK OF DIVERSITY
WHICH HAS ALWAYS BOTHERED ME
IT'S SOMETHING THAT CAUSED MY
DAUGHTER.
BEING HALF BLACK AND HALF LATINA
TO PULL HERSELF.
OUT OF A CHARTER SCHOOL BECAUSE
SHE WAS SICK OF BEING PARADED
AROUND FOR AUTHORIZES AS IF SHE
WAS REPRESENTATIVE OF THE SCHOOL.
SHE SAID THIS IS AT AT TEN COULD
SAY THIS IS WRONG.
THEY WANT TO ACT LIKE THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT IT'S NOT IT'S NOT
SERVING STUDENTS LIKE ME.
MAYBE BECAUSE WORK HAVE A LITTLE
BIT MORE MONEY THAN THE PEOPLE
IN OUR DISTRICT BUT IT'S NOT.
AND SO BECAME THIS IDEA BUT NOW
EVEN A GRADE SCHOOL LIKE HIGH
TECH HIGH.
CONTINUES TO OPEN UP ANOTHER AND
ANOTHER AND ANOTHER SCHOOL.
SO SCHOOL THAT USED TO BE KIND
OF A NEIGHBORHOOD SERVING AREA
SCHOOL NOW HAS INTO ASSEMBLY
DISTRICTS AWAY ANOTHER HIGH
SCHOOL.
IT HAS FIVE OR SIX HIGH SCHOOLS.
TWO OR THREE ELEMENTARY SCHOOLS
FOUR MIDDLE SCHOOLS AND WHAT
HAPPENS IS THESE EACHERS WHO
PUT IN TIME AT A SCHOOL GET
MOVED AROUND FROM SCHOOL TO
SCHOOL.
SO YOUR BEST MOST QUALIFIED
TEACHERS ARE BEING MOVED OUT OF
WHAT USED TO BE A LITTLE GREAT
[inaudible]
BET.
OF OF OF EXPERIMENT.
OF TRYING THINGS AND MAKING THEM
WORK.
OF ACTUALLY CREATING A MARKET
PLACE OF THE TEACHERS WERE
PROVIDED.
A GOOD SALARY AND AND THE
INCENTIVE TO STAY THERE IS NOW
BEING DESTROYED BECAUSE AS THAT
GROWS.
THAT'S NOT BE PROVIDED WERE SEEN
IN OUR LOCAL ELEMENTARY SCHOOL
SITUATION BY WHICH TO TEACHERS.
TO TEACHERS WHO HAVE BEEN
LONGEST SERVING THERE AND HAVE
GREAT RECORDS THEY ARE THE STATE
THE TEACHERS WHO PROVIDE THE
MOST TO STUDENTS.
ARE ARE NOT BEING HAVING THEIR
CONTRACTS RENEWED BECAUSE THE
CHARTER SCHOOL.
HAS NO BASIS BY WHICH THEY KEEP
A TEACHER R. DON'T AND ONCE YOU
BECOME TOO EXPENSIVE.
YOU'RE EXPENDABLE.
THAT NOT ONLY HURTS THE TEACHER
BUT IT HURTS EVERY KID IN THAT
SCHOOL.
ALL I CAN SAY IS CHARTER SCHOOLS
ARE NOT ON ITS OWN.
A BAD IDEA I SUPPORT CHOI HAVING
SOME LIMITED CHARTER SCHOOLS.
I I I I HAVE ALWAYS TOLD THE
TEACHERS UNION THAT TO OPPOSE
ALL CHARTER SCHOOLS SEEM
COUNTERPRODUCTIVE.
THIS IS HOW THIS IS SOMETHING
THAT ALL TEACHERS SHOULD WANT TO
NOT HAVE TO ABIDE BY SOME STREET
CURRICULUM TO BE ABLE TO
EXPERIMENT. TO TO HAVE NEW LIVE
LEARNING STANDARDS FOR ALL KINDS
OF DIFFERENT KIDS BUT THAT'S NOT
WHAT'S HAPPENING ANYMORE.
AND WE'RE LEAVING BEHIND SO MANY
KIDS.
I DON'T KNOW HOW TO RECONCILE
THAT.
I'VE BEEN CALLED A HYPOCRITE AN
IN THAT'S I UNDERSTAND WHY
PEOPLE WOULD.
I'M NOT SAYING THIS CHARTER
SCHOOLS GOOD ENOUGH FOR MY KIDS
BUT NOBODY ELSE WHAT I'M SAYING
IS IT'S TIME TO PRESS PAUSE.
BRING PEOPLE TOGETHER FIGURE OUT
HOW WE GET BACK TO WHAT THIS
MOVEMENT WAS SUPPOSED TO BE.
HOW WE CONTINUE TO SUPPORT OUR
TRADITIONAL PUBLIC SCHOOLS WITH
THE IDEAS THAT ARE IN KEEPING IN
CHARTER SCHOOLS AND THAT WE
DON'T DECIMATE?
COMMUNITIES BY PULLING KIDS OUT
THE BEST IN THE BRIGHTEST OUT OF
OUR TRADITIONAL PUBLIC SCHOOLS
AND SENDING THEM SOMEWHERE ELSE
UNTIL THAT SCHOOL WANTS TO CLOSE
DOWN OR CHANGE THE WAY THAT
THEY'RE DOING THINGS.
I DON'T KNOW IF THIS IS THE
ANSWER I DON'T.
BUT I WANT ONE OF THESE BILLS TO
MOVE FORWARD BECAUSE I'M HOPEFUL
THAT THIS TASK FORCE WILL COME
UP WITH REALLY GOOD IDEAS AND WE
NEED A VEHICLE TO PUT THOSE
IDEAS THAN. THIRTY SECONDS I
HOPE TODAY THAT WE KEEP THIS
DISCUSSION GOING BY PASSING ONE
OF THESE BILLS.
I'M CHARTER SCHOOL PARENT WHO
WANTS TO BELIEVE IN THE FUTURE
WE WILL HAVE CHARTER SCHOOLS
THAT WORK HAND IN HAND WITH OUR
TRADITIONAL PUBLIC SCHOOLS IN A
VERY LIMITED WAY.
THE CONTINUE AND THAT WILL
PROTECT OUR TEACHERS AND I WANT
TO BE ABLE TO TALK TO MY LOCAL
SCHOOL BOARD ABOUT THAT.
BECAUSE I GUARANTEE YOU NOBODY
AT THE STATE BOARD.
REALLY CARES WHAT I THINK ABOUT
MY LOCAL CHARTER SCHOOL.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR MY VOTE.
MS QUIRK SILVA.
DIRECTNESS.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS.
MEMBERS WE ARE AT A CRISIS WE'RE
IN A CRISIS IN EDUCATION SO
TODAY'S DISCUSSION IN THIS BILL
PERTAINS TO CHARTER SCHOOLS AND
WITH.
OUR PUBLIC EDUCATION BUT THERE
ARE SO MANY CRISIS IS AN
EDUCATION WE CAN ALL OF US STAND
HERE ALL DAY LONG AND TALK ABOUT
THE GOOD THINGS THE BAD THINGS
AND REALLY THE DESTRUCTIVE
THINGS.
LAST NIGHT I HAD AN OPPORTUNITY
TO SEE A DOCUMENTARY THAT WAS
PUT ON BY THE FIRST PARTNER --
JENNIFER.
NEWSOM.
THE GREAT AMERICAN LIE.
AND THIS DOCUMENTARY FOCUSED UP
IN ALL OAKLAND.
AND IT SHOWED SOME PART OF
PUBLIC SCHOOL JUNIOR HIGH
STUDENTS AND WHAT THEY WERE
GOING THROUGH EVERY SINGLE DAY --
AND THAT WAS JUST ONE OF THE
SCHOOLS BUT THE MESSAGES ARE
FAILING STUDENTS AS A PUBLIC
SCHOOL TEACHER MYSELF FOR THIRTY
YEARS.
I HAVE SEEN THE MOST BEAUTIFUL
TEACHERS THAT ARE DEDICATED THAT
IT YOU WOULD WANT YOUR CHILD TO
HAVE WHO HAVE.
DEVOTED THEIR TIME SPENT EXTRA
HOURS ON THE WEEKENDS AND NIGHTS
BUT I'VE ALSO SEEN THE SCHOOLS.
PUBLIC SCHOOLS THAT OFFER EVEN
SCHOOL CHOICE IN THEIR SCHOOLS
PARENTS TAKE THEIR KIDS IN MY
CITY TO WHAT WE CALL THE HILL
SCHOOLS AND THE FLAT LAND
SCHOOLS ARE HAVING LINES WITH
PARENTS PULLING THEM OUT.
AND THESE ARE PUBLIC SCHOOLS.
AND SO WHAT WE CREATE EVEN IN
OUR PUBLIC SCHOOLS ARE THE HAVES
AND THE HAVE NOTS THE PARENTS
THAT CAN PROVIDE TRANSPORTATION
HAVE ACCESS TO MOVE THEIR KIDS.
THEY MOVE THEM AND WHAT HAPPENS
IS MANY OF OUR TITLE ONE SCHOOLS
ARE LEFT WITH THE LEAST
QUALIFIED TEACHERS WITH PARENTS
NOT BEING ABLE TO ADVOCATE AND
THAT DOESN'T EVEN DISCUSS THE
CHARTER SCHOOLS.
AND AGAIN CHARTER SCHOOLS ARE
INNOVATIVE THEY CAN BE VERY
SUCCESSFUL IN SOME OF THE
OPPOSITE SO WHERE ARE WE TODAY
MAKING A DECISION ON ARE WE
GOING TO MOVE FORWARD WITH THAT
CONVERSATION OR WE GONNA STAND
STILL.
OR GO BACKWARDS AND TO BE HONEST
ALL RIGHT TO THE AUTHOR.
MADE A COMMITMENT LAST WEEK WHEN
TALKING TO HIM.
UP AND TO SEE T. A. WHICH IS AN
ORGANIZATION I'VE BEEN INVOLVED
WITH FOR THIRTY YEARS BUT I AM
CONFLICTED IN SO TODAY I WILL
GIVE MY VOTE. TO MOVE FORWARD
BUT I URGE US TO CONTINUE THIS
CRITICAL CONVERSATION BECAUSE WE
ARE FAILING STUDENTS WE HAVE
FOURTEEN HUNDRED EMPLOYEES AT
THE DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION.
I WANT TO KNOW I DON'T CARE
ABOUT THE REPORTS IN THE LC FF I
CARE ABOUT WHAT'S HAPPENING IN
THE CLASSROOM BECAUSE I
GUARANTEE YOU. FOR THIRTY YEARS
OF TEACHING I SAT WHAT THE
BETWEEN THIRTY AND THIRTY FIVE
STUDENTS WITH NO EXTRA HELP NO
MATTER HOW MUCH MONEY WE PUT
INTO THE SCHOOLS MULTIPLE
LANGUAGES SPECIAL ADD.
IN MY CLASS WITH MAYBE A A
SPECIAL ED TEACHER COMING IN FOR
THIRTY MINUTES I HAD TO PUT UP A
BOARD TO SHOW HOW MANY KIDS WERE
COMING IN AND OUT IN AND OUT.
BECAUSE WE DON'T HAVE THE
PROFESSIONALS THEY ARE TO BE IN
THE CLASS WITH US THERE'S SO
MUCH THAT I CAN SAY MEMBERS BUT
WHETHER IT'S PUBLIC SCHOOL
WHETHER IT'S CHARTER SCHOOLS WE
HAVE TO BE BETTER WE CANNOT
CONTINUE. TO PUT KIDS IN UP
PLACES AND I DON'T CARE IF IT'S
CHARTER OR PUBLIC WHERE THEY'RE
NOT SUPPORTED.
PARENTS ARE TRYING TO DO THEIR
BEST BY WORKING JOBS AND THE
LEAST THAT WE SHOULD EXPECT IS
THAT OUR KIDS CAN GO TO SCHOOL
AND A SAFE PLACE AND THAT THEY
CAN LEARN.
THAT'S WHAT EDUCATION ABOUT IT'S
ABOUT LEARNING LEARNING TO WRITE
TO READ A PLACE WHERE THEY CAN
LEARN ABOUT LITERATURE AND
HISTORY AND CHARACTERS AND WE
POLITICIZE THIS AND WE HAVE.
THIS WAR BETWEEN CHARTERS AND
PUBLIC SCHOOL WE'RE MAKING IT
WORSE SO TODAY I WILL SUPPORT
THIS BILL.
BUT WITH GREAT CONCERN AND I ASK
OUR MEMBERS TO CONTINUE THIS
DIALOGUE AND BRING THESE PEOPLE
TOGETHER PARENTS TEACHERS AND
LOCAL SCHOOL BOARDS BECAUSE
UNLESS WE WORK TOGETHER WE
CONTINUE THIS GREAT DIVIDE.
AND THAT MOVIE LAST NIGHT
DOCUMENTARY A GREAT LIFE I ASKED.
I URGE YOU TO SEE IT BECAUSE IT
TALKS ABOUT THE FOUNDATION OF
OUR COUNTRY BEING TORN APART.
THERE WAS QUIRK SILVA MS
KAMLAGER-DOVE.
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU AYE AYE RISE.
IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL I WILL
BE SUPPORTING IT WITH
TREPIDATION BUT ALSO WITH SOME
FAITH AND HOPE.
THAT WE WILL USE THE POLITICAL
COURAGE AND ANGER THAT IS ON
THIS FLOOR TO MAKE A COMMITMENT
TO FIX OUR FAILING PUBLIC.
SCHOOL EDUCATION SYSTEM.
WE ARE POLITICIZING OUR KIDS AND
WE ARE POLITICIZING THEIR FUTURE.
BY DEMONIZING CHARTERS AND
VICTIMIZING PUBLIC SCHOOLS.
THERE ARE GOOD AND BAD ACTORS
ACROSS THE SPECTRUM.
WE SHOULD BE HAVING A
CONVERSATION ABOUT FULLY FUNDING
OUR PUBLIC SCHOOL EDUCATION
ABOUT RETOOLING PROP.
NINETY EIGHT ABOUT TALKING ABOUT
THE FACT THAT MANY OF OUR SCHOOL
DISTRICTS ARE LANDLORDS PROPERTY
OWNERS WITH UNDER IN ROLLED
SCHOOLS.
BECAUSE PARENTS ARE USING THEIR
CHOICE TO PUT THEIR KIDS
SOMEPLACE ELSE.
I'M A STEP MOTHER OF TWO KIDS IN
A PUBLIC IN PUBLIC SCHOOLS I AM
COMMITTED TO PUBLIC SCHOOLS.
WHEN WE TALK ABOUT WHERE OUR
KIDS ARE GOING TO GO WE'RE
LOOKING AT THE TEACHERS AND
WE'RE LOOKING AT THE SAFETY?
ALL OF THOSE SCHOOLS WE'RE NOT
LOOKING ABOUT THE CAFETERIA THE
LANDSCAPING OR ANY OF THAT.
AND WHEN THOSE TWO THINGS ARE IN
FLUX ARE IN CRISIS WE HAVE A
RESPONSIBILITY AND AN OBLIGATION
TO FIND CHOICE SO THAT WE MAKE
SURE THAT WE ARE PROTECTING OUR
KIDS.
SO WHY DON'T WE TALK ABOUT HOW
WE'RE FUNDING OUR PUBLIC SCHOOL
EDUCATION.
WHY DON'T WE TALK ABOUT THE FACT
THAT BECAUSE OF BUSING BECAUSE
WHITE FOLKS TOOK THEIR KIDS OUT
OF PUBLIC SCHOOLS BECAUSE WE
PASSED PROP THIRTEEN THAT WE RE
DIRECTED FUNDING AND COMMITMENT?
AWAY FROM OUR PUBLIC SCHOOL
SYSTEM WHY DON'T WE TALK ABOUT
THAT.
BECAUSE MOST FOLKS DON'T WANT TO
WORK FIVE JOBS. TO AFFORD
PRIVATE TUITION.
BECAUSE THEY DON'T HAVE A PUBLIC
SCHOOL IN THEIR NEIGHBORHOOD TO
TAKE THEIR LET'S KEEP IT REAL.
SO I'M VOTING TO MOVE THIS BILL
FORWARD.
BUT IN THAT VOTE IS A VOTE TO
REALLY TALK ABOUT WHAT WE WANT
FOR THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND
FOR OUR KIDS RICH KIDS POOR KIDS
MIDDLE CLASS KIDS WHO ALL
DESERVE THE RIGHT. TO BE ABLE TO
TAKE THEIR CHILD TO A PUBLIC
SCHOOL IN THEIR NEIGHBORHOOD AND
AND KNOW THAT THEIR CHILD WILL
BE SAFE.
MS MELENDEZ YOUR RECOGNIZE.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I KNOW
WE HAVE A A WHOLE PACKAGE OF
BILLS COMING FORWARD TO ADDRESS
CHARTER SCHOOLS AND WE HAD.
A LOT OF PERSONAL CONVERSATIONS
ON THIS FLOOR ABOUT HOW CHARTER
SCHOOLS HAVE AFFECTED --
SOMEONE'S LIFE HOW PUBLIC
SCHOOLS HAVE AFFECTED SOMEONE'S
LIFE AND THAT'S GREAT BECAUSE
THERE'S ROOM FOR ALL
[inaudible]
BUT LET'S REMEMBER THE FACT THAT
THERE ARE.
IT'S NOT A ONE SIZE FITS ALL.
AND I CAN'T TELL YOU HOW MANY
EMAILS I'VE RECEIVED AND I KNOW
YOU RECEIVE THEM.
TO ABOUT PARENTS WHO SAY THE
PUBLIC SCHOOL IN MY NEIGHBORHOOD
WASN'T THE RIGHT FIT FOR MY
CHILD.
OR THE PUBLIC SCOOL IN MY
NEIGHBORHOOD WAS FAILING.
THE KIDS WHO ATTEND THERE.
WE HAVE A MORE THAN HALF OF
AFRICAN AMERICAN YOUNG BOYS YOU
DON'T READ AT GRADE LEVEL IN
pTHAT IS A FAILURE.
WE HEARD THE CONVERSATION
EARLIER ABOUT WHERE CALIFORNIA
RANKS WITH RESPECT TO EDUCATION
OUR LEVEL OF SUCCESS.
THIS FUNDING HAS GONE LIKE THIS
IF YOU LOOK AT THE GRAPH FUNDING
IS GONE UP THE LEAD LOOKS OF
SUCCESS HIS PAID FLAT.
THAT'S NOT SUCCESS IN MY EYES I
DON'T THINK IT IS YOURS EITHER.
BUT TO DENY PARENTS AND CHILDREN.
THE OPTION TO PUT THEIR CHILD IN
A SCHOOL THAT BEST SUITS THEM
WHETHER IT'S THEIR ACADEMIC
NEEDS WHETHER IT'S THEIR
BEHAVIORAL NEEDS.
IT'S NOT OUR PLACE TO TO STAND
BETWEEN THE PARENT AND CHILD AND
THEIR EDUCATION BECAUSE YOU ONLY
GET TO DO IT ONCE THERE'S NO
GOING BACK.
THERE NO DO OCCURS SO I DON'T
KNOW WHY WE HAVE TO HAVE THIS
BATTLE BETWEEN THE PUBLIC
SCHOOLS IN THE CHARTER SCHOOLS.
I I UNDERSTAND THE POLITICAL
SIDE OF IT BUT FROM A PARENT'S
PERSPECTIVE MY GOODNESS ARE SO
MANY PEOPLE IN HERE.
WHO ARE PARENTS MANY OF YOU NOW
THANKFULLY IT'S A DIFFERENT
LEGISLATURE IN THE MAKE UP IS
YOUNGER AND YOU HAVE YOUNG KIDS
AND WE HAD KIDS STILL IN SCHOOL?
SO.
I WOULD THINK THIS IS VERY
PRESSING ON YOUR MIND.
THE FACT THAT THIS THAT THE
EDUCATION YOUR KIDS ARE ABLE TO
GET OR NOT ABLE TO GET.
IT'S SOMETHING YOU ONLY GET TO
DO ONCE.
THIS IS NOT A BATTLE BETWEEN
PUBLIC SCHOOL IN CHARTER SCHOOL
THIS IS A BATTLE FOR YOUR KIDS
EDUCATION.
I WOULD URGE YOU KNOW ABOUT.
THANK YOU MISS MELENDEZ DOCTOR
EGGMAN.
YOUR RECOGNIZED.
I THINK IT WAS SPEAKER MEMBERS --
I ALSO DID NOT PLAN TO SPEAK ON
THIS BILL TODAY BUT MOSTLY
BECAUSE I DID KNOW WAS ECONOMY
COMING UP TODAY -- AND SO I I I
DO ALSO TAKE OFFENSE TO IT A
COMING UP AT THE VERY LAST
MINUTE WHEN PEOPLE AREN'T QUITE
SURE AND THEN ALL OF A SUDDEN
HERE IT IS.
AND LIKE ALL OF YOU I HAVE GOOD
CHARTERS AND I HAVE NOT SO GOOD
CHARTERS.
AND I ALSO LIVE WHERE I
PERSONALLY LIVE IN MY DISTRICT
IS A HIGH POVERTY AREA.
IT IS ONE OF THE HIGHEST POVERTY
AREAS IN MY CITY.
AND ITS PEOPLE KNOW WHEN I MOVED%
THERE I DIDN'T HAVE A CHILD
[inaudible]
AND NGUYEN KINDERGARTEN BEGAN
ALL OF A SUDDEN I HAD A CHILD
AND SO I HAD TO MAKE SOME
DECISIONS ABOUT WHAT I WAS GONNA
DO I AM A PRODUCT OF PUBLIC
EDUCATION.
K. THROUGH TWELVE ALL THE WAY UP
TO PHD ARE GOING TO PUBLIC
SCHOOLS AND I'M A GIANT
SUPPORTER IN PUBLIC SCHOOLS --
NGUYEN AND I WAS LUCKY ENOUGH TO
GET MY CHILD INTO A MAGNET.
THAT IS VERY CLOSE TO MY HOUSE
THAT IS A MAGNET AT ANOTHER
PUBLIC SCHOOL.
SHE'S NOW GRADUATING WITH A
CAUGHT NOW PROMOTING A FIFTH
GRADE.
HER NEXT STEP IS TO FOR HER TO
CONTINUE IN THAT MAGNET.
SHE'S A TEN YEAR OLD IS A CENTER
TO A COMPREHENSIVE HIGH SCHOOL
ACROSS TOWN.
BECAUSE THAT'S WHERE THE MIDDLE
YEARS ACADEMY AS THAT DOESN'T
FEEL LIKE A GOOD OPTION TO ME.
MY TO PUBLIC SCHOOLS WITHIN IN
MY AREA.
HAVE SOME OF THE LOWEST TEST
SCORES IN THE COUNTY.
I DON'T THINK THAT'S AN OPTION
FOR ME.
SO I THEN AM BASED WIT THE
ISSUE DO I SEND MY KID TO A
PRIVATE SCHOOL DO I SEND MY KID
TO A PAROCHIAL DO I SEND MY KID
TO A CHARTER.
AND NONE OF THOSE ARE EASY
DECISIONS.
I WANT LIKE EVERYBODY WANTS
EVERY PUBLIC SCHOOL WE HAVE TO
BE FULLY FUNDED SO WE DON'T HAVE
TO HAVE THESE CONVERSATIONS.
BUT THE KID SHOULDN'T BE THE
ONES PUT IN THE MIDDLE AND THE
PARENTS SHOULDN'T BE THE ONE TO
PUT IN THE MIDDLE.
LIVING AN INCREDIBLY DIVERSE
PLACE I CAN TELL YOU UNLIKE
OTHER PEOPLE OF SPOKE THE
CHARTER SCHOOL THAT I GO AND SEE
ARE INCREDIBLY DIVERSE MOSTLY
BROWN AND BLACK KIDS.
WHO ARE WHO ARE THERE ATTENDING
AND MANY DOING VERY WELL?
MY COLLEAGUE FROM SAN DIEGO I
ECHO THE THE THAT WE'RE NOT
TALKING ABOUT THE QUALITY OF THE
SCHOOLS WERE NOT TALKING A
STUDENT OUTCOMES.
I AM ALSO PREPARE FOR THIS
CONVERSATION GO FORWARD BUT I
WOULD LIKE SOME REAL I ALSO
THINK THAT WE'RE GOING TO ASK
FOR DATA WE'VE GOT TASK FORCE
GOING ON FOR US TO BE.
DOING THIS VERY QUICKLY COULD
PUT AN URGENCY CLOSET DO THIS
LATER.
IS ALSO A LITTLE.
DISINGENUOUS.
BUT I THINK THE CONVERSATION
SHOULD CONTINUE AND I WANT TO
HEAR.
AND IF YOU'RE GONNA TAKE
AMENDMENTS ON THE SIDE HAT
MEANS GOT TO COME BACK HERE FOR
CONCURRENCE.
I THINK WE ALL WANT AN APPEAL
PROCESS THAT IS FAIR.
I ALSO HAVE A DISTRICT THAT HAS
AN INCREDIBLE AMOUNT OF WHITE
FLIGHT I HAVE FIVE SCHOOL
DISTRICTS REPRESENTING ONE CITY.
LET ALONE THE COUNTY.
SO IN LESS THERE'S A GOOD
PROCESS.
FORD FOR SCHOOL TO BE ABLE TO
APPEAL THE PROCESS OF EITHER RE
CHARTERING OR NEW CHARTER TO THE
COUNTY BOARD OF EDUCATION.
I THINK IS A FLOP WE'RE GONNA
TALK ABOUT LOCAL CONTROL IS
REALLY TALK ABOUT IT IN A MORE
COMPREHENSIVE WAY.
I LOOK FORWARD TO THE CALL.
CONVERSATION CONTINUING AND A
COMMITMENT FROM THE AUTHOR.
THANK YOU DOCTOR EGGMAN THANK
YOU MEMBERS MR O'DONNELL.
YOU MAY CLOSE YES I THINK YOU
MISTER.
SPEAKER AND I APPRECIATE THE
CONVERSATION HERE AND AGAIN I
DON'T WANT THIS TO BE A
CONVERSATION ABOUT CHARTERS ARE
BAD.
CHARTER GOOD CHARTERS ARE PUBLIC
SCHOOLS SO THIS IS REALLY ABOUT
SUPPORTING ALL CALIFORNIA'S
STUDENTS AND ALL PUBLIC SCHOOLS
IN CALIFORNIA.
THE QUESTION HERE TODAY IS NOT
OUR CHARTERS BAD AND THAT'S WHAT
YOU'RE VOTE MEANS NOT AT ALL NOT
AT ALL.
IT IS MUCH MORE COMPLEX THAN
THAT AND I JUST WANNA SPEAK TO
MY MY COLLEAGUE FROM FRESNO
BROUGHT UP THAT HE HAD A LOCAL
BOARD THAT EITHER ATTEMPTED TO
OUR DID SHUT A HIGH PERFORMING
CHARTER SCHOOL DOWN.
FOR THE LEGAL SHOULD THIS BILL
PASS THAT IS NOT THE INTENT HERE
AND I DO WANT. TO RE RE ITERATE.
AND I THINK I'VE DONE IT A
COUPLE TIMES HERE THAT I AM
COMMITTED TO DISCUSSING AND
AMENDING THE RE AUTHORIZATION
AUTHORIZATION PROCESS AND MAKING
IT.
FAIR I KNOW MY COLLEAGUE FROM
STOCKTON SAYS SHE WANTS IT FAIR
OKAY YEARS I'M LOOKING AT YOU
RIGHT NOW I'M SAYING THE WORD
FAIR.
OKAY I UNDERSTAND THAT AND I
ALSO WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE MY
COLLEAGUE FROM LOS ANGELES WHO
BROUGHT UP THERE ARE MANY HIGH
PERFORMING.
CHARTER SCHOOLS ACROSS THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA I ABSOLUTELY
CONCUR IN FACT ONE OF MY OWN
FAMILY MEMBERS.
HAS ATTENDED A CHARTER SCHOOL
AND WHY AS MICE MY COLLEAGUE
FROM STAMMERED YOU KNOW BROUGHT
UP.
IT WAS THE BEST FIT AND HAVE A
CHARTER SCHOOL WORKS FOR YOU YOU
SHOULD SEND YOUR CHILD THERE.
BUT THAT'S NOT WHAT THIS BILL IS
ABOUT THIS BILL IS ABOUT.
RE LOOKING AT THE AUTHORIZATION
AND RE AUTHORIZATION PROCESS SO
WITH THAT -- I I APPRECIATE THE
CONVERSATION A VERY SIMPLY.
I ASKED FOR AN AYE VOTE TODAY IS
THE START OF THE CONVERSATION
NOT THE END OF THE CONVERSATION
WE WILL HAVE MANY MORE
CONVERSATION WAS STAKEHOLDERS WE
HAVE THE SUPERINTENDENT'S --
TASK FORCE OUT THERE THAT'S
GOING TO FURTHER INFORM THIS
BILL AGAIN MISTER SPEAKER I ASK
FOR AN IPHONE.
THANK YOU MISTER O'DONNELL AND
WITHOUT THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS OF THE DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE
.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DECIDE ABOUT
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF A
TAKES
FORTY ONE IS THAT OF A
ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF A
DESIRE
TO VOTE
[inaudible]
MR DONALD.
WHAT IS YOUR PLEASURE SIR?
MISTER SPEAKER I MOVE THE CALL
MISTER O'DONNELL MOVES A CALL
[inaudible]
MEMBERS WE NO CHANGES AT THIS
TIME [inaudible]
MR HOLDEN.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER ON FILE
ITEM ONE SIXTY FOUR A. B. SIX
THIRTY FIVE BIGELOW -- HOLDEN NO
TO I'D.
THE CHANGE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
HOLDEN ASSEMBLY WILL SIX THIRTY
FIVE NO TÁI [inaudible]
IS PETRIE-NORRIS.
FILE ITEM SEVENTY FIVE AB SIXTY
EIGHT I IT'S NOT VOTING.
VOTE CHANGE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
PETRIE-NORRIS ASSEMBLY BILL
SIXTY EIGHT I IT'S NOT VOTING.
FILE ITEM TWENTY TWO AB FOURTEEN
SEVENTY EIGHT I TO NOT VOTING.
THE CHANGE ASSEMBLY ARE
PETRIE-NORRIS IS ONLY ABLE
FOURTEEN SEVENTY EIGHT I TO NOT
VOTING [inaudible]
MR LEVINE.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AB
SEVENTY FOUR I TO NOW.
THE CHANGE ASSEMBLYMEMBER LEVINE
ASSEMBLY BILL SEVENTY FOUR I TO
KNOW
MEMBERS I AM PREPARED TO
LIFT THE CALL.
ON FILE ITEM.
TO NINETY FOUR A. B. FIFTEEN OH
FIVE THE CLERK WILL POST.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO WISH TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE
.
MR O'DONNELL MOVES A CALL.
MR REPLACES THE CALL
[inaudible]
CORRECTION
.
MEMBERS WE CAN.
TAKE ADDITIONAL VOTE CHANGES AS
NEEDED MR GABRIEL.
AB TWO THIRTY FIVE I DID NOT
VOTING.
WELL CHANGE GABRIEL SOME WITH
BILL TO THIRTY FIVE I TO NOT
LOADING [inaudible]
MR BERMAN.
YOU.
ARE RECOGNIZED FOR VOTE CHANGE.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AB TWO
THIRTY FIVE I DID NOT VOTING.
VOTE CHANGE BERMAN ASSEMBLY BILL
TWO THIRTY FIVE I TO NOT VOTING
.
MEMBER CENTER TEN AT BUDGET
SUBCOMMITTEE.
FOUR IS GOING TO BE MEETING IN
THE RULES COMMITTEE ROOM
[inaudible]
IMMEDIATELY.
MISTER COOPER IS THAT RIGHT NOW
AS OPPOSED TO UPON A GERMAN.
MEMBERS RULES APARTMENT --
BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE NUMBER FOUR
MEETING THE RULES COMMITTEE ROOM
[inaudible]
BEGINNING IMMEDIATELY
YEAH [inaudible]
MEMBERS.
ACTION BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE FOUR
WILL BE MEETING UPON A GERMAN.
THAT'S A CORRECTION BUDGET
SUBCOMMITTEE FOUR MEETS UPON
ADJOURNMENT OF SESSION WHICH
WILL HAPPEN.
AT SOME POINT
[inaudible]
MR O'DONNELL FOR WHAT PURPOSE
YOU RISE SIR.
YOU MISTER SPEAKER FOR YOUR
PATIENCE AND ALL MEMBERS FOR
THEIR PATIENTS -- I JUST WANT TO
CLARIFY I THOUGHT I SAID IT
BEFORE BUT I I THINK I NEED TO
CLARIFY ONE MORE TIME.
THAT THIS BILL AB FIFTEEN OH
FIVE WILL BE AMENDED TO FURTHER
ADDRESS -- THE APPEALS PROCESS
THERE NEEDS TO BE AN APPEALS
PROSSER NEEDS TO BE DUE PROCESS.
BUILT INTO THIS BILL AND IT ALSO
NEEDS TO BE FAIR.
SO WITH THAT I TURN IT BACK TO
YOU MISTER SPEAKER.
MEMBERS I AM PREPARED TO LIFT
THE CALL ON FILE ITEM TO NINETY
FOUR AB FIFTEEN OH FIVE THE
CLERK WILL POST.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE THE CLERK WILL.
CLOSE THE ROLE.
AND TALLY THE VOTE.
AYE AYES [inaudible]
FORTY TWO KNOWS.
NINETEEN THAT MEASURE PASSES
[inaudible]
PLEASE REFRAIN.
WE HAVE ORDER IN THE CHAMBER.
ALL OTHER ITEMS REMAINING WE
PASS RETAIN ALL MOTIONS SHALL BE
CONTINUED.
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
BUSINESS I'M READY TO ENTERTAIN
A MOTION TO ADJOURN.
MISTER CALDERON MOVES AND MISS
WALDRON SECONDS THAT THIS HOUSE
STANDS ADJOURNED UNTIL.
THURSDAY MAY TWENTY THIRD AT TEN
AM AND A QUORUM CALL IS LIFTED